THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE GALLERY. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE. FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR SIX
SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. FOR
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU. A
LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE UN MUTED. AND YOU WILL
BE READY TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANTTHAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THIS HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS. MUTED WE
HAVE SIXTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA AT THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST
ONE MEASURE HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM THE AGENDA FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. SENATE BILL NINE TWO ZERO.
THERE IS ONE BILL PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SENATE BILL TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. WE WILL ESTABLISH
A QUORUM WHEN WE HAVE MEMBERS
PRESENT ON THE FLOOR. IN THE
INTERIM WE WILL MOVE FORWARD AND
ACT AS A SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
BILLS WE HAVE THE PRO TEM CENTER
ATKINS WITH THIS APPROACH HIM
YOU HAVE ONE BILL BEFORE US
TODAY SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING AS I PERCENT SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. AND TO START I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL I READ THE
ANALYSIS WITH GREAT INTEREST.
AND I SO APPRECIATE YOUR
APPROACH AND YOUR SUGGESTIONS.
SHOULD SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
ADVANCE TODAY I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THE POLICY
CONSIDERATION MENTIONED.
SPECIFICALLY ON PAGE TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS RELATING TO REDUCING.
ABORTION TRAINING BARRIERS AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TRANSITION
TO PRACTICE. IF YOU ASK ME
THIRTY YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS
MANAGING A COMMUNITY CLINIC-
SERVICES AT A WOMEN'S HEALTH
CENTER. IF I'D STILL BE TALKING
ABOUT DEFENDING ROE VERSUS WADE
AND FIGHTING FOR ABORTION ACCESS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I WOULD
HAVE SAID I CERTAINLY HOPE NOT.
BUT HERE WE ARE. IN STATE HOUSES
IN COURTHOUSES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ALL THEWAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT ARE REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS ARE BEING STOLEN FROM US.
ONCE AGAIN WOMEN ARE BEING
PUSHED TO EXTREME MEASURES TO
ACCESS ABORTION CARE. AND ONCE
AGAIN THEY FACE HAVING TO PUT
THEIR BODIES IN DANGER. AND
THAT'S WHY WE FIND OURSELVES YET
AGAIN IN A POSITION OF DEFENSE.
NO I LEARNED A LONG TIME AGO ON
THE BASKETBALL COURT THE BEST
DEFENSE IS A GOOD OFFENSE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
BY GIVING MORE TRAINED AND
QUALIFIED NURSE PRACTITIONERS
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE ABORTIONS
WITHOUT THE SUPERVISION OF A
DOCTOR. SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
IS A PROACTIVE STEP TO FURTHER
INCREASE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
QUALITY REPRODUCTIVE CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR STATE IS FACING
A SERIOUS SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY
CARE CLINICIANS. ESPECIALLY IN
THE LATINO BLACK AND NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES A PROBLEM
THAT'S EXPECTED TO GET EVEN MORE
DIRE OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
CURRENTLY OVER 40% OF COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA DON'T EVEN HAVE
CLINICS OR PROVIDERS THAT
PROVIDE ABORTION. THOSE TWO
FACTORS COMBINED ME THAT FAR TOO
MANY PREGNANT PEOPLE WHO MAY
NEED TO CONSIDER ABORTION AS AN
OPTION CAN I DO SO. SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD OFFER THAT
OPTION TO MORE WOMEN AND
FAMILIES. CALIFORNIA HAS LONG
BEEN A LEADER IN REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS. BUT THE PRACTICAL NEED
TO ENSURE REAL ACCESS IS FAR
FROM DONE. ONE EARLY STEP I TOOK
WAS OFFERING AB ONE FIFTY FOUR
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN TO EXPAND THE
TYPES OF HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
WHO CAN PERFORM FIRST TERM
ABORTIONS WITH THE SUPERVISION
OF A DOCTOR TO INCLUDE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. IN SEVEN YEARS
LATER THE LEGISLATURE PASSED AB
EIGHT NINETY AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AND IT
CREATED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
QUALIFYING NURSE PRACTITIONERS
THE CARE FOR PATIENTS WITHOUT
THE SUPERVISION OF A DOCTOR. AND
NOW WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THOSE
LAWS CAN WORK TOGETHER IN
UNISON. SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD MAKE IT CLEAR THAT NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WHO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY CAN ALSO PROVIDE
FIRST TERM ABORTIONS WITHOUT A
PHYSICIAN'S SUPERVISION. THE
BILL ALSO CLARIFIED THAT AMONG
OTHER CRITERIA NURSE
PRACTITIONERS NEED THREE YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE UNDER A PHYSICIAN
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY. NURSE
PRACTITIONERS PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN PROVIDING REPRODUCTIVE
CARE. ALLOWING EXPERIENCED PART
NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO UTILIZE
THEIR FULL TRAINING AND
EDUCATION WILL EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF QUALIFIED REPRODUCTIVE CARE
PRACTITIONERS. PARTICULARLY IN
AREAS LACKING ACCESS TO CARE. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BILLS OFF
OF THE SUCCESS OF THESE TWO
PRIOR LEGISLATION ON BILLS TO
FURTHER STRENGTHEN AND EXPAND
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE CARE
WHILE ALSO LIFTING UP A
WORKFORCE OF SKILLED NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND GIVING THEM
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO CARE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. WHILE TIME SEEMS
TO BE MOVING BACKWARDS I THINK
IN MANY PLACES ACROSS THE NATION
THIS BILL WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD- TO
TESTIFY MISTER CHAIRMAN. IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE CHRISTY WASTE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND DEBBIE
BAMBERGER A WOMEN'S HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONER AT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IN EAST OAKLAND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND- YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM BEFORE MOVING FORWARD WITH
TESTIMONY LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BUT INSTEAD OF DIRECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROTH HERE
ROTH HERE MELENDEZ ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HERE BEAT BACKER
BACKER HERE DAUGHTER EGGMAN-
TARO. JONES JONES HERE LEYVA
LEYVA HERE MAN. MANY HERE NEWMAN
NEWMAN HERE A SHOW ABOUT A SHOW
BOTH HERE PAN. AND HERE. WE HAVE
A QUORUM. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IN ADDITION TO THE TWO
INDIVIDUALS IDENTIFIED BY THE
PRO TEM DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY. IN THIS CASE EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. DECEMBER CHRISTY WIESE
PLEASE PROCEED. CHRISTY WE
SOMEHOW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS ARE WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE PROGRAM'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
THRILLED TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT
AND AS THE SPONSOR. I WANT TO
GIVE THE REST OF MY TIME TO ONE
OF OUR NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO BE
BOMBARDED WHO WILL SPEAK TO HER
EXPERIENCE IN MORE DETAIL AS A
NURSE PRACTITIONER WORKING I'M
IN THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND
ABORTION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FIRST
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO HEAR AND DISCUSS
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ISSUE TODAY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
PROTON FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND
COMMITMENT TO EXPANDING ACCESS
TO ABORTION SERVICES. MY NAME IS
DEBBIE BAMBERGER I'M A WOMEN'S
HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONER AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN EAST
OAKLAND AND A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS MEMBER. I'M ALSO
AN ADVISORY BOARD MEMBER FOR
TEACH TRAINING AND EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE. I'VE BEEN A
PRACTICING NURSE PRACTITIONER
FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS I EARNED
A MASTER OF SCIENCE IN NURSING
AS WELL AS A DOCTORATE OF
NURSING PRACTICE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. IN MY WORK AT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD I PROVIDE FAMILY
PLANNING GYNECOLOGY AND ABORTION
SERVICES BOTH MEDICATION AND
ASPIRATION OR SURGICAL. I WAS
THE FIRST NURSE PRACTITIONER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO WAS
TRAINED TO DO ASPIRATION
ABORTION WHEN SENATOR ATKINS
PREVIOUS BILL AB ONE FIFTY FOUR
WAS MADE LAW ALLOWING SUPERVISED
AND PEAS PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS
AND NURSE MIDWIVES. TO PROVIDE
ABORTION SERVICES TO OUR
PATIENTS. AT MY CLINIC WE SERVE
A DIVERSE URBAN POPULATION WITH
PATIENTS COMING FROM ALL
SURROUNDING AREAS TO RECEIVE
CRITICALLY NEEDED REPRODUCTIVE
CARE. CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS A
SHORTAGE OF ABORTION PROVIDERS
OVER 40% OF COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA DON'T EVEN HAVE A
SINGLE CLINIC THAT PROVIDES
ABORTION. AND BECAUSEOF THE
ATTACKS ON REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND IN
OTHER STATES WE ARE ALREADY
SEEING PATIENTS FROM TEXAS.
TRAVELING HALFWAY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO GET AN ABORTION
PROCEDURE THAT TAKES ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES. SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE WOULD INCREASE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY ABORTION
AND REPRODUCTIVE CARE BY
CONTINUING THE INTENT OF TWO
PREVIOUS BILLS. AB ONE FIFTY
FOUR AND AB EIGHT NINETY BECAUSE
AB EIGHT NINETY GAVE CALIFORNIA
AND P. IS THE ABILITY TO
PRACTICE WITHOUT A PHYSICIAN'S
SUPERVISION. SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE WOULD BRING THE STATUTE
ALLOWING MPS TO PROVIDE FIRST
TRIMESTER ABORTION IN LINE WITH
ALL THE OTHER HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND PEAS CAN OFFER. THE
INTENT OF SENATOR ATKINS
PREVIOUS BILL AB ONE FIFTY FOUR
WAS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
ABORTION CARE BY EXPANDING THE
TYPES OF PROVIDERS WHO PERFORM
ABORTIONS. WHILE THERE ARE MANY
CALIFORNIA AND PEACE WHO ARE
WILLING AND INTERESTED IN BEING
TRAINED TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
AND PEAS ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND
PROVIDERS WHO WILL TRAIN THEM AS
MANY OF THE TRAINING PROCEDURES
ARE GIVEN TO PHYSICIAN RESIDENTS
RATHER THAN OTHER PROVIDERS.
THERE IS A PARTICULAR DEARTH OF
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES IN AREAS
LIKE FRESNO BAKERSFIELD AND
MERCED. SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD NOT ONLY INCREASE ACCESS
TO THESE SERVICES BUT WOULD GROW
THE PROVIDER POOL SINCE
EXPERIENCED MPS COULD TRAIN
OTHER MPS ON ABORTION
PROCEDURES. THERE IS NO REASON
THAT ABORTION SHOULD BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY FROM OTHER
PROCEDURES AND PEAS PROVIDE.
EVEN BEFORE AB EIGHT NINETY I
WAS PROVIDING ABORTION CARE AND
SERVING PATIENTS WHEN MY
SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN WAS NOT
PHYSICALLY PRESENT. OFTEN HOURS
AWAY I KNOW MY LIMITATIONS I
KNOW WHEN TO CONSULT OTHER
PROVIDERS AND I KNOW WHEN TO
CALL FOR HELP. SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WILL ALLOW ME TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ABORTION
SERVICES WITHOUT THE UNNECESSARY
STANDARDIZED PROCEDURES THAT
LIMIT THE NUMBERS OF MPS WHO CAN
PRACTICE. I RECENTLY HAD A
PATIENT WHO IS IN URGENT NEED OF
AN ASPIRATION PROCEDURE THIS WAS
A NONVIABLE PREGNANCY THAT
RESULTED IN A MISCARRIAGE THE
PATIENT WAS FROM HAYWARD AND HOW
TO TRAVEL TO MY CLINIC IN EAST
OAKLAND IN ORDER TO GET THE CARE
SHE NEEDED. IF I HADN'T BEEN
AVAILABLE SHE WOULD HAVE HAD TO
GO TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
POTENTIALLY WAITING MANY HOURS
FOR CARE DURING A SCARY AND
VULNERABLE TO HI. AND THIS PLACE
IN URBAN AREA OF CALIFORNIA
IMAGINE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN ONE
OF THE COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE
ANY ABORTION PROVIDERS. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE IS ABOUT
GETTING MORE PEOPLE IN FAMILIES
THE CARE THEY NEED I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND THE GROWING NEED FOR
MORE PROVIDERS OF ABORTION
SERVICES AND ALL OTHER HEALTH
CARE. SERVICES PASSING SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WILL ALLOW
HIGHLY TRAINED AND QUALIFIED
NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO ALLEVIATE
THE HEAVY WORKLOAD THAT IS
CARRIED BY ALL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. AND THAT IS
DETRIMENTAL TO PATIENT CARE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEVER HEARD FROM ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
IN SUPPORT. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT SAYING
NONE LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA
TELECONFERENCE URBIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP ANY
SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY ME PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO FIRST
ONLINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PLEASE PROCEED HELLO
LINE TWENTY. ALL RIGHT. SB EIGHT
FORTY. POSTMODERNISM ALL MINE
AND BOTH WERE. WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO MOVE ON A STRETCHER YES YES
PLEASE. LINE TWENTY TWO EUROPA
MATTHEW H. R. I'M HERE FOR SB
ELEVEN SIXTEEN SO I DON'T KNOW
HOW I GOT ON THIS QUEUE OKAY
THANK YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
CONNIE MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. TWENTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING THE
JERRY MEMBERS OF HIS WILL BE
GOING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND PORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE FIFTY FIVE.
OUR QUOTA UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE BECAUSE HE SHOULD BE IN A
WELCOME TRICK CALIFORNIA IN
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE SIXTY. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROCK FAN COOLED
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PUT. NINE SIXTY TWO. MORNING MY
CLAIM IF OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
BINA FORTY SIX. THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION AT PAPA HOTEL
DISTRICT AND- THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. BLIND. SIXTY NINE. I
KNOW THE YOUNG ON BEHALF OF
PRESIDENTIAL ACTIONS HEALTH
INSURANCE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE TWENTY. GOOD
MORNING AND KATRINA CANTRELL
DIRECTOR OF WOMEN'S HEALTH
SPECIALISTS OF FEMINIST WOMEN'S
HEALTH CENTER WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF F. B. ONE THREE SEVEN
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING JEFF PEOPLE A WITH
GOVERNOR FOR CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
NEXT PLEASE. NINE FORTY SEVEN.
THANKS PENSION AFTER A MERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN SISTERS NINE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A SPORT IF AMENDED
PETITION AND ACCORDING TO
NETWORK WITH MATT APPROACH HIM
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR THANKS
PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY ONE. FIVE
TEACH TRAINING EARLY ABORTION
FOR COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE IN
FRONT OF THE COURT- AT EIGHT
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
TURN OVER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MUCH BETTER NOW HAVING HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS. AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FIRST LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE MOVED TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE URBIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WOULD HAVE TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION THE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WE WILL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU TO STATE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. ONCE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
FEW LINES WITH OPERATORS WILL BE
JUST A MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
COMMENT. THANK YOU SIR.
LOCAL FIRST ONLINE NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU PENNY HARRINGTON FROM
THIS TO CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
PLEASE. WE ONLINE NUMBER. SIXTY
THREE. MY NAME IS ROBERT BYRD I
AM A NATIVE OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
EXECUTIVE COORDINATOR OF PRO
LIFE SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. MAILONLINE.
FIFTY FOUR. IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. FINE SIXTY SEVEN. BOB THIS IS
A GREG BIRD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS. PINE. SIXTY FOUR. TONIO
QUALITY CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY FOUR.
MOHAMMED THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. M.
LINE. FIFTY SIX. I LINE FIFTY
SIX EUROPEN. NEXT PLEASE MOVING
UP. THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THAT'S NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS FETTERMAN.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR I WANNA
ABOUT THE PROGRAM FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- WE OBVIOUSLY
OF GOVERN STATE AFFAIRS BUT IT'S
- HARD NOT TO SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
WITH OUR FEDERAL COURTS
INCLUDING THE SUPREME COURT
BEING INCREASINGLY OVERTAKEN BY
RADICAL IDEOLOGUES WHO HAVE NO
RESPECT FOR THE RULE OF LAW. S.
N. N. OR FOUR FREEDOMS AND IT
LOOKS UNLIKELY THAT ROE V. WADE
I WILL MAKE IT TO THE FIFTIETH
BIRTHDAY ON JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND NEXT YEAR- REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOMS ARE UNDER ATTACK ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY IN OUR COURTS. IN
OUR SUPREME COURT AND SO ONCE
AGAIN I THINK CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE IN A
POSITION TO LEAD SO I THINK THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT I RECOGNIZE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION BUT I
THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
PREPARE IN THE STATE FOR WHAT
WILL LIKELY BE. A FLOOD OF WOMEN
SEEKING REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES IN
OUR STATE AND SO- I I'M GOING TO
VOTE I AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE CO AUTHOR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR MAN CENTER PAM. I THANK
YOU- AND I WANT TO THANK OUR PRO
TEMP FOR HER- ONGOING LEADERSHIP
AND ENSURING ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND
APPRECIATE HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE- I WOULD NOTE THAT I
HOPE THAT THE ASSET THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE SAMPLE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF- SURGEONS
GYNECOLOGISTS THE-
MEDICALIZATION THAT SUPPORTS
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOMS- AND OTHER-THAN THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY TO
DRESS I THINK SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT- THE- I GUESS. IN TERMS
OF- TRAINING AND SUPERVISION- I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORT PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL-
REGARDING- EXPAND THE ACCESS TO-
FOR NURSE PRACTITIONERS PERFORM-
THE ASPIRATION PROCEDURES AS AS
OUTLINED- BUT ALSO BUT DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT TRIED. AS
NURSE PRACTITIONERS HAVE. MOVING
TOWARD IN A PRACTICE THAT WE
HAVE SOME EQUIVALENCE WITH OTHER
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO HAVE
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE FOR EXAMPLE
TO AMOUNT OF CME EACH OF US HAVE
TO TAKE IT'S NOT EQUIVALENT TO
THAT NURSE PRACTITIONERS ARE
REQUIRED THE LAST- AND IN TERMS
IN TERMS OF THE SCOPE OF THE
EXPERIENCE DURING CLINICAL TIME.
TO BE SURE THAT CORRESPONDS IN
THAT TRANSITION TO PRACTICE THAT
CORRESPONDS TO WHAT THEY'LL BE
DOING IN PRACTICE- THAT THERE'S
NOT SCRIPT AND SEE THEIR- WHICH-
SO. YOUR LEADERSHIP CERTAINLY
WHAT SUPPORT THIS BILL SO YOU
CAN WORK ON THESE ISSUES- BUT
AGAIN A STRONG SUPPORTER
REPURPOSE OF THE BILL WHICH IS
EXPANDABLE DOCTOR ABOUT- THERE
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN SENTIMENT. THANK YOU
MR HERE AS USUAL CENTER PANAS
SPOKEN FOR MAYBE IT WAS THE
WITNESS VERY. CLEARLY POINTED
OUT THERE ARE STILL SIGNIFICANT
ACCESS TO CARE ISSUES ACROSS THE
STATE ACROSS A WHOLE BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF CARE NOWHERE
IS THIS MORE IMPORTANT. THAN IN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH- GLAD TO
SUPPORT. THIS BILL LIKE TO MOVE
AT THE PROPER TIME. THANK YOU A
CENTER. MEMBERS IN OTHER.
COMMENTS OR- SEEING NO MIKE'S UP
- TEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER TERRY AND COLLEAGUES I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
INTO THE- THE WITNESSES TODAY I
APPRECIATE- THE DISCUSSION AND
THE SUPPORT AND I WILL SAY
MOVING FORWARD I AM COMMITTED TO
FINDING WAYS TO IMPROVE ABORTION
TRAINING STANDARDS- TO COME TO
SOME AGREEMENT WITH- THOSE THAT
HAVE FEEDBACK STAKEHOLDERS. YOU
KNOW I HOPE. IN RECOGNIZING THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE MOST
STRINGENT- CRITERIA FOR
TRAINING. OF PRACTITIONERS
FRANKLY AT EVERY LEVEL OF
PRACTICING CLINICIANS SO I FEEL
THERE ARE WAYS THAT WE CAN BUILD
UPON THIS AND HOPEFULLY COME TO
SOME AGREEMENT. SO I'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK IN GOOD FAITH WITH
PHYSICIANS AND ANY OTHER
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS. AND TO
YOUR POINT WITH AN INCREASING
PROVIDER SHORTAGE WHICH HAS ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED OVER THE LAST
THREE DECADES. NOT JUST AN
ABORTION CARE BUT I WOULD SAY IN
PRIMARY CARE AS WELL WE WANT TO
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION AS A LEADER OUR
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM. AND I DO
THINK WE NEED TO ACT SWIFTLY AND
UTILIZE ALL THE TOOLS IN OUR
TOOLBOX THAT IS WHY I'M HERE
TODAY. TO TALK ABOUT THIS NEWS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO ENHANCE
ON EIGHT NINETY EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY AND AB ONE FIFTY FOUR. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WILL
ENABLE EXPERIENCED QUALIFIED AND
TRAINED NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO
BOOST OUR REPRODUCTIVE AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR NEWMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
AND STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL
NOW. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
REMIND YOU TO PLEASE SPEAK INTO
YOUR MICROPHONE WHEN VOTING.
ROSS HI ROSS HI MELENDEZ
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D BEAT
BECKER BAKER AYE DODD EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO. JONES JONES
KNOWN LEYVA LEVI MEN MEN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE AYE CHOI BOGUE
. I CHOI BOGUE NO HAN HAN I. THE
BILL HAS THE VOTES I TO KNOW
HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. MEMBERS LET'S TAKE UP
THE CONSENT. CALENDAR FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN SENATE BILL
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN AM STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THEY CAN
THANK COUNTER SENATE BILL TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN DO YOU PASS AND RE
REFER TODAY. I DON'T HAVE TO SAY
THE MOTION- ROSS. ROSS HI
MELENDEZ URSULA. URSULA IBEATS.
BACKER BAKER AYE DODD EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO JONES JONES
I LEYVA LEAVE A AYE MAN MEN AYE
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE AND SHOW A
VOGUE A SHOWBOAT I'D HAN CAN I.
TEN VOTES. SEN CALENDARS OUT.
JONES SINCE FIRST SENATOR DOES
NOT HERE WHY DON'T WE TAKE YOU
YOU HAVE TO BILLS ONE SENATE
BILL NINE ONE NINE AND THE
SECOND BILL. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE. IS IT OKAY
IF I PRESENT FROM MY EARLY MAY
AND I WOULD ASK THOSE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO PLEASE
MUTE YOUR- BONES. THERE JONES
SENATE BILL NINE ONE NINE PLEASE
PROCEED IN READING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SENATE BILL NINE
ONE NINE WOULD HELP COMBAT
CATHOLIC CONVERTER THEFTS WITH A
THREE PRONGED APPROACH. FIRST
THIS BILL REQUIRES NEW AND USED
MOTOR VEHICLE DEALERS TO
PERMANENTLY MARK THE VEHICLE
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER OR THE VAN
ON A CALORIE CONVERTER OF ANY
VEHICLE BEFORE THEY SELL IT THIS
REQUIREMENT WILL CREEK RECREATE
WILL CREATE A WAY TO IDENTIFY A
CALCULATOR IF IT IS ILLEGALLY
REMOVED FROM THE CAR. SECOND
THIS BILL ALLOWS METAL RECYCLERS
TO BUY CATALYTIC CONVERTERS ONLY
IF THEY HAVE A CLEARLY VISIBLE
AND ON TAMPERED VAN ON THEM.
RECYCLERS WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED
TO KEEP DETAILED RECORDS OF ALL
SALES FROM BOTH BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS AND MAKE THOSE
RECORDS ACCESSIBLE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THIRD THIS BILL
ADDS FINES TO THE CURRENT
PENALTIES FOR CALIBER THEFTS AND
MAKES IT EASIER TO ESTABLISH
PROBABLE CAUSE FOR ARREST AND
PROSECUTION. I WANT TO SHOW THE
COMMITTEE WHERE CAROL CONVERTER
LOOKS LIKE- BUT I FORGOT TO
BRING IT SO I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
- CALIFORNIA IS THE NUMBER ONE
IN THE NATION FOR KELLY
CONVERTER THEFTS WITH EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DEATHS JUST LAST YEAR.
THAT'S A 13100% INCREASE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. WEALTHY
YOU CAN STILL CALIBURN UNDER TWO
MINUTES AND MAKE A QUICK TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS. THEFT
VICTIMS OF FACE UP TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO REPLACE THE
CONVERTER. AND A LOSS OF THE
VEHICLE WHILE THERE'S GETS
FIXED. THE PROBLEM HAS ONLY
GOTTEN WORSE OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS AND DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE
SLOWING DOWN. THAT'S MAKING OUR
ACTION TODAY ON THE MAJOR OF THE
UP MOST IMPORTANCE. MY BILL
INCORPORATES A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY TO TACKLE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THEFTS FROM ALL
ANGLES. I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
MAY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL MANDATES ON
BUSINESSES AND I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS.
TO FIND A SOLUTION ADDRESSES
THEIR CONCERNS AND TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC FROM CALICUT BERNARD
THEFTS. THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
OF CENTER JONES I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE- TWO WITNESSES ON
THE LINE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
YES SIR A DETECTIVE LEONARD WITH
THE CHULA VISTA POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND ALISON ADDY IF I
PRONOUNCE THAT LAST NAME
CORRECTLY. WITH THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU WERE ON THE
LINE PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED. THIS
IS DETECTIVE LEONARD. PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SAMSON
LEONARD AND I'M A DETECTIVE WITH
THE TO THE BEST A POLICE
DEPARTMENT. CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
OR CATS ARE THE PERFECT TARGET
FOR THIEVES. VALUABLE SIMPLE TO
STILL IMPOSSIBLE TO TRADE. AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS NO RECOURSE.
POSSESSION OF STOLEN PROPERTY IS
A CRIME AGAINST THE PERSON. SO
WITHOUT A PERSON OR VICTIM
THERE'S NO CRIME. OFFICERS
LOCATE CATCH DURING TRAFFIC
STOPS. KNOW THAT THEIR STONE
BECAME PROVE IT. AND THE
SUSPECTS ARE NEVER HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. SAN DIEGO COUNTY
HAD OVER TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
CAPTIVES REPORTED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THAT'S IN MY CITY
INCREASED BY SEVEN HUNDRED
PERCENT. THIS YEAR'S LOOKING
WORSE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
WHERE PEOPLE PARK ON THE STREET
OR UNSECURED LOTS- SPECIALLY
VULNERABLE. I MET VICTIMS LIKE
CLAUDIA AND JORGE WHO CAN AFFORD
REPAIRED OR STOLEN CATCH ANOTHER
MAKE PAYMENTS ON CARS THAT THEY
CAN'T EVEN USE. PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS CURRENT LAW CREATED A
BLACK MARKET TO MINIMAL
OVERSIGHT OF BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS CASH TRANSACTIONS. IF I
WOULD HAVE POLITICIANS BUSINESS
THEM APPLICATION WITH THE COUNTY
I COULD SELL CATS TO RECYCLER.
THAT NOW NEED ONLY LOG MY
BUSINESS NAME. THE RECYCLERS ARE
ACTING WITHIN THE LAW AND THEY
CAN CLAIM IGNORANCE BECAUSE THE
STONE CAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
LAUNDERED BY THE PREVIOUS
TRANSACTION. BETWEEN THE FIFTH
AND MY SHOW BUSINESS. I
SPECTATORS WHERE. WE THOUSAND OF
CASH THE UP WAITING SHE TO OUR-
TO THE TRAINED- CATCH JACK CUTS
. DURING REQUIRES MORE OBVIOUSLY
STOLEN. BUT HOW DO YOU PROVE
THAT SOMETHING ENTREES STONE.
SENATE BILL NINE ONE NINE MAKE
THE STATE BEFORE REACHING FOR
SARTELL. CATS WILL NOT BE MARKED
WITH. MAKING UNIQUE ALLOWING
OFFICERS TO LOCATE VICTIMS MAKE
ARRESTS. ACT BASED ON PROBABLE
CAUSE ABSENT IN A READILY
AVAILABLE VICTIM AND FINALLY.
THIS BILL WILL CLOSE LOOPHOLES
AND THAT REQUIREMENTS MAKING IT
MORE DIFFICULT TO LAUNDER STOLEN
CATS. AND THE BLACK MARKET WILL
SLOW OVERNIGHT. OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL OUR COMPANIES WORRIED ABOUT
INCREASED OVERHEAD. BUT
SUPPORTERS ARE JORGE CLAUDIA AND
EVERY CALIFORNIAN IMPACTED AND
FRUSTRATED BY THIS CRIME. WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. TO
GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT A FIGHTING
CHANCE AND THAT'S WHAT I SUPPORT
SENATE BILL NINE ONE NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR MISSOURI
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING PONDERED THE DEVELOPMENT
EIGHTY WITH THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT SEVEN OF
THE STATE'S LARGEST HOME AND
AUTO INSURER. SB NINE ONE NINE
RESPOND TO CRITICAL ISSUE FOR
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT MAKES IT NEARLY 30% OF ALL
AUTO CLAIM THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
I THINK DARK INCREASE ESPECIALLY
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
DESPITE THE FACT THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN
VEHICLE SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX AT THE ANALYSIS WHILE POINTS
OUT THAT HAD ONLY BEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN BUT THIS ISSUE
IS IN THE FOREGROUND ONE COMPANY
NOTED THAT THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
CATALYTIC CONVERTER BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WITH ONLY
FIFTY SEVEN. BY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IT WITH THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE INDUSTRY ON AVERAGE
THIS IS RESULTING IN TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN QUEENS. HER COMPANY ANNUALLY. THE
ABILITY TO. OUT OF AND OUT OF
BILL FOR THE WHO FELT CATALYTIC
. WOULD BE A BETTER STEP TOWARD
FOR THE NAY OF THAT ANNUALLY AT
CAL LEAD THE NATION IN.
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THAT. BEEN
FORWARDED DURING BOTH ON THE IN
THE AND ON. WHO ARE LEFT WITH AN
OPERABLE VIA. AND EXTENDED TIME
IN SHOP. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE SUPPORT NIGHT BUT- THANK
YOU MA'AM NO SIR FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE ONE
NINE. ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
LET'S MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING OF US.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP ANY SUCH WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL NINE ONE NINE WE WILL BEGIN
. IF YOU SECURE UP IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. CALL UPON THIS BE
COULD BE REFERRED TO AS YOUR
LINE NUMBER PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION WITH
LEGISLATIVE RECORD. ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
QUEUE UP AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE A LINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IF YOU CAME DOWN ON
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND NEXT WE
HAVE WHAT I NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
EMILY I'M A RESIDENT OF NUMBER.
AND I SUPPORT AND BEING NINE ONE
NINE. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND
WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT
PLEASE. OKAY WELL I NEVER. AND I
DO SUPPORT I SUPPORT PRESS.
THREE NINE ONE NINE. THANK YOU
SIR JUST A REMINDER TO THOSE ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE PLEASE
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON- TO
ATTEMPTING TO TESTIFY THAT WILL.
MINIMIZE THE- THE FEEDBACK.
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. AND WE DO
HAVE LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM IN THE MIDST THAT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WHICH IS PART OF EXCEPT
ONE WE ARE IN SOME THE COURT. SB
NINE ONE NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER- PURCHASED THE AT
LIKE UP IN SUPPORT THE SPACE ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. WHEN. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINE TO GIVE THIS
. THANK YOU MISTER POTTER HAVING
HEARD FROM THIS THE- LET'S FALL
THE SAME PER. AND FOR MANY
OPPOSITION. MOVING TO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION IN PERSON. TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SIR PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND PROCEED
VERY GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ANTHONY SAMPSON WITH
SAMPSON ADVISERS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION. THE IN CDA
HAS TAKEN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON SB NINE NINE
NINETEEN AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
IN A DIALOGUE. WITH US REGARDING
OUR CONCERNS. FIRST YOU CAN SEE
A- THE UNDERLYING INTENT TO THE
BILL. INTO THIS AND CURRENTLY
SUPPORTS OTHER CATALYTIC
CONVERTER MEASURES. FOCUSED ON
INCREASED ENFORCEMENT. AS IT
RELATES TO THIS BILL CNC DA'S
CONCERNS RELATE SPECIFICALLY TO
THE REQUIREMENT THE DEALERSHIPS
PERMANENTLY MARK. OR ETCH THE
VIN NUMBER INTO THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER BEFORE THE VEHICLE CAN
BE SOLD. WE'VE BEEN INFORMED
THAT SOME BELIEVE THAT PERMANENT
MARKING PERMANENTLY MARKING THE
VIN NUMBER IS SIMPLE AND
INEXPENSIVE. BUT IS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
MANY VEHICLE MODELS INCORPORATE
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER. IS PART
OF THE EXHAUST MANIFOLD
REQUIRING DEALERSHIP TECHNICIANS
TO DISASSEMBLE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE VEHICLE ENGINE
JUST ACCESS THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER. TO PROVIDE JUSTTWO
EXAMPLES TO PERMANENTLY MARK ONE
BALL THE MODEL. IT WOULD TAKE
DEALERSHIP TECHNICIANS TWO POINT
EIGHT TO FOUR HOURS TO
PERMANENTLY MARK ONE VEHICLE
DEPENDING ON ENGINE VARIANT. FOR
CERTAIN ACURA MODELS IT CAN TAKE
TWO TO FIVE HOURS. BUT EVEN
ASSUMING PERMANENTLY MARKING VIN
NUMBERS INTO CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS WAS SIMPLE AND
INEXPENSIVE. WE WOULD KNOW FOR
THE COMMITTEE THAT MANY OF THE
MOST TARGETED VELAR VEHICLES ARE
NOT EVEN BEING SOLD BY NEW CAR
DEALERSHIPS. DATA FROM THE
SERVICE DEPARTMENT OF ONE LARGE
TOYOTA DEALERSHIP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHOWS THAT MOST. BUT
THAT THE MOST TARGETED VEHICLE
ARE 200-062-0009 PREVIOUS'S
WHICH VERY FEW NEW CAR DEALERS
EVEN SELL. RATHER THOSE ARE
OFTEN SOLD THROUGH PRIVATE
VENDORS SELLERS LIKE CRAIGSLIST
EBAY MOTORS IN FACEBOOK MARKET
PLACE GET SB NINE NINETEEN DOES
NOT SEEK TO REQUIRE PERMANENT
MARKING THROUGH THOSE FORMS. WE
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO SERVICE
SILVER BULLET TO THIS PROBLEM AT
THE SAME TIME C. N. C. D. A
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON A MORE TARGETED
SOLUTION WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THAT CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR
DEALERSHIPS. ARE NOT SALAS
SADDLED WITH THE LABOR INTENSIVE
AND COSTLY OBLIGATION OF
PERMANENTLY MARKING EVERY SINGLE
VEHICLE THAT THEY SELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE MODERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
NINE ONE NINE WE WILL CONTINUE.
RIGHT DON'T. AND IF YOU NEEDED
THE Q. ONE ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
ANALYZE IT HERE UP HERE ONE
MOMENT.
AND WE HAVE A LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAVE
CONCERNS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. BYRON AND ANYONE
ELSE BUT WHAT AND IF ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE YOU'LL PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE LINE. FORTY THREE IS WHAT.
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS OF
NEIL CLARK ON BEHALF OF I. A.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TO PROTECT THE
LEGITIMATE BUSINESS OF SALVAGE
POOLS ON THE RECYCLERS TO
TRAVELERS AND LICENSED
WHOLESALERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. AND IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE OF LOOKING UP AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINE
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S NOT BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE FLOOR
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. CENTER
NEWMAN. AT DAVIS YOU'RE- TO THE
AUTHOR BED DIDN'T THE- ISSUES
RAISED BY THE NEW CAR DEALERS.
OPS POTENTIAL- I UNDERSTAND FROM
YOUR SISTER YOU'RE WORKING WITH
THEM AS A SAID SOMETHING I THINK
THE WHERE YOU CAN MEET THEM. A
KIND OF POSSIBLY. BUT AND
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS. YES
WHERE WERE WE HAD A VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION LAST WEEK- MY STAFF
IS RUDE IS IN CONTINUOUS
CONVERSATION WITH THEM. WHEN WE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL I WASN'T
EXPECTING THAT THERE'D BE ALMOST
A DOZEN OTHER YOU KNOW CONVERTER
BILLS ON THIS AS WELL SO- WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA WORK VERY
AGGRESSIVELY WITH THEM IN AND-
THEY'RE HAVING A BOARD MEETING
AT SOME POINT TIME THIS WEEK I
THINK. AND HOPEFULLY GET TO A
POINT WHERE. WE'RE ALL HAPPY
WITH LANGUAGE ANSWER TO BE
CLEARLY DID WOULD YOU AGREE THAT
THERE SEEMS TO BE AN ESSENTIAL
DIFFERENCE FOR NEW CARS- AN
OLDER MODEL CARS AS RELATES TO
ACCESS TO CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
YES ON SOME OF THE NEW CARS- WE
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW IF IT'S HARD
FOR THE MECHANIC TO GET TO THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER. I THINK THE
SAME ASSUMPTIONS IS HARD FOR THE
- THIEF TO GET TO THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT AT THIS POINT TIME IS
HOW DO WE PRETEND TO LANGUAGE.
AS TO. THE CONVERTERS ARE
DIFFICULT TO GET TO VERSUS THE
ONES THAT ARE EASIER TO GET TO.
PROJECTED BASED ON THAT OF THE
GLASS WITH BUILDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NORMAN CENTER PAM
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
ACTUALLY SERVE ALONG THE SAME
LINES A CENTER- NEWMAN- AND DOES
MAKE I THINK THAT THAT ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THERE'S LIKE TEN
BILLS ON CALCULATORS- SO AND
CERTAINLY NO THAT IS A BIG
PROBLEM AND- MY DISTRICT IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD- I GUESS
INTRACELLULARLY WITH THE NEW CAR
DEALERS- AND- IT IS. VISITORS
DATA AS ANYONE BEEN ABLE TO GET
DATA IN TERMS OF THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF THE NEWER AND
THE NEWER MODELS WHEN THEY'RE IN
THE MANIFOLDS ORDERS ACTUALLY
BEING STOLEN AT THAT BECAUSE-
THEY'RE HARDER TO GET TO SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE.
INFORMATION OR ANY OF THE
WITNESSES THAT HAVE HAS
INFORMATION. REGARDS TO THE-
DEGREE OF RISK OF THOSE CAL
CONVERTS COMPARED TO ONES IN
OLDER MODELS WHERE THEY'RE MUCH
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND UNDERSIDE
CAR. MY UNDERSTANDING WITH MY
CONVERSATION WITH THE NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION LAST WEEK IS
SOME VEHICLES ARE VERY DIFFICULT
TO GET TO. AND SOME NEW VIEW
NEWER VEHICLES. ARE NOT VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET TO SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS.
WHAT MATRIX- DO WE USED TO JUST
DISCERN THAT AND LAW. AND WHAT
LANGUAGE CAN WE COME UP WITH TO
MAKE THAT DIFFERENCE DIFFERENCE.
AND SO I TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
THERE BEING NUMEROUS BILLS. ON
THIS ISSUE- I WOULD IMAGINE AT
SOME POINT TIME. YOU KNOW SOME
OF THOSE BILLS ARE GONNA BE
NARROWED DOWN. AND YOU KNOW FOR
ME PERSONALLY I'M SUPPORTING ALL
OF THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER BILLS
TODAY. BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED
TO KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING
IN AND HAVE A ROBUST DIALOGUE
AMONGST BOTH HOUSES. AND IN AND
GET TO A SOLUTION I THINK WE
WILL- BETWEEN THE SEVERAL
AUTHORS AND THE STAKEHOLDERS I
THINK WE'LL GET THERE. IF WE-
KEEP EVERYTHING MOVING AT THIS
POINT TIME. OKAY OKAY WELL I
THINK I THINK RESOLUTION THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUES GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT AT LEAST FOR ME
AND PERHAPS FOR SOME MY
COLLEAGUES AS WELL- I DON'T WANT
TO SEE DEALERS HAVING TO
ESSENTIALLY TAKE APART. NEW CARS
IN ORDER TO GET RID OF IN NUMBER
AND THEN PUT IT BACK TOGETHER
AGAIN AND POTENTIALITY. WHETHER
IT'S A NEW CAR OR EVEN A FAIRLY
RECENT CARD IT'S NOW DOWN AND A
LOT- AND- IT'S NOT EXPENSE BUT
ALSO POTENTIALLY- YOU KNOW. WELL
BANDAGING CAR SOME OTHER HELP.
SO ESPECIALLY IF THE RISK IS
MUCH LOWER FOR SOMEONE TO STEAL
THIS CALICOBURGERS BECAUSE OF
THE POSITION ITSELF- SO
APPRECIATE AN ANSWER AND-
CERTAINLY. ABOUT FOUR TO MOVING
THE BILL FORWARD BUT HOPE THAT
THAT'S- EXPECTED THAT TO BE
ADDRESSED BEFORE IT. SHOWS UP ON
THE FLOOR THANK YOU. SIR PAN
AGREE WITH YOU ALMOST VERBATIM.
THANK CENTER PAN CIRCULAR- THANK
YOU MISTER- I'VE GOT THE LARGEST
NEW CAR DEALERSHIPS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN MY
DISTRICT CITY OF CERRITOS
INTERCOURSE- THE NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION- CONCERNED AS I AM
CONCERNED- HOW THE AUTHOR IS
GOING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION OBVIOUSLY BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE- YOU'VE ALREADY SET
THE PATH TO WORK WITH THEM AND-
AS LONG AS YOU COME TOGETHER AND
OBVIOUSLY WE JUST HEARD THAT
CERTAIN MODELS OF A JUST TOO
DIFFICULT TO GET TO OBVIOUSLY
THESE THIEVES WANT TO GET IN GET
OUT AND SO ON AND OBVIOUSLY WHAT
WE HEARD. IT'S THE OLDER OLDER
MODELS BUT- I APPRECIATE WITH
YOU OFFERS GOING WITH THIS AND-
I- RESERVE THE RIGHT TO TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT IT DOWN THE ROAD
BUT I WILL O AHEAD AND EVEN
MOVE THE BILL TODAY- AT
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I
APPRECIATE HIS SUPPORT AND I'M
HOPING THAT THEY CAN FIND THAT
HAPPY MEDIUM THAT WE'RE ALL
LOOKING FOR BECAUSE IT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS THAT TAKING THE STEP
FORWARD IN AYE- COURAGE TO NEW
CAR DEALERSHIPS TO WORK WITH YOU
AUTHORS FOR THEN WE CAN GO
AHEAD. GO FORWARD WITH THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEARCH A LOT OF CENTER
BACKER IS THAT YOUR MAKE UP YEAH
I'LL JUST ECHO COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE AND- TO LOOK FOR THE
MOVE FORWARD A ON IN THAT
CONTEXT THANK YOU SIR. HOW IS
ANY OTHER. CAN OR- SIGNAL. UP
JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- FOR THE- GREAT DIALOGUE
THIS MORNING AND- WITH THAT I'LL
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR WE DO HAVE A MOTION BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ARCH
ALETTA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY MADAM STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL NINETY ONE NINETY
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY ROTH
ON. ROSS AYE MELENDEZ. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA IBEATS. BACKER BAKER
AYE DODD. DODD AYE EGGMAN HER
TADO JONES JONES I LEYVA LEYVA
ICEMAN MAN I NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
UNTIL ABODE UNTIL A BUG EYED MAN
CAN I. TURN VOTES WILL HOLD ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT UP
CENTER JONES WHILE YOU HAVE THE
MIKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE TO
YOUR SECOND BILL SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE YES SIR
THANK YOU. WE ARE. S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE WILL REQUIRE
EACH BOREDOM BUREAU WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO PUBLICLY POST A LIST OF
CRITERIA USED TO EVALUATE
APPLICANTS WITH CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS SO APPLICANTS MAY
UNDERSTAND THEIR LIKELIHOOD OF
BEING GRANTED BUSINESS LICENSURE
BEFORE THEY APPLY THE BILL WILL
REQUIRE THE DCA TO DEVELOP A
CLEAR PROCESS FOR VERIFYING
APPLICANT INFORMATION INCLUDING
PERFORMING BACKGROUND CHECKS OF
APPLICANTS AND REQUIRING
APPLICANTS WITH PRIOR
CONVICTIONS TO PROVIDE CERTIFIED
COURT DOCUMENTS. SO THAT THE
PROPER CONVICTIONS ARE RECORDED
IN THE PROCESS IT ALSO REQUIRES
THESE BOARDS AND BUREAUS TO
DEVELOP A PROCEDURE TO PROVIDE
FOR IMPROVED APPEALS PROCESS
THAT WE MARK SENSIBLE TO
APPLICANTS WHO ORIGINALLY DENIED
THIS REQUIREMENT CREATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE LICENSURE
PROCESS MORE TRANSPARENT
INCLUSIVE FOR ALL APPLICANTS MR
HERE I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION ON THE
LINE. TO SPEAK IN FAVOR. PLEASE
PROCEED. WHY NOT SHOW THE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PEDRO NAVA CHAIR
OF THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
IS ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. CHERNOV IF YOU WERE ON
THE LINE THREE PLEASE PROCEED.
WELL LET'S MOVE ON LET'S SEE IF
THEY'RE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY WHICH TO TESTIFY IN%
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL. THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITED
TESTIFIED VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THEM. IF YOU'D LIKE
YOU UP IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE LINE NUMBER NINETY FIVE
LET'S GO AHEAD. BY NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT PLEASE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE YOU UP
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. DO AND LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN THIS GUY HAD. UP
HERE HI MY NAME CLEARLY I'M A
RISK THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GO.
AND I SUPPORT B. THIRTEEN FIVE.
I. COLDLY CAFE YOU ONCE AGAIN
FOR THOSE ON THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE ME THE YOU WATCHING THE
HEARING PRO TO TEST IT WILL
MINIMIZE THE FEEDBACK NEXT
PLEASE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE
YOU UP IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE NO FOR THE- I
THINK YOU. MODERATOR I WAS
DISTRACTED DID YOU SAY THERE ARE
NO OTHER. INDIVIDUAL YES I'M
SORRY THERE ARE NO BUT NO
FURTHER LINE DID YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. WELL LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION FIRST ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY WHICH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR. LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY.
AND WE'RE WAITING TO DO SO IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE VIA
TELECONFERENCE OR- AND THOSE
WISHING WISHING TO QUEUE UP IN
OPPOSITION TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME NO I'M NOT I'M
BEING TESTIMONY. OKAY I BUDGET.
PLEASE PROCEED IDENTIFY YOURSELF
THAT YOUR POSITION. DOCTOR
SHEKHAR. I AM I AM HAVING
TROUBLE HEARING AND
UNDERSTANDING YOU. WE'RE TAKING
TESTIMONY ON SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE IF YOU ARE
NOT. INTERESTED IN PROVIDING
pANOTHER YOU'LL HAVE TO QUEUE
BACK UP. MODERATOR PLEASE PROP
THE NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU UP
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF
THERE ARE ANY LINES THAT WOULD
LIFT YOU UP PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. AT THIS TIME SIR
. THANK YOU AS MODERATOR LET'S
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS FIRST
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU UPS FARE-
AND- YEAH APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRING THIS FOR- AND THE WORK OF
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION. I
WOULD MAKE THAT THAT- IN THE
POLICY COMMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS.
THEY DID MAKE NOTE THAT- EACH
BOARD- HAS DIFFERENT COURT
REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO- THE
SENATE. AN INVASION AND OF
DIFFERENT MAY HAVE- DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT-
AT THAT PARTICULAR RELEVANT TO
THAT PARTICULAR PROFESSION.
SOAKING MAYBE CAN YOU TO ADDRESS
THE S. SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED
IN THE POLICY COMMENTS- IN TERMS
OF. THE ROLE OF EACH PARTICULAR
BOARDS I GUESS AND THIS BILL IS
LIKE IT'S SOMETHING CUTTING
ACROSS ALL THE BOARDS BUT THE
BOARDS- THE REPORT OF DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH SO- DO APRIMO. THAT
DEPRECIATE THE AT THE- THE ISSUE
RAISED BY LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION- TRYING TO DRESS BUT
PERHAPS CAN YOU ADDRESS THOSE.
THANK THANK YOU DR PAN AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL TAKE A SHOT
ANSWER THE QUESTION AND THEN I'M
I'M BEING TOLD BY MY STAFF AT
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION'S
BACK ON THE LINE SO- MY YES THAT
IS TRUE- IT IS YOU KNOW FOR ALL
THE DCA BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS-
EACH ONE WILL HAVE TO. IN ANY
TWENTY HAS DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS- YOU FOR WHO
THEY'RE GOING TO ALLOW TO BE
LICENSED. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE- IN THIS WAS.
DISCOVERED BY THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION ORIGINALLY- THIS
CHALLENGE. IS THAT EACH BECAUSE
EACH BOARD IS DIFFERENT- AS A-
AS A PRIOR SOME OF THE PRIOR
CONVICTION. HE THERE'S YOU KNOW
IT IS VERY. DIFFICULT OR- YOU
KNOW A LOT OF LEG WORK TO FIND
OUT. YOU KNOW WHICH CAN WHICH
BOARD- LICENSE YOU CAN APPLY
FOR. AND EVENTUALLY GET
APPROVED. WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION BEING READILY
AVAILABLE SO OUR OUR GOAL HERE
IS TO MAKE THIS INFORMATION MORE
READILY AVAILABLE. SO THAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO RE
ENTER THE WORKFORCE. AND GAIN-
YOU KNOW JIM AT WORK. I HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO PURSUE.
THE CAREER THAT. THEY HAVE THE
BEST CHANCE OF GETTING APPROVED
FOR. OKAY BUT- FREE SHOULD I
GUESS THE WELL ACTUALLY IF WE
HAVE THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY FINALLY MIGHT BE HELPFUL
TO HEAR FROM THEM AT THE ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE. THEY COULD DO SO IN
THEIR REMARKS THANK YOU. BUT
YOU'RE FINISHED RIGHT NOW CENTER
PAN YES THANK YOU OKAY. CENTER
MEN WITH YOUR PERMISSION I'M
GOING TO TAKE YOUR NOVEL IF HE'S
ON THE LINE TURNOVER PLEASE
PROCEED. YES SIR CAN YOU HEAR ME
TRONG PERFECT. I AND I APOLOGIZE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED- BUT
ANYWAY GOOD MORNING UPDATE YOUR
ROUGHLY COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS PEDRO NAVA CHAIR LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION I'M HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SIXTY
FIVE. AS YOU KNOW THE COMMISSION
IS AN INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT NOW IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE COMMISSION ISSUED A REPORT
EXAMINING CALIFORNIA'S
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING SYSTEM.
AND DURING OUR STUDY WE FOUND
THAT CALIFORNIA'S WITH CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS ON THEIR RECORDS
THANKS SEVERAL CHALLENGES WHEN
TRYNG TO BECOME LICENSE IN A
REPORT ENTITLED JOB FOR
CALIFORNIANS STRATEGIES TO EASE
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING BARRIERS
WE OFFER SEVERAL STEPS TO HELP
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES. FIRST IF THEY COULD
ONLY ASK FOR OFFICIAL CONVICTION
RECORDS RATHER THAN RELYING ON
AN APPLICANT'S MEMORY THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT APPLICANTS WON'T
FACE DISQUALIFICATION BECAUSE
THE CONVICTIONS THEY PUT ON
THEIR APPLICATIONS DON'T MATCH
WHAT. COMES BACK ON A BACKGROUND
CHECK. SECOND LIFE IN A DOOR
SHOULD BE RE. TO LIFT ON THEIR
WAY. THE CRIED TO THAT IS USED
TO EVALUATE APPLICANTS WITH
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS. WE WANTED
TO DO THIS UP FRONT SO THAT
FORMER OFFENDERS DECIDE WHETHER
TO INVEST IN THE EDUCATION THE
TRAINING AND THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. AND FINALLY THE STATE
COULD CREATE AN INFORMAL APPEALS
PROCESS TO PROVIDE APPLICANTS
THE OPPORTUNITY. EXPLAINED
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR APPLICATIONS
RIGHT NOW APPLICANTS WHO ARE
DENIED A LICENSE MAY ENGAGE IN
AN APPEALS PROCESS BUT THAT CAN
BE CONFUSING AND EXPENSIVE. SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE WOULD
ADVANCE THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. BY HELPING
MITIGATE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT CALIFORNIA'S WITH
CONVICTIONS ON THEIR RECORDS
FACE WHEN TRYING TO BECOME LIFE.
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR JONES
FOR THIS LEGISLATION ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL TODAY ON BEHALF
COOPER COMMISSION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. FOR ALLOWING ME TO
COME BACK IN LINE. THANK YOU
JOURNAL FOR YOUR- CENTER MEN.
THANK YOU TO ROTH- I WANT TO
ECHO THE CONCERNS RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO- YOU
KNOW I THINK WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT- YOU KNOW FIRST WHY I
SHOULD SAY I APPLAUD THE GOALS
OF THIS PARTICULAR. BILL I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY WE PROVIDE
PATHWAYS- FOR THOSE WHO WERE
REHABILITATED WHO. SERVE THEIR
TIME- BUT I ALSO WORRY ABOUT.
THE BURDENS THAT WERE IMPOSING
ON BUSINESSES ACROSS THE BOAR
HERE IN THE STATE- IT DOES
STRIKE ME I CERTAINLY RESPECT.
THE FACT THAT LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION A BODY ON WHICH I
SAID IS SUPPORTING THIS BILL-
THE FACT THAT I CHAIR NOVELS
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BUT BUT I DO HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW REDUNDANT THIS BILL IS
WHAT THE COST OF THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE BOTH THE STATE. I
ENTERED THE BUSINESSES AND THE
PROFESSIONALS THAT IT WILL
IMPACT. AND I KNOW THAT THIS
BILL AT THIS POINT DOES NOT HAVE
A FISCAL IMPACT- IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS UNDER STUDY- SO
I GUESS MY QUESTION TO CHERNOV A
INTO THE AUTHOR IS. I DO WE HAVE
ANY SENSE OF WHAT THE POTENTIAL
COST MIGHT BE- AND DO WE HAVE
ANY SENSE OF AGAIN MAY MAYBE
THIS IS ALREADY BEEN. ANSWERED
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE BUT- YOU
KNOW IS THERE A WAY TO REDUCE
THE REDUNDANCY OF THIS BILL SO
THERE'S NOT CREATING OVERLAPPING
REGULATIONS OF THE KIND THAT TOO
MANY PEOPLE. IN MY DISTRICT-
COMPLAIN ABOUT. DOES THE RANGE
THE CHECKOUT PERSON YES ALL OF
OUR LIVES. THE REDUNDANCY I'M
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION ON THE REDUNDANCY YOU
KNOW IT THE- YOU KNOW A SPORTING
COMMISSION- IS INDEPENDENT TO
SOME DEGREE IN IS GOING TO HAVE
TO. YOU KNOW FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT THIS
INFORMATION ON. THEIR WEBSITE
BUT I THINK THAT'S NECESSARY AS
PART OF THE BILL- ACCOMPLISH THE
GOALS OF THE BILL AS FAR AS THE
COST- I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE THAT
WORKED OUT IN APPROPRIATIONS. I
SAID ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SO I'M ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT COSTS TO THE DIFFERENT
BOARDS AND GROWS ON THIS AS WELL
SO WILL BE TAKEN IN OVER THE
PHONE THAT TO THE PROCESS AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO.
US CENTER MAN ONCE THAT FISCAL
ANALYSIS IS DONE. THANK YOU AND
THEN JUST A FOLLOW UP I'D SAY I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY JUST
GIVEN THE LEVEL OF LIVER
COMMISSION SUPPORT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AND A GOOD SIGNAL- BUT
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS
THIS BILL MOVES ALONG TO.
IDENTIFY THE COSTS AND THE
BENEFITS RIGHT HAVE A GOOD SENSE
OF- YOU KNOW WHETHER THIS BILLS
GETTING A BANG FOR THE BUCK WELL
I'M HOPEFULLY THE BENEFIT IS
THAT MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNEMPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME AND THEIR DEBT TO
SOCIETY WILL BE ABLE TO COME
BACK INTO SOCIETY AND BECOME
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS AND WORK
ALONGSIDE WITH ALL OF US. TO
MAKE A BETTER CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU SACRAMENTO CENTER JONES.
HELLO JENNY FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SENATOR
JOE VOTE. GOOD MORNING THIS
CHERRY MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE- AUTHORED THE BILL
CENTER JONES FOR THE WORKING OUT
LEADING THE EFFORT HERE HI HE
SAID AND PUBLIC- AND LABOR. AND
PUBLIC SAFETY AND LABOR AND I
HAVE TO SAY MANY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAD IN BILLS THAT WE
SEE- COMMITTEE ARE BILLS WITH
REGARDS TO TRYING TO FACILITATE
PEOPLE COMING BACK AND BE ABLE
TO HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
ONCE THEY HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME
SAID THIS BILL IS JUST A- VERY
COMMON SENSE LOGICAL BILL FOR
ONE TRANSPARENCY INTO TO MAKE
THE PROCESS A LITTLE MORE
EFFICIENT FOR CHRISTY FOR PEOPLE
AFTER THE TIME AND NEED TO START
PRESERVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO. BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THEMSELVES
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THE LEAD ON THIS AT SENATOR
JONES AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR HOLLINGS ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SAYING NO MICROPHONES UP CENTER
JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANKYOU MISTER CHAIR CURRENT A
LOT FOR LICENSURE IS TOO UNCLEAR
FOR FORMERLY INCARCERATED
POPULATION- BY STREAMLINING THIS
PROCESS AND PROVIDING ACCURATE
INFORMATION ONLINE. PLATFORMS
THE BUSINESS LICENSE APPLICATION
PROCESS WILL BE MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND ACCESSIBLE
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS AYE ASTOR
AYE VOTE THIS MORNING THANK YOU
SIR DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE.
FEDERAL SHOW BOAT AND MOVE THE
BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS. AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY MADAM STEP
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL ONE THREE SIX FIVE
DO YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY ROTH
LINE ROSS I'M MELINDA'S.
ARCHULETA ARGILLITE I'D- BACKER
. BAKER AYE DODD. DODD AYE
EGGMAN HER TADO JONES HI JONES I
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MIN MIN HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE A TO A BOGUS A
QARABAG IPN N. I WAS TEN VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. LET'S MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SEVEN CENTER
LEARNED IS BEEN SITTING
PATIENTLY. SO YOU HAVE TO BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY WILL START
WITH SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY EIGHT
IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND MEMBER SENATE BILL
TEN SIXTY EIGHT REQUIRES GOBIZ
TO DEVELOP ECONOMIC FORECAST
THAT INCLUDE CLIMATE IMPACTS AS
PART OF THEM. IN TWENTY TWENTY A
TEAM OF RESEARCHERS STUDIED TE
NATIONWIDE IMPACT OF
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WILDFIRE SEASON AN ESTIMATED ITS
ECONOMIC DAMAGE TOLD AT ONE
POINT EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS A
REPORT PUBLISHED BY THE
RESEARCHERS AT THE UC MERCED
WATER SYSTEMS MANAGEMENT LABS
FOUND THAT RECENT REDUCTIONS IN
RAIN WATER. RESULTED IN AN
ESTIMATED THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES OF
CROPLAND LEFT DRY AND ON PLANET
IN THE GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA
ALONE RESULTING IN SUBSTANTIAL
ECONOMIC IMPACT. AS OF NOW
THERE'S NO STATEWIDE ENERGY THAT
IS MEASURING THE EFFECTS THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HAVING ON THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC OUTPUT. TO
INFORM POLICY MAKING AROUND OUR
EFFORTS TO COMBAT THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE NEED TO HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
THSE CLIMATE EVENTS ARE
AFFECTING THE STATE'S ECONOMIC
OUTPUT. WE SHOULD TAKE KEY DATA
POINTS BASED ON THE CONTINUED
INCREASES IN WILDFIRES ACROSS
THE STATE. THE REDUCTION OF
SNOWPACK IN THE SIERRA AND MORE
AND MAP THEM INTO AN ECONOMIC
FORECASTS THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
FINANCIAL IMPACTS OF THESE
EVENTS. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO. I AM HAVING CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WITH APPROPRIATE
STAKEHOLDERS TO DETERMINE HOW
MANY CLIMATE SECTORS WE WANT
EXAMINED EXPECTED COST ESTIMATES
SUGGESTED FUNDING MECHANISMS AND
WHETHER GOMEZ IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE ENTITY TO DO THE
WORK. THIS POINT BILL ENJOYS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE. THANK YOU SIR LET'S
NOW MOVE TO ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FIRST.
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY WHICH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TEN SIXTY EIGHT. SAYING NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SENATE
BILL TEN SIXTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
PLEASE. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR. LET'S NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES FIRST ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. THING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR BUSINESS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY EIGHT.
WE WILL CONTINUE. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO PLEASE.
AND THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN Q.
SIR THANK YOU SIR OW FOR.
BRINGING THE MATTER BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE FLOOR
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
PANFILO BY SENATOR BOOKER. THANK
YOU. CENTER LAYERED FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I CERTAINLY
STRONGLY AGREE WITH THE PURPOSE
OF THE BILL WHICH IS TO BE SURE
WE INCORPORATE- CLIMATE CRISIS
INTO OUR ECONOMIC. FORECASTS ARE
I THINK YOU TOUCHED A LITTLE BIT
I WAS SHARING CONTENT AND TERMS
OF- BUT THIS IS ASKING GOBIZ IN
AN ANALYSIS INDICATED GO
BUSINESSES DO ECONOMIC FORECAST.
SO ARE YOU A TI SORRY DID YOU-
BUT LOOKING AT FOR HAVING
FINANCE ARE ACTUALLY ONLY ALSO
DOES OTHER BODIES WERE ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY DO ECONOMIC FORECAST
TO DO THIS OR ARE YOU STILL
LOOKING AT. HAVING GO BIZ
CENTURIES AGO BIZ IS IT IS THE
START POINT AND- THEY MIGHT BE
IN A BETTER POSITION TO
SUBCONTRACT. WITH SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE HARDER TO
GO THROUGH- DIRECTLY AND IN THE
IDEAL WORLD. WE WOULD HAVE
SOMEBODY LIKE THE ANDERSON
SCHOOL INCORPORATED INTO THE AIR
I THANK THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
RESOLUTION FROM THE BOARD OF
REGENTS AND DO ALL THIS STUFF IN
SO I THINK WE WOULD PURSUE
THINGS LIKE THAT AND SEE IF THAT
WORKS AND IF WORSE COMES TO
WORSE. GOBIZ COULD SUBCONTRACT
WITH THEM AND GET AROUND ALL THE
OTHER REQUIREMENTS THAT MIGHT
SLOW IT DOWN AND DECIDED THAT
THEY COULD DO IT SO FOR US IT'S
JUST AS YOU SAID WE WANT TO DO
THIS ORDER SEARCHING FOR
MECHANISM THAT WORKS IN THE BEST
WAY. OKAY AFA PRESHEAF THAT-
LOOK FOR TO THE EVOLUTION OF THE
BILL CLEARLY THE STATE YOU KNOW
AS IT THROUGH BUT IF FINANCER
FOR US L. A. O. OR YOU KNOW EACH
IT CETERA AND- I THINK ABOUT HOW
WE CAN INCORPORATE THAT INTO A
LEASE OR STATE. AND THEN OF
COURSE- IF WE CAN GET A PRIVATE
ENTITY TO HELP DO THAT- OR OR-
OR IT'S JUST. UCLA CONFRATERNITY
AND OUTSIDE ENTITIES- TO HELP
OUT THAT WOULD BE GREAT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SERVICE CENTER BETTER. THANKS
YEAH MY POINT WAS LONG LINES OF
CENTER PANTS SO ITHINK YOU.
ADDRESS IT IS ALSO GOING TO
BRING UP YOUR BRING SOME OF
THOSE ACADEMIC ENTITIES INTO THE
ANALYSIS WHICH YOU ALSO TRUST SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. WELL JENNIFER THE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SITTING NO MICROPHONES UP.
EARLIER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
. JUST I APPRECIATE THE EXCHANGE
AND THEN- I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THE WORK THAT SENATOR
PAN ASKED ABOUT AND TRY TO GET
TO THE RIGHT RESOLUTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR OWN
PHONE THANK YOU SENATOR DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
MOTION BY SENATOR MA'AM. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY
EIGHT TO PASS AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROSS HI ROSS AYE MELENDEZ
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA IBEATS
BACKER. BAKER AYE DODD. DODD AYE
EGGMAN HER TADO JONES LEYVA
LEAVE A AYE MIN. MAIN AYE NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE I TELL ABOUT OKAY A
SHOW ABOUT AYE PAN HAN I WAS
NINE VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THERE
LARGER ON A ROLL MOVED YOUR
SECOND BILL SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FORTY EIGHT SIR WELL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I HOPE I'M ON A
ROLL SO- SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FORTY EIGHT AIMS TO STREAMLINE
THE REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF
ANNUAL CANNABIS LICENCES. BY
ELIMINATING REDUNDANT REVIEW BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL AFTER A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS COMPLETE SEQUEL
BUT WHILE THE LEGAL MARKET
CONTINUES TO EXPAND ILLEGAL
CANNABIS ACTIVITY REMAINS
PERSISTENT AND THIS BILL AIMS TO
ENSURE TAT THOSE ENTERING INTO
THE REGULATED MARKET. BY
SHORTENING THE TIME IT TAKES TO
AND TAINT AND ANNUAL LICENSE
ISSUED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. THE EXISTING
PROCESS IS THIS ONE APPLE CAN
SUPPLY FOR STATE CANNABIS
LICENSE THEY TYPICALLY WORK WITH
THEIR LOCAL JURISDICTION FIRST
TO ATTEND LOCAL APPROVAL. THE
APPROVAL PROCESS INVOLVES
COMPLYING WITH SEQUEL WHETHER IT
RESULTS IN APPLYING FOR AN
AVAILABLE EXEMPTION OR PREPARING
A ROBUST ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
SUCH AS A NEGATIVE DECLARATION
OR AN ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT. WHEN THAT LOCAL PROCESS
IS COMPLETED AND THE APPLICANT
APPLIES FOR STATE COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS LICENSE THE STATE MUST
COMPLY WITH SEQUEL EVEN THOUGH
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE STATE
SEEK WILL REVIEW THE SCOPE OF
THE PROJECT IS THE SAME THAT WAS
ANALYZED UNDER SEEK WHAT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THE DEPARTMENT CAN
RELY ON A LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
COMPLETED ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
BUT MUST UTILIZE ITS OWN
INDEPENDENT JUDGMENT A PROCESS
WHICH CAN RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
TIME AND RESOURCES ASSOCIATED.
WITH FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW ON THE SAME SCOPE OF THE
PROJECT THAT WAS REVIEWED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL- THE STATE DESIRES
TO BRING EVERYBODY INTO LEGAL
COMPLIANCE THERE'S DEADLINES.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO RESOLVE
THIS IN A GOOD WAY THERE'S NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION AND SINCE
THE ANALYSIS WAS RELEASED I'VE
RECEIVED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FROM
THE INDUSTRY KEEVER. GOOD
FARMERS GREAT NEIGHBORS WHICH IS
BASED IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU CENTER LET'S NOW MOVE
TO. THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FIRST WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. REMEMBERS RAND MARTIN
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE PARENT
COME A COMPANY BETTER KNOWN
AROUND THE BUILDING IS KHALIFA
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. YES GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. AN INDEPENDENT
COMPANY SPARK AND CALCRAFT IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT. THING DONE LET'S MOVE
IT WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP ANY
SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU HAVE NOT
ALREADY DONE SO AND WISH TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. MOBILEFIRST ONLINE ONE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
REMEMBER IS THE ALICIA PRIEGO
HERE ON BEHALF OF EVA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HERE IS THE FULL SB. TEN
NINETY SEVEN. NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE ONE OTHER
COMMENT- IN CUBA JUST A MOMENT.
WHO NINE ONE FIFTEEN DURING Q.
HE MAY HAVE MENTAL NUMBER LINE
NUMBER IN LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NO
FURTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS
LET'S NOT FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES FIRST
MOVING TO THE GALLERY ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE. PROMPT ANY
SUCH INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO SENATE
BILL ELEVEN. FORTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THEM. THANK YOU YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO TWO THE
OPPOSITION AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. PHOTO.
MY NINETY FIVE IF YOU WANTED TO
STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE REPEAT THE COMMAND. WE DO
HAVE A FEW OTHERS WAITING FOR
OPERATORS. I'LL GO FIRST ALIGN
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HELLO PLEASE PROCEED. YEAH
THE VISION OF THE. FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANKS PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE ONE OH SEVEN. YES THIS
IS SAM RIDDLE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF NORTH COASTAL PAIRED
ASSOCIATIONS MENTAL HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU WE HAVE LINE. FIFTY
FOUR. HI THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTITIONERS
AROUND CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST A
REMINDER TO THOSE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME IN ADDITION TO YOUR
POSITION WITH THE BILL NEXT
PLEASE. MISTER COULD YOU REPEAT
WHICH BILL WERE ON AS WELL WE'RE
ON SENATE BILL. ELEVEN FORTY
EIGHT ONE ONE FOUR EIGHT. THANK
YOU. YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION TO
ONE ONE FOUR EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE ONE THREE. YES MY NAME
IS BECKY RAP I'M WITH UNITED
PARENTS AGAINST LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA AND I. AND AGAIN THE
BILL. ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE
NINETEEN. YES BARBARA GORDON
USED ADVOCATE I AM AGAINST. BILL
ONE ONE FOUR EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WHAT IS. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN. GOD SHIPMENT IN SAN
DIEGO OPPOSED. TO ONE FOUR
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
TALK OUR FINAL LINING KEYLESS
LINE NINETY FIVE. HI I TRIED TO
SAY MY NAME KRLA GET PRIMARY
FROM CALIFORNIA ON THE KIDS
ADVOCATE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL PROTECT OUR CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA PLEASE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
MISTER MODERATOR. NOT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS FIRST
SENATOR NEWMAN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR MEN AT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO SHY I AM AMONG THOSE
WHO IS OF THE FAIRLY STRONG
BELIEF THAT THE VOTERS. SPOKEN
SPOKE FAIRLY CLEARLY- THROUGH
PROP SIXTY FOUR IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AND SO WHAT WE SEE AT
THIS POINT- BAR CONTINUED
EFFORTS. WELL INTENTIONED YOU
KNOW TO RELITIGATE THIS ISSUE-
BUT WHAT WE WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
DOING IS WE'RE MAKING. THE LEGAL
MARKET FAR LESS COMPETITIVE
AGAINST THE ILLICIT MARKET- AND
THAT RUNS EXACTLY COUNTER TO
WHAT THE VOTERS WANTED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO PRESS SIXTY FOUR SO
I'M I'M I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL- I'D LOVE TO HEAR THE
AUTHORS SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
I AM HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL THAT
AT THE PROTECT. THANK YOU SEVEN
WAS EITHER A QUESTION. YOU CAN
DO THAT IS CLOSER IT'S BETTER
FOR HIM THANK YOU SENTIMENTS
CENTER MEN. I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FULLERTON AND- JUST THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
BILL- AS A LAWYER AS LAW
PROFESSOR I THINK IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE INCENTIVIZE. COMPLIANCE
pWE SEE AROUND THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW IS IMPORTANT. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE SEE WHEN
IT COMES TO MARIJUANA THE
CULTIVATION THE GROWTH THE
DISTRIBUTION THE SALE. OF
MARIJUANA IN THE STATE IS THAT
THOSE WHO PLAY BY THE RULES
THOSE WHO APPLY FOR LICENSES TO
PAY THE FEES AND TAXES I HAVE TO
RUN THROUGH HURDLE AFTER HURDLE-
AND IT IS INCREASINGLY BECOMING-
AS MY COLLEAGUES IMPORTANT
ALLUDED TO IT IT JUST IT NOT. A
COMPETITIVE OR- YOU KNOW
SALVAGEABLE POSITION FOR THESE
FOLKS TO BE AND- WHEN THEY'RE
COMPETING AGAINST AN UNLICENSED
MARKET THAT IS REALLY. ONE THAT
WE DON'T ENFORCE AGAINST THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THAT HAS NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR BREAKING LAW I
SO I THINK WE NEED TO DO WHAT WE
CAN TO MAKE THE LEGAL MARKET
THOSE WHO. FOLLOW THE RULES I TO
TRY TO INCENTIVIZE THEM TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH A STREAMLINED
APPROACH I ALSO THINK WE NEED TO
GO FURTHER AND TRY TO DO WHAT WE
CAN TO ENFORCE AGAINST THOSE WHO
DON'T PLAY BY THE RULES- SO I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
NO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING IT FOR. THANK
YOU A- CENTER MEANT. ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS CALLING
SEEING NO. MICROPHONES IN THE
AIR CENTER LAYERED WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
FROM MY COLLEAGUES AND I THINK
IN MANY WAYS THEY CONSTITUTE A
GOOD CLOSE. LET ME AB ONE.
PERSPECTIVE FROM SOMEBODY WHO
WAS SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES FOR EIGHT YEARS.
BECAUSE OUR DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE HAD TO PARTICIPATE
IN ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS IN
CERTAIN PLACES. AND ONE IN
PARTICULAR STICKS IN MY MIND. IT
WAS IN MENDOCINO COUNTY THERE
WAS A MASSIVE ILLEGAL DIVERSION
OF WATER THERE WAS USE OF
PESTICIDES THAT WERE
QUESTIONABLE. BOB AT AT AT LEAST
ONE OF THEM I DON'T KNOW IF IT
WAS THAT ONE PEOPLE WERE HEAVILY
ARMED. THERE WAS NO STANDARDS OR
TESTING OF THE PRODUCT IS
REQUIRED AND THE VOTERS.
LEGALIZED AS THE VOTERS DID IT
SO IT'S OUR JOB TO BRING PEOPLE
OUT OF THE ILLICIT MARKET AND
INTO COMPLIANCE THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES END ARE. IT REQUIRES
EQUAL ON THE SAME PROJECT ONCE-
SO I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU CENTER RULER DELIVER
MOTION ON SENATE BILL. ELEVEN
FORTY EIGHT MOVED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY PHANTOM
STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WITH. IF SENATE BILL ONE
ONE FOUR EIGHT TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ROSS TIME
ROTH AYE MELENDEZ ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS BACKER. DODD
DODD AYE EGGMAN HER TADO JONES
JONES I LEYVA LEVI MEN. MAN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE I CHAU ABODE
UNTIL ABOUT IPN CAN I. NINE
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. FINNER
WINNER YOU HAVE BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY. THIRTY TWO OF ONE
BILL BEFORE US TODAY AT SENATE
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
PROCEED IN READING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SORRY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR I CALL
YESTERDAY I'M PRESENTING- SENATE
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX. BY WHICH
WILL PROVIDE A CALIFORNIANS WITH
ACCESS TO SAFE AND TESTED
MEDICINAL CANNABIS- BY ENSURING
THAT OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
CITIES IN OUR COUNTIES- ALLOW-
FOR THE SALE OF MEDICINAL
CANNABIS. WHETHER THROUGH RETAIL
OR DELIVERY OR BOTH- TO BE CLEAR
I WANNA MAKE SURE A FEW THINGS
ABOUT THIS BILL. THE PURPOSE IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA AS WE SPEAK
NOW. CATEGORICALLY BANNING ANY
AND ALL SALE OF MEDICINAL
CANNABIS. AND STRESSED MEDICINAL
CANNABIS THIS BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE ADULT USE CANNABIS AND
THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR- THIS BILL IS DIRECTLY
RELATED. TO MEDICAL CANNABIS
WHICH THE VOTERS LEGALIZED IN
CALIFORNIA IN. NINETEEN NINETY
SIX- LEGALIZING MEDICINAL
CANNABIS- AM TWENTY SIX YEARS
LATER- A HUGE SWATH OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES CONTINUE- TO
UNDERMINE- WHAT PROP TWO
THIRTEEN DEAD. BY CATEGORICALLY
BANNING THE SALE OF MEDICINAL
CANNABIS CANNABIS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION. MEDICAL CANNABIS
AS THE VOTERS ARE RECOGNIZED AS
THE SCIENCE RECOGNIZES- IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH VARIOUS
CONDITIONS ON MEDICAL CANNABIS-
REALLY TOOK HOLD IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES- WHEN PEOPLE WHO ARE
DYING FROM AIDS USED MEDICAL
CANNABIS- TO IMPROVE THEIR
HEALTH- AND TO EXPERIENCE LESS
PAIN AND SUFFERING AS THEY
STRUGGLED THROUGH- HIV. ARE WE
ARE THE PEOPLE LIVING WITH
CANCER BENEFIT CANNABIS
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
HAVING BAD SIDE EFFECTS OF
CHEMOTHERAPY ON PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH ARTHRITIS WITH
INSOMNIA WITH A NUMBER OF HEALTH
CONDITIONS OR MEDICAL HANNAH
CANNABIS HELPS PEOPLE BE
HEALTHIER AND LEAD BETTER LIVES
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY THE VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY CALIFORNIA.
LEGALIZED IT AND IN FACT SINCE
CALIFORNIA LEGALIZED MEDICAL
CANNABIS IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
WE. STATES HAVE FOLLOWED SUIT
AND YET IN CALIFORNIA
TRAGICALLY- ACTIONS BY A LARGE
MAJORITY OF CITIES- HAVE MADE
IT. DIFFICULT OR IMPOSSIBLE FOR
PEOPLE TO PURCHASE LEGAL MEDICAL
CANNABIS LEGAL MEDICINE. 62% OF
CITIES 62% MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
CATEGORICALLY BAND. ANY SALE A
CANNABIS LARGEST ADULT USE
MEDICAL CANNABIS AS WELL HUGE
SWATHS OF THE STATE. LITERALLY
PROHIBIT AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT IF YOU ARE SOMEONE LET'S
SAY WHO'S- UNDERGOING
CHEMOTHERAPY OR LIVING WITH HIV
OR HAS SEVERE ARTHRITIS OR
ANOTHER HEALTH CONDITION WHERE
YOU WILL BENEFIT. AND YOU ARE
BENEFITING FROM THIS ON CANNABIS
YOU HAVE TWO CHOICES. EITHER TO
HAVE TO TRAVEL SOMETIMES VERY
LONG DISTANCES TO OBTAIN LEGAL
MEDICAL CANNABIS OR MORE LIKELY
YOU'LL SIMPLY BY IT ON THE
ILLICIT MARKET AND I AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE THE PREVIOUS
BILLS. THAT THIS CRIMINAL
EFFECTIVE CRIMINALIZATION.
BANNING. SUSAN THE LEGAL SALE
AFFECTIVELY FUELS ILLICIT MARKET
AND FORCES PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HEALTH CONDITIONS THE BY WHEN
YOU LISTEN MARKET WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME ASSURANCE OF
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR THE
SAFETY OF THE PRODUCT THAT THEY
ARE PURCHASING NOW THE REASON
WHY CITIES ARE CURRENTLY AT
LEAST ARGUABLY ALLOWED TO BAN
THE SALE MEDICAL CANNABIS
THERE'S CURRENTLY A LEGAL
DISPUTE ABOUT DELIVERY BUT THE
COURTS TO ADDRESS THAT THE
REASON IS. THAT AFTER PROP SIXTY
FOUR PASSED WHICH- AUTHORIZES
CITIES THE LOCAL CONTROL TO
ALLOW CITIES TO BAN THE SALE OF
ADULT USE WITHIN THEIR
BOUNDARIES AND WE'RE NOT
TOUCHING ON NORTH PROBABLY COULD
WAIT. THE LEGISLATURE THE NEXT
YEAR AND PASSING IMPLEMENTING
LEGISLATION FOR PER PROP SIXTY
FOUR- WITHOUT BEING REQUIRED TO
DO SO THROUGH IN MEDICAL
CANNABIS AND AUTHORIZED CITIES.
TO BAN THE SALE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION- THAT WAS A MISTAKE
I AM AND THIS LEGISLATION WILL
HELP WALK OUT BACK. ON WHAT SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX DIES THERE'S A
SAYS THE CITY'S YOU YOU CAN
DECIDE HOW YOU'RE GOING TO GRAD
ALLOW LEGAL MEDICAL CANNABIS
CELLS IN YOUR BOUNDARIES. YOU
CAN AUTHORIZE DELIVERY YOU CAN
AUTHORIZE STOREFRONTS CAN
AUTHORIZE BOTH- YOU WILL HAVE
BROAD LATITUDE IN DECIDING-
LIMITATIONS AS LONG AS IT'S
REASONABLE AND ARE NOT
EFFECTIVELY BANNING IT IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBERS AND SO FORTH-
AND- THAT'S ALL YOU HAVE TO DO.
IS JUST CAMPAÑA EVERYTHING I'M
SO COLLEAGUES THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ACCESS- BILL I
APPRECIATE ALL THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BOATS- WITH ME HERE TODAY- TO
TESTIFY ON HIS AB JENKINS WERE
BELIEVERS HERE IN PERSON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. AND THEN APPEARING
BY TELEPHONE IS DEL GARINGER
FROM CALIFORNIA. A NORMAL. THANK
YOU SO AS JENKINS PROCEED THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX THE
MEDICINAL CANNABIS PATIENTS
RIGHT ACCESS ACT. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION WHICH WILL RESTORE
MUCH NEEDED ACCESS TO LEGAL
MEDICINAL CANNABIS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA WAS THE
FIRST STATE TO LEGALIZE MEDICAL
CANNABIS WITH THE PASSAGE OF
PROP TO FIX TWO TO SEVENTEEN THE
PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY FOUR A
DECADE LATER HAS LED TO FEWER
LEGALLY PERMISSIVE. PERMISSIBLE
CANNABIS RETAILERS IN THE STATE
THAN THERE WERE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IN OTHER WORDS MEDICINAL
CANNABIS IS HARDER TO FIND THAN
IT WAS A DECADE AGO WHILE
ESTIMATES VARY IT IS BELIEVED
THAT MORE THAN 65% OF
CALIFORNIANS TWO THOUSAND PLUS.
MEDICINAL DISPENSARIES SHUT
THEIR DOORS BY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DEPRIVING MEDICAL CANNABIS
PATIENTS ACCESS TO SAFE QUALITY
TESTED PRODUCTS ACCORDING TO
REPORT PUBLISHED BY POLITICO
THERE WERE APPROXIMATELY TWO
LEGAL DISPENSARIES PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE ONE
OF THE LOWEST RATES IN THE
NATION. AMONG STATE SUPPORTING
LEGAL CANNABIS SALES THE ROOT OF
THE PROBLEM CAN BE FOUND IN PROP
SIXTY FOUR IS DUAL LICENSING
STRUCTURE WHEREBY CANNABIS
BUSINESSES MUST BE LICENSED BY
BOTH THE STATE AND APPROPRIATE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO OPERATE.
ACCORDING TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE OUT OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY JURISDICTIONS VOTED IN
FAVOR OF LEGALIZATION GET TO
DATE TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES STILL PROHIBIT COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS RETAIL. PROP SIXTY FOUR
INDIFFERENTLY TRIGGERED THE
CLOSURE OF THOUSANDS OF
MEDICINAL CANNABIS DISPENSARIES
AND THE CREATION OF NEW DRY
ZONES ACROSS THE STATE.
UNLICENSED CANNABIS BUSINESSES
HAPPENED A MONOPOLY ON CANNABIS
COMMERCE AND THIS IS NOT A THREE
THEORETICAL ISSUE BUT A HUMAN
ONE. CANCER PATIENTS LOOKING FOR
RELIEF FROM PAINFUL SYMPTOMS AND
TREATMENTS VETERANS LOOKING FOR
NON PHARMACEUTICAL ALTERNATIVES
FOR PTSD RELATED SLEEP ISSUES
AND STRESS AND CHRONIC PAIN
SUFFERERS. LOOKING FOR SAFE LONG
TERM ALTERNATIVES TO OPIATES
OPIOIDS THESE ARE THE PEOPLE FOR
WHOM CALIFORNIA WROTE THE
COMPASSIONATE CARE ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. AND THE
PEOPLE TO WHOM WE OWE A DUTY OF
LOYALTY TODAY. SB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX DOES NOT SEEK TO OVERTURN
LOCAL CONTROL OR PREVENT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FROM JUST SAYING
NO TO ADULT USE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES. IT SIMPLY PREVENTS
JURISDICTIONS FROM BARRING
PATIENTS FROM ACCESSING THE
MEDICINE THEY NEED FOR THESE
REASONS C. C. I. A. IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MS JENKINS MR GARINGER. BONTA
YOU- THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE. ALL FROM REPRESENT
CAL NORMAL WEAR ORGANIZATION
FORMERLY. LAW EIGHT BECAUSE- CAL
MEDICAL. YOU SHOULDN'T. BOB HE
ARMED TWENTY FOUR YEAR
CALIFORNIANS PASSED THE
COMPRESSION YOU CRACKED LAW. TO
LEVINE WOULD BE FREE AND
AFFORDABLE. WITH MARIJUANA ALL.
ARTICLE ONLY EARLY TUESDAY TO.
ARE YOU SORRY SAY THAT- HOW- HE
SHE A LEGAL RIGHT.
LARA CROFT. THEY'RE THE RESULT
WE CONTINUE TO HEAR. WELCOME
POINTS FOR MEDICAL PAGE WHOSE
THE BASE CARE CANNABIS BE IN
THEIR LOCAL. SOME RAMPS TRAVEL
TO OUR- WHEN YOU'RE A QUICK.
FROM WHAT I SAY ALL. DO NOT
FIFTY PAST THE EVIDENCE FOR.
WANT MEDICAL VALUE ONLY-
INVALIDATED IN RIVER BY THE NAME
CARRIER OF SCIENCES THE U. MORE
HELP FOR. INDIAN STUDIES ARE CAL
GROWN FOR CANNABIS RESEARCH.
WHICH IN PARTICULAR HAS THAT CAN
IS EQUALLY AFFECT. IN HELPING
ONLY CHRONIC PAIN ARE YOU CAN. I
COULD NOT LITTLE BE TREATED
OPIATES AND OTHER. WE NOW IN
SCORES OF STUDIES WILL BE IN
THOUSANDS OF SHOPS.
RUBBLE GETTING MEDICINE YOU
CALIFORNIA. WE APPRECIATE THE
PROSPECTS FOR REQUIRES LOCAL
OPTION FOR ADULT USE SALES
HOWEVER PROPERTY FOR ALL
EXCLUSIVELY BECAUSE. NOT
OVERWRITE- ALL RIGHT OFF THE BAT
YOUR FIFTEEN HELLO GOVERNMENTS
HAVE NO MORE RIGHT BAM OR PETER
THE ACCESS TO MEDICINE CAMERA
THE BAND ACTUAL OTHER LEADING
PROBLEMS HE PARMA. R. WE IN
ORDER ARE WIENER SPA THE BUILDER
OUR WE THIS. ARBOREA PROHIBITING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM. EATING
LEGAL ACCESS TO MEDICINAL
CANNABIS REQUIRING YOU TO OUR-
TRUMP OF LEGAL DELIVER MORE
OPTIONAL. FOR- NO GOOD REASON
FOR ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO FIX
COULD BE STOPPING LEGAL RIGHT TO
REPORT THE LATEST WE CLING THANK
ASSEMBLY FROM THERE WE RESPONSE
HOWEVER HE AND RESPECT URGE YOU
ARE ABLE TO THE DEBT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR LET'S NOT MOVE TO
ANY OTHER WITH AND WHICH TO TEST
IN SOME ANY OTHER WITH IN THE
WHO TO. IN SERVER STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR PER PLEASE HELLO
MR CHU MEMBERS BY WEBER HERE
WITH A GROUP ON BEHALF OF LEAVE
AND PER TEAM AND SOME THANK YOU
SIR NAY PLEASE. THIS IS YOUR
MEMBERS RAN NUMBER OF THE
COMPANY AND SO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. WHICH TO. IN SOME.
SEEING NONE MOVE TO WIN. WERE
THE TEST VIA THE TOLL CARE OR
WAS. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT.
ANY SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL. ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
AND HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'LL GO FIRST
TO LINE ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX
TORRANCE THE STRATEGY THREE
FIFTY ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. PINE. FIFTY FOUR. FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL MOVE ON
TO LINE TWENTY NINE. NINE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKS
PLEASE GO TO LINE. ONE THIRTY
ONE THREE ZERO. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS THIS IS EDWIN MORE
BOND ON BEHALF OF CANDOR CRACKED
AND SPARK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. FINE. ONE
THIRTY NINE. HELLO NARVASA ON
BEHALF OF DR BRONNER'S- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU KNOW FOR THE LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
SUPPORTERS LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. FIRST ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEVISION SERVICE. I
UNDERSTAND I HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. AND A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WHO WERE ON THE LINE.
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX.
PLEASE PROCEED. MORNING
PERFECTLY. ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION THAT THE ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX LOCAL CONTROL IS
CENTRAL TO THE PASSAGE OF BOTH
THE ORIGINAL MEDICAL CANNABIS
REGULATION AND SAFETY ACT AND
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR THE KIND
AND THE COMBINED NUMBERS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS REGULATION
WAS NEVER INTENDED TO COMPEL THE
FITTING OF CANNABIS BUSINESSES
FOR LOCAL CONDITIONS MADE ANY
PORK THAT OTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WERE AND REMAIN IN
CRITICAL PARTNER CANNABIS
REGULATIONS WITHOUT GOOD WILLING
PARTICIPATION THIS PROGRAM
CANNOT SUCCEED SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX TO DISREGARD THE THINK TANK.
I FEEL OF AN EIGHTY EXPERTISE
ENTIRELY FROM THE PREMISE THERE
ARE THREE VERY TO MEDICAL ACCESS
AND HELP THIS IS SIMPLY UNTRUE
THIRTY THREE COUNTIES A LOT
MEDICAL AND ADULT USE CANNABIS
BUT YOU CAN FOR A TOTAL OF OVER
TWO SIX NOW FIFTY SEVEN FOUR PER
OF. TWENTY COUNTIES DO NOT CAN
RETAIL AT LEAST ONE IN CITY THAT
AND IN MANY CASES MULTIPLE
THIRTY THREE OF FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY OF SOME SORT OF ACCESS
THAT COVERED 99% OF CALIFORNIA.
I THINK ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX IMPAIR
LOCAL CAN INJURE PERMIT CAN
MEDICAL RETAIL NOW IN THE FUTURE
BY BILLION THE ABILITY TO
REGULATE CANNABIS BUSINESSES THE
BILL WOULD PROHIBIT COUNTY-
CITIES FROM ADOPTING REGULATION
FIFTEEN TO I'M REASONABLY
RESTRICT ACCESS THE BROUGHT AN
ENTIRELY OPEN ENDED DEFINITION
OF UNREASONABLE IN THE BILL%
LITTLE MORE THAN A RECIPE FOR
UNENDING LITIGATION FOR MANY
YEARS TO COME FURTHER AMENDING
EXISTING EXISTING LOCAL
ORDINANCES THAT WERE DEVELOPED
AND APPROVED AN OPEN AND PUBLIC
PROCESS WILL POSE A SIGNIFICANT
FISCAL IMPACT ON JURISDICTION.
CANNOT BE RECOUP THE FEES IN
ADDITION AND SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS USING A RETAILER
OR DELIVERY SERVICE WHICH IS
LIKELY THE CAPACITY SMALL
JURISDICTION MARKET CAN SUPPORT
CANNOT RECOVER INFLAMMATORY ****
WITH JUST ONE OR TWO DELIVERY
OPTION FOR THESE REASONS AND
MANY MORE WE OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
ENOUGH FOR. YOU IN ABOUT THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU. LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE YOU ONE
LINE. YEAH THANK YOU CAN SHOW
MEMBERS EVERYTHING THE KIND OF
LOOKING CAL CITIES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITE TO THAT YEAH
LET EIGHTY. WHICH WITH THE
BUREAU UNDER MY LOCAL MAY I'M
THE BIGGEST AND AT THE USE
CANNABIS GROW AND SAFETY ACT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS NOT HER.
BEGINS DONE THEIR IN THE IN OF
TOMORROW KOMMER CANDIDATE
REGULATE. WITH HUNDREDS OF
CITIES ALLOW FOR A WEEK AND
JURISDICTIONS CURRENTLY THE-
LOCAL CANNABIS FOR BOTH NEGATION
AND USE- I WOULD ARGUE
CONSIDERING IT SAID PERCENT OF
THE THAT PROPOSITION FOUR AND
APPROXIMATELY 67% OF THE STATE.
RESIDE IN COUNTY AND CITY WITH
THE DEATH AND ADULT USE RETAIL
WE HAVE DEMONSTRATE COMMITTEE TO
IT ACT. WITHOUT UNDERMINING THE
CONTROL THAT WOULD PROMISING
CITY COUNTY IN NOW. MILITARY TO
HAVE NOT YET MOVED HER
COMMERCIAL CAN SECTOR PACK
HEATING ACTIVITY HAD NOT ONLY
AYE I RETURN BUT RATHER IN OR TO
THE WHAT A PRO FOR THEIR
RESPECTIVE JURISTIC. ANALYZE
NEARBY IMPACT INCLUDING WITH THE
CANNABIS REGULATORY SCHEME AND
HOW THE STATE IS HANDLING THE
BACK ON THE PROVISIONAL LICENSES
PERMITTING ANY. PARTICULARLY ONE
WELL DOCUMENTED THE REGULATORY
CHALLENGES AND THE COMPLEX
MATTER WELL ANY INDUSTRY WOULD
PREFER A SIMPLE EXPEDIENT AND
OVERRIDING LOCAL CONCERNS AND
REGULATIONS SUCH AN APPROACH
MANIFESTLY BAD FOR COMMUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIA AND IT'S NO
DIFFERENT. FOR THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. YEAH MARK TWENTY NINE
AND THEN. WOULD REMOVE EXPORT
TALK. FOR LOCAL JURORS. TO LIMIT
SALE OF THE COULD NOT. STORE
RETAIL SALE. OUR INTENT COMPOUND
INTEREST TO PERMIT THE SERVICES
WELL THE SERVICES ARE OFTEN
EIGHTY BECAUSE OF LOCAL AFTER
DELIVERY ACTIVELY CAN HARDER TO
REGULATE YOUR THE P. AND CONTACT
ARE NOT APPROACHED FOR ALL.
LEGAL ACT IN THE CA THREE COURT
HAD CLEAR THAT LOCAL. KERN HAVE
ABILITY TO RESTRICT PRO CANNA
DELIVER TREND. UNDER MARKERS
THAT AND THEN FILL THE
TEMPERATURE THAT TOOL FROM.
REGULATE TOOL SHOULD BE REJECTED. CHANGING THE LOCAL AFTER THE
RULES WHILE THE STATE IS STILL
IN THE INFANT. PHASE OF THE
REGULAR FOR. WILL BRING THE
PARTNER ENTRANCE THAT EITHER THE
EXIST FOR AWAY. THIS ONE P. THE
BUT- PROP THAT CHURCH HAVE MADE
EXPANDING HANNAH RETAIL THROUGH
THE STATE. THE STRAIN THAT
TRYING TO OUR DAMAGE BY DAY.
NOTED AN ARTICLE LETTER ARE
CLEAR AND POSITIVE. SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX CLIPS IS NOT. AND THE
STATE INTO BACK AT THAT TO THE
ERA OF HAPHAZARD RIGHT. DISTRUST
AND- WE SEE THAT ACCOUNTED FOR
TO OVERALL GOAL PUT FORWARD BY
THOSE WHO TO COME FURTHER ACCESS
. FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE AT
ELEVEN A SIX AND WITH THAT WITH
YOUR NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU
MONTEREY WHICH YOU PROMPT ANY
OTHER WAY. WAITED TO AND
OPPOSITE TO SENATE ALLOW EIGHTY
AND- THERE ARE ANY WILL CONTINUE
WITH THEM. THANK YOU- WE ALREADY
HAVE SEVERAL IN Q. IF ANYONE
ELSE HAS WOULD LIKE TO BUT HAS
NOT PRESSED ONE ZERO YOU MAY DO
SO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE. ONE TWENTY THREE.
DIANNE GRAY NUMBER OF
GRANDPARENTS UNITED AND I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LOSE. NINE
NINETY. HI IN ET AL DONNA I'M
JUST REPRESENTING MY LITTLE BABY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE NINETY. I CAN
ONLY GET FROM MARYSVILLE AND I
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW A GUY GOT
KILLED YOU KIDNAPPED IN THE POT
INDUSTRY RECENTLY IN SAN DIEGO
PROVED THAT CRIMEA'S CULTURED
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ANOTHER
REMEMBER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS BILL SENATE BILL ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX SO WHEN I NEED YOU TO
DO IS GIVE ME YOUR NAME AND THEN
GIVE ME YOUR POSITION. PLEASE
CHARLIE PRIMARY FOR OUR I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT FOR. STATE
AND CRIME THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
PLEASE. FIND ONE THIRTY SO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HARPER FIVE
MILLION ABBOTT AND I STRONGLY OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. ONE FOUR ONE. HELLO THIS
IS KELLY MCCORMICK FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU OPPOSED SENATE BILL ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE FORTY
FOUR. VERBALLY HILLS IN
OPPOSITION SB ELIMINATED. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE ONE FORTY
SIX. HI MY NAME IS KATHLEEN LET
AND ON BEHALF OF COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AGAINST MARIJUANA
USE AND LEGALIZATION ANNA PUBLIC
PRACTITIONER I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. NINE ONE FORTY SEVEN. MY NAME
IS BECKY RAP AND I'M WITH UNITED
PARENTS AGAINST LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
BILL. THANK YOU LEVEL UP THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
ONE THIRTY EIGHT. THIS IS KELLY
O'BRIEN IN SAN FRANCISCO OPPOSE
THIS BILL ALL THE ARGUMENT YOU
CAN USE TO FOUR STARS LITTLE
TOWN TO HELP STRIP JOINTS IF WE
DIDN'T WANT THEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE JUST YOUR
NAME AND POSITION. PLEASE FIND
ONE THIRTY. THANK YOU LINE ONE
THIRTY THREE. HI MY NAME'S
SCALABLE I'M AN ADVISER WITH
EVERY BRING MATTERS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE- BILL LEVIN EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. ONE
THIRTY SIX. HI ERICA HEARING
WHAT THE NORTH COASTAL
PREVENTION COALITION AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. NINE THIRTY FOUR.
EIGHTY ONE HERMOSA COALITION FOR
DRUG FREE KIDS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. Q. NEXT PLEASE
. ONE FORTY. HI THIS IS JOE SWAN
FROM HER MOSTLY BEACH I ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANKS
SIR NEXT PLEASE. NINE NINETY
EIGHT. CARLO PRESIDENT OF
AMERICANS AGAINST LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA WE OPPOSE THIS BILL IT
SMACK IN THE FACE OF THE VOTERS
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. I
AM. ONE OH SEVEN. THANKS PLEASE
ONE OF SEVEN NINETY ONE YOU.
THEY'RE NOT ADELINE OAKLAND I'M
SORRY AND LITTLE HERE WITH NORTH
COASTAL PAIRED ASSOCIATION THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE- COMMISSION
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. PERFECT LET'S
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS STARTING
FIRST WITH SENATOR MEN. THANK
YOU TERRA- I DO HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL AND
I'VE ADDRESS THOSE WITH THE
AUTHOR- YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE- IN
CHARGE OF FORTY MILLION
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE AND- I
THINK THERE IS A PLACE FOR LOCAL
CONTROL A STRONG PLACE FOR LOCAL
CONTROL. AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL IN PARTICULAR THE ONES THAT
WOULD OVERRIDE LOCAL ZONING
AROUND RETAIL STOREFRONTS- THAT
BEING SAID I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR IS WORKING RIGHT NOW- IN
IN TRYING TO NEGOTIATE- ASPECTS
OF THIS BILL WITH OPPOSITION
WITH THE LEAGUE OF. CITIES AND-
I DO WANT TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
MORE TIME TO TRY TO MAKE THIS
BILL IN A PLACE THAT THAT I
COULD BEFORE I WEAR THIS BILL TO
COME TO VOTE RIGHT NOW ON THE
FLOOR I JUST WANNA BE CLEAR I
WOULD NOT VOTE FOR IT- BUT I
WILL VOTE FOR TODAY- JUST
BECAUSE I DO WANT TO GIVE THE
OTHER TIME TO. TO TRY TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND I HOPE
HE DOES THAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SETTLEMENT CENTER PANEL.
THANK YOU AND- YEAH I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- DRESSING
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IN THIS BILL
NOT THAT I'M PERSONALY A BIT OF
A SKEPTICAL ABOUT MEDICAL
MARIJUANA- BUT- I'D THE VOTERS
SPOKE CLEARLY ABOUT ACCESS TO
MEDICAL MARIJUANA AND THEN THEY
SPOKE AGAIN ABOUT ACCESS TO
MARIJUANA. AND AND CERTAINLY
THERE IS. YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME
EVIDENCE FOR. THE USE OF
MARIJUANA TO HELP WITH CERTAIN
CONDITIONS- SO I GUESS THAT THE
QUESTION OF WHAT OPPOSED TO THE
OP THERE IS THAT AND WHAT LANE
FOR SAY THAT- WEALTHY OPPONENTS
HAVE. TESTIFIED THAT. BUT LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF CALIFORNIANS- HAVE
ACCESSTO MARIJUANA MEDICAL
MARIJUANA CHALLENGES IS THAT
WHAT THE- PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
SAID IS THAT ACTUALLY. ALL
CALIFORNIANS SO YOU SHOULDN'T
DEPEND ON WHERE YOU LIVE WELL
YOU CAN GET ACCESS TO MEDICAL
MARIJUANA OR NOT AND SO I
BELIEVE WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
PERHAPS OFFER COMPLETE BY IS
THAT IS LIKELY DOESN'T REQUIRE A
LOCALITY TO HAVE A- STOREFRONT.
JUST THAT IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
STOREFRONT THAT THEY HAVE TO
ALLOW DELIVERY SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN GET GET GET ACCESS AS-
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA SAID PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
MARIJUANA. AND PERHAPS MAYBE CAN
ALSO TOUCH ON WHETHER.
LOCALITIES WOULD BE ABLE TO
PERHAPS. HAVE SOME GUIDELINES ON
THE DELIVERY BUT THEY HAVE TO
SHOW THAT THERE IS DELIVERY
INTERNET ALLOW STOREFRONT AND
THEN SECOND OF ALL IN THE NOW IS
DISAPPOINTED OUT THAT THERE IS
A- YOU KNOW ISSUE ABOUT WHAT IS-
UNREASONABLE AND- MAYBE. JUST
CLARIFY- ACTUALLY EXACTLY HOW
MUCH- SAY DOES A LOCALITY HAVE
UNDER THAT STANDARD TO ACTUALLY-
RESTRICT- IS A STOREFRONT- SO.
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
ADDRESSING THOSE ISSUES I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CENTER POUND. WHY
I'M AND I AGREE WITH YOU THE
VOTERS KALISTA THAT THEY WANTED.
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS I DO JUST WANT TO KNOW-
IN TERMS OF THE TESTIMONY FROM
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT GROUPS. AND
THEIR LETTER I JUST HAVE TO BE
HONEST AND I WORK WITH THESE
GROUPS ALL THE TIME A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR THEM- THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LETTER. IN THE LEAST
SEE SOCCER ROLE COUNTY SO WE
RECEIVED- ON IT IN OUR IN OUR
FUTURE- STILL COLLEGE
STATISTICS. TEXTBOOK IN THE
CHAPTER ABOUT HOW TO MANIPULATE
STATISTICS THAT LETTER SHOULD BE
AN EXHIBIT IN THAT IN THAT
TEXTBOOK I DON'T SAY THAT.
LIGHTLY ON THAT LETTER AND I
HOPE THAT THEY WILL STOP DOING
THIS IS AN EXTREME MANIPULATION-
THE DATA AND IT REALLY PAINTS A
VERY MISLEADING. PICTURE YOU
KNOW TO TALK ABOUT COUNTIES WHEN
COUNTIES ONLY REGULATE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF DISPUTES ON THAT ON
THAT DATA WHEN 62% OF CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA CATEGORICALLY BANUS.
IN TERMS OF WHAT CITIES CAN DO-
AND WE THE CITIES WILL HAVE WIDE
LATITUDE IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
UNDER THIS BILL AGAIN BEING.
CLEAR THERE IS AN ONGOING. STAY
AT THIS ABOUT WHETHER CITIES ARE
ALL TO RISK DELIVERY AT ALL.
THERE'S THAT'S BEING LITIGATED
RIGHT NOW UNDER PROP SIXTY FOUR
AND THE COURTS AND THE END
RESULT IS NOT. ANYWAY TOUCH OUR
WE'RE NOT CHANGING- ANY EXISTING
RIGHTS AND ONE HOUSE. ON THE DAY
TEN- JUST YOU ONLY DELIVERY.
THEIR WINE. AND THEN AND THEN
THEY CAN ALSO WITH DELIVERY
STOREFRONT. THEY CAN PUT AS YOU
KNOW TO REASONABLE- LIMITATIONS
ON AS LONG AS- THAT THOSE LIMIT
THOSE LIMITATIONS. MARIN SO
SEVERE THAT IT EFFECTIVELY- YOU
KNOW- MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
OVERLY HARD FOR PEOPLE TO
ACCESS. AND SO IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER IF THEY GO WITH
STOREFRONT THE NUMBER OF
STOREFRONTS THEY WILL HAVE.
SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY THERE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO ALLOW AS MANY
AS PEOPLE WANT TO BUILD. THEY
CAN HAVE AND REASONABLE
LIMITATIONS IN TERMS OF WHERE-
IN TERMS OF- IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER- SO YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE.
A SMALL TOWN. AND IF THEY GO
WITH STORE FRONT ONE DISPENSARY
MAY BE HIGHLY REASONABLE. IF THE
IF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WHICH
IS AN ISSUE THERE BECAUSE THEY
ALLOW CAMERAS. CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND ONE DISPENSARY.
THAT'S PROBABLY ON REASONABLE
FOR CITY OF ALMOST THREE
MILLION. PEOPLE DAVID CAN YOU
KNOW. THEY DON'T HAVE
STOREFRONTS FOR EXAMPLE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO LET IT BE OPEN
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. THEY CAN PUT
REASONABLE HOURS LIMITATIONS-
BUT NINE YEAR THEY CAN'T BUT IF
THEY SAID YOU CAN BE OPEN ONE
HOUR A WEEK. THAT WOULD CLEARLY
BE. UNREASONABLE ON IF SOMEONE
CHALLENGES THE CITY'S
DETERMINATION OF WHAT'S
REASONABLE. THE CITY WILL BE
THAT THE WHAT WE CALL. AN ABUSE
OF DISCRETION STANDARD WOULD BE
APPLIED. WHICH MEANS THAT AS
LONG AS THERE'S SOME REASONABLE
BASIS FOR WHAT THE CITY DECIDED.
THE CITY WILL HAVE BROAD
LATITUDE- SO CITIES WILL STILL
HI SIGNIFICANT PART. THEY SIMPLY
CAN'T DO ACCOUNTABLE BAN ANYMORE
. THAT THANK YOU IN AND THAT'S
HELPFUL- SO. I THINK. YOU'VE
UNDERSCORED THAT CITY IS THAT
LOCALITIES CITIES AND COUNTIES
WILL HAVE A STILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE- SERVE LATITUDE THANK THEY
COULD ACTUALLY OF- ELIMINATE
STORMS SAY WE WANT A STOREFRONT
AND AGAIN THIS IS A JUST ABOUT
MEDICAL CANNABIS THIS IS NOT
CAMPUS OVERALL THE MEDICAL
CANNABIS THAT THEY WOULD STILL
BUT THEN THEY WOULD STILL NEED
TO ALLOW PEOPLE LIVE IN THEIR TO
HAVE ACCESS TO IT THROUGH THE
LIVERY. SO SO WITH THAT ANY
APPRECIATE CLARIFICATIONS I
THINK THAT THE VOTERS DID SAY
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO MEDICAL CANNABIS AND I THINK
THAT- AND SO THE NINE THEM
DANCE- BY BASICALLY ELIMINATE
ALL OPPORTUNITIES I THINK THIS
IS PROBLEMATIC AND SO BUT I DO
HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH LOCALITIES TO FIGURE OUT
SOMEBODY'S BOUNDARIES BUT WITH
THAT- CERTAINLY- I APPRECIATE
THE RAIN BILL FORD AND LOCAL
SUPPORT THE BILL SO YOU CAN WORK
ON THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR PAN- SENATOR NEW.
JUST A LINE MIGHT SELF WORTH TO
PANIC. AND THE BILL WHEN. THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU. SIGNAL NO
OTHER MICROPHONES IN THE YEAR-
CENTER WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COOK. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER CHAIRMAN BECAUSE I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR- BURKE
HOPEFULLY- MOVING HIS BODY
COMMITTEE TODAY- AS I DO WITH
ALL BILLS EVERYONE OF COURSE
HAVE AN OPEN DOOR WORKING WITH
THE OPPONENTS- WE'VE ALREADY
LAST WEEK MET WITH. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT GROUPS HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING WITH- AND
OFTEN RESOLVING OUR DISPUTES AND
IF THERE IS A PATH TO RESOLVING
DISPUTES THIS IS YOUR YOU KNOW I
WOULD. OF COURSE ALWAYS I PREFER
TO DO THAT SO WILL CONTINUE. TO
ENGAGE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THE CENTER WHERE THE BEEN
MOVE BY CENTER NEWMAN. TO PASS
FOR REFER THE ON GO AND FINANCE.
STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIXTY PASSING REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
REMIND YOU TO PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONE ON WHEN YOU'RE
VOTING. ROTH HI ROSSII MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. B. ZERO. BE NO BAKER.
AYE BACKER AYE DODD ALL RIGHT
DODD AYE EGGMAN. HER TADO. JONES
JONES KNOWN LEYVA. LEYVA AYE MIN
MAN HI NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE AYE
CHAU ABODE. NO ROBERT HAND BY
HAND I. IT IS SEVEN TO THREE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. COLLEAGUES WE WERE
GONNA WILL PROCEED WITH THE ITEM
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN. BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. AND BEFORE SENATOR
BRADFORD TAKES THE MIKE LET ME
JUST REVIEW ONE WHERE WE ARE. IT
IS ABOUT TWELVE OH FIVE TWELVE
OH THREE TO BE SPECIFIC WE HAVE
SEVEN BILLS LEFT TO GO. WE HAVE
A HARD STOP IN THE CHAMBER AT
ONE FIFTEEN SO YOU CAN WORK THE
MATH SO UNLESS WE PICK IT UP. WE
WILL BE RESUMING HERE AFTER
SESSION CONCLUDES UNTIL WE
FINISH THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AGENDA. SO
WITH THAT CENTER BRADFORD YOU
HAVE ONE BILL TODAY IT IS SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN PLEASE
PROCEED IN READING THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN
WHICH IS AIMED AT PROTECTING
PAWN. BOB HUNT CUSTOMERS FROM
IDENTITY THEFT AND ALSO PROTECT
THE SAME CUSTOMERS FROM
POTENTIAL PROFILING BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THIRD PARTY
VENDORS THAT HAVE ACCESS TO
IDENTIFYING CUSTOMER
INFORMATION. FARM BROKERS IN
CALIFORNIA HEAVILY REGULATED AND
PROVIDE A VALUABLE SOURCE OF
SHORT TERM CREDIT TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY NOT OTHERWISE HAVE
CREDIT SAVINGS FOR MONEY TO PAY
AN UNEXPECTED EXPENSE SUCH AS
CAR REPAIR ARMOR MEDICAL
EMERGENCY. PROMPT BURKE POT
BROKERS ALSO SERVE AS A
FINANCIAL SAFETY NET FOR THE
UNBANKED POPULATION AS EVERYONE
WHO SEEKS A PAWN LOAN CAN BORROW
MONEY REGARDLESS OF THEIR
CREDIT. WORTHINESS FOR EVERY
PAWN LOAN EIGHT ZERO NUMBER OF
THE ITEM USE ASK COLLATERAL AS
WELL AS DETAILED PERSONAL
INFORMATION FOR THE CUSTOMER IS
ENTERED INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA UPON. AND
SECONDHAND DEALERS SYSTEM BETTER
KNOWN AS CAPS. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY HIGH PROFILE DATA BREACHES
IN THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
ACCORDINGLY THE POTENTIAL FOR
PERSONAL INFORMATION UPON
CUSTOMERS TO BE LEAKED CREATES A
HEIGHTENED RISK. OF IDENTITY
THEFT BECAUSE THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE LIMITED FINANCIAL RESOURCES
THEY ARE OFTEN LEFT WITH LITTLE
OR NO RECOURSE IN THE EVENT OF
THAT THEIR PERSONAL OR FINANCIAL
INFORMATION HAS BEEN
COMPROMISED. REDUCING THE RISK
OF EXPOSURE OF PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION DURING
SECONDHAND PAWN TRANSACTIONS IS
CRITICAL TO PROTECTING VALUABLE
COMMUNITIES FROM THEFT IN
PREDATORY SCHEMES UNDER THIS
BILL. PAWN BROKERS WILL CONTINUE
TO COLLECT AND RECORD THE SERIAL
NUMBERS OF ALL ITEMS USED AS
COLLATERAL AS WELL AS PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF THE CUSTOMER.
HOWEVER ONLY SERIAL NUMBERS
WOULD BE ENTERED INTO THE CAPS
SYSTEM THEREBY PROTECTING THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
CUSTOMERS. PAWNBROKERS WOULD
STILL BE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION WHEN REQUESTED
ADDITIONALLY I'M AMENDING THIS
BILL FOLLOWING THE COMMITTEES-
WE ARE FOLLOWING THIS COMMITTEE
TO CLARIFY THIS INFORMATION MUST
BE PROVIDED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
IMMEDIATELY UPON REQUEST AND NO
LATER THAN THE NEXT BUSINESS
DAY. I WANT TO THANK TWO
COMEDIANS CHEER FOR THE ANALYSIS
AND RECOMMENDING THIS AMENDMENT.
TESTIFYING TODAY AS FORMER
MEMBER OF BURKE TOOK TO RICO WHO
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA
PAWNBROKERS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MR THREE CO
PLEASE PROCEED. THANKS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANKS HER
BRADFORD APPROACH WORK ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SOLICITATION BUMMER BECAUSE OF A
CONCERN FOR YEARS ABOUT
PROTECTING THE PERSONAL
IDENTIFICATION INFORMATION FOR
THE CUSTOMERS MANY OF WHOM ARE
OUR IMPACT AS MUCH OF MY CENTER
BRADFORD AND RUFFLE UP WITH
LITTLE OR NO RECOURSE IN THE
EVENT OF PERSONAL OR FINANCIAL
INFORMATION IS COMPROMISED MUCH
HAS CHANGED SINCE CAPS FOR THE
CUP REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WHAT
A DEFECT IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
NEITHER LEGISLATORS NOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENVISIONED THAT JUST
TWO WEEKS AGO PRESIDENT BOTTOM
WOULD ACTUAL FORMAL WARNING TO
AMERICAN BUSINESS LEADERS
TELLING THEM TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
COMPANY'S CYBER SECURITY'S
IMMEDIATELY. THE PRESENCE
CONCERNED ARE SHARED BY A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF US SENATORS
HOOSIER LETTER LAST MONTH TO
HOMELAND SECURITY RAISING
QUESTION ABOUT AMERICA'S
READINESS. FOR RUSSIAN CYBER AND
DISINFORMATION THREATS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY- GOVERNMENT ONE
THE WORST. CYBERESPIONAGE
INSTANCE RECORDED THAT WERE ACT
. THOSE INFRASTRUCTURE THREE OF
US FIRMS INCLUDING MICROSOFT.
WHILE IT WAS INITIALLY BELIEVED
THAT THE ATTACK WAS LIMIT US
TREASURY DEPARTMENT. OFFICIALS
LATER LEARNED THAT THOUSANDS OF
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
THE GLOBE INCLUDING NUMEROUS
ENTITIES WITHIN THE U. S.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SUFFER FROM A
SINGLE ATTACK. AND WENT
UNDETECTED FOR MONTHS. WHEN THE
PUBLIC RESPONSE TODAY SB THIRTY
SEVENTEEN THE GOAL WAS
STRAIGHTFORWARD. AFTER LEARNING
ABOUT DATA BREACHES AT EQUIFAX
LARGE RETAILERS OTHER BUSINESSES
AND GOVERNMENTS. ACROSS THE
COUNTRY PUMP BROKERS WANT TO
PROTECT OUR CUSTOMERS FROM
IDENTITY THEFT. WE BELIEVE THE
PROCESS OUTLINED IN THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN ACHIEVE THE BALANCE OF
SAFEGUARDING. THE PRIVACY OF
CUSTOMERS AND ASSISTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH TRACING. AND
RECOVERING. STOLEN PROPERTY. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NUMBER AND
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR SYSTEM FROM THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
THREE COATS. NOW HEAR FROM ANY.
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NO SUCH WITH.
BUT MOVED TO WIN. WERE TO TEST
THE TELE. ORVIS MATTER IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES. WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
LINE WITH AN OPERATOR BE JUST A
MOMENT. THANK YOU.
HER COMMENT COMES FROM LINE ONE
SIXTY SEVEN ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
ELIZABETH O'DONNELL I'M WITH
MARIN RESIDENTS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH CANADA'S POLICIES AND I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NO FOR
THE MIND IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR NOW LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
FIRST WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
IN OPPOSITION. FITTING NINE
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MISSED
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROP ANY
SUCH INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL. THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN WE WILL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU TO SUPPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE.
WE DO HAVE ANOTHER COMMENT TO BE
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT THANK YOU.
PINE ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORY CELLS- ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PLEASURE
OR SELLER OF PROPERTY BEING
REMOVED FROM THE ELECTRONIC
DATABASE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR- AND
PROPONENTS BUT AT THIS TIME ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT MURDERER.
THANK YOU KNOW FURTHER LINES IN
Q. OKAY LET'S BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. YOU KNOW
MIKE'S UP IN THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR. LABOR CENTER
BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ASKED STATE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS STATED
OPPOSITION BY THE SHERIFF'S BUT
I THINK- THE MOMENT THAT YOU-
THIS COMMITTEE HAS SUGGESTED
HELPS IS ALONG THE WAYS OF
ADDRESSING THOSE CONCERNS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER LIVES
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM STAFF
DIRECTOR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB ONE THREE ONE SEVENTY PASSED
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH. ROTH AYE MELENDEZ
ARCHULETA. OUR I'D BEAT. NO
EIGHT NOW BACKER. BACKER I'D
DODD. DODD AYE EGGMAN. FOR TARO
JONES. LEYVA. LEYVA ICEMEN MAN
HI NEWMAN. UNTIL ABOUT. HAN HI
CAN I THE VOTERS SEVENTY ONE
WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR UMBERG ITEM
NUMBER SIX SENATE BILL. NINE
EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR N. MEMBERS I'LL ARE ALSO
THANK- IN ADDITION THE CHAIR FOR
HIS WORK ON THE BUILDING AT
SHAKER- FOR- DANA'S WORK AS WELL
AS THE STAFF'S WORK ON THE BILL-
I THINK THE COMMITTEE HAS
ALREADY BEEN MADE AWARE OF THE
EPIDEMIC WITH RESPECT TO THE
THEFT OF CATALYTIC CONVERTERS SO
I WILL NOT BELABOR THAT POINT-
THIS BILL- PROVIDES THAT- WHEN A
CAR IS SOLD TO THE SELLER- TIME
SALE WILL. FETCH IS THE VIN
NUMBER OR THE LICENSE PLATE
NUMBER ON THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER. WILL ALSO- REQUIRES-
CORPS RECYCLERS OF CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS MAINTAIN RECORDS THAT
DESCRIBE EACH CATALYTIC
CONVERTER WITH SUFFICIENT
PARTICULARITY AND ALSO THEY'RE
BASICALLY BE A CHAIN OF PAYMENT
REQUIRING SOME SORT OF- EITHER
CREDIT CARD OR CHECK OR SOME
OTHER WAY OF MAINTAINING. THE
CHAIN OF POSSESSION WITH RESPECT
TO THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER I
HAVE WITH ME- I THINK
TELEPHONICALLY ALEXANDER. PARK
IN THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
ROSEMARY SHE HAND WITH CONSUMERS
FOR AUTO RESPONSIBILITY AND I'M
SORRY AUTO RELIABILITY AND
SAFETY. WILL TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR WITNESSES PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READING. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU LUCK GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS ALEX PARKIN
AND I'M A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY- WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. IN
EIGHTY EIGHT FOR TWENTY NINE
YEARS FOURTEEN OF WHICH WERE
WITH THE A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AUTO THEFT TASK FORCE WHERE HE
SERVED AS THE DEPUTY IN CHARGE-
ONCE AGAIN I'M NOT GONNA TELL
YOU ALL. ABOUT WHAT A BIG
PROBLEM CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT AS WE ALL KNOW IT- IT'S A
NATIONWIDE PROBLEM AND
PROSECUTORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WE ALL FACE THE SAME ISSUE.
UNLESS THERE'S AN IDENTIFYING
NUMBER ON THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
FOR US TO PROSECUTE THIS AS A
CRIME- EVERYONE'S CAR HAS A- THE
SERIAL NUMBERS COLUSA IN ITS ON
YOUR DASHBOARD ANYBODY CAN SEE
IT BUT WHAT YOU CAN'T SEE IS
THAT ALL THROUGH THE INSIDE OF
YOUR CAR. THAT VIN NUMBERS
DUPLICATED ON EVERY IMPORTANT
SYSTEM EVERYTHING THAT'S
EXPENSIVE INSIDE YOUR CAR THAT'S
WORTH STEALING HAS THE VIN
NUMBER WITH THE EXCEPTION OF A
CATALYTIC CONVERTER- THE REASON
THAT THAT THE- STAFF HAS
EXPLODED LIKE THIS IS BECAUSE
THE PAYS A LOT OF MONEY AND IT'S
VIRTUALLY RISK FREE. UNLESS WE
ACTUALLY CATCH THESE GUYS IN THE
ACT IT'S A REALLY DIFFICULT. FOR
US TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
FURTHERMORE THE TAKE HIS PART
THEY SELDOM A LOT OF MONEY A LOT
FUN THE WAY- A- RECYCLER. AND
DOES THE RECYCLE ALSO. BE HOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR BY SCHOOL GOODS
. BECAUSE UNLESS THERE'S AN
IDENTIFY NUMBER THERE'S NO THAT
WE CAN. THAT THEY STOLEN- THE
DATE- SENATOR UMBERG HIS- YOU
KNOW PUT. ADDRESSES OF THESE
ISSUES IT'LL HAPPEN. IN IF THE
SHOULD GO INTO EFFECT IF THESE
ARE CAUGHT WITH A FEW CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HOLD RESPONSIBLE. FOR THE MORE-
ONCE WE CAN IDENTIFY THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS. THE MARKET
FOR THE STOLEN PARTS SHOULD
COLLAPSE- CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT IS NEVER GONNA GO AWAY
JUST LIKE ALL KINDS OF AUTO
THEFT. WITH THIS BILL SHOULD
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE PROBLEM-
ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT COLLEAGUES
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
CONSIDERING SIMILAR APPROACH TO
IDENTIFYING THESE CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS AND WERE URGING YOU
TO DO TO SAY. IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
THEM OTHERWISE WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK. THANK YOU SIR MS. WHAT
HEREBY RIGHT HERE IN THE LAND OF
THE NUMBERS ROSEMARY HAND I
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY AN INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT OUT I THINK THE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FOR DECADES WE HAVE SPEARHEADED
ENACTMENT OF NEW WORTH LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY TO
INCLUDE PROTECTIONS FOR OWNERS
OF NEW AND USED VEHICLES. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT PASSAGE OF SB
NINE EIGHTY SIX AND APPRECIATE
CENTER ON BURKE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN CHAMPIONING THIS
IMPORTANT AND TIMELY MEASURE
ACCESS CONCORD HAVE TESTIFIED
AND IF YOU'VE. HEARD FROM OTHERS
TODAY. HELLO CONVERTER BACK INTO
PROBLEM NOW. AND ESPECIALLY IN
HELLO. AND I PERSONALLY KNOW THE
VICTIM OF THE- CRY. AND
SOMETIMES THEY'RE TARGETED
MULTIPLE. AND IT COSTS REAL
HARDSHIP FOR THEM NOT ONLY
BECAUSE THEY OFTEN HAVE TO PAY
HALF THE DEDUCTIBLE SOMETIMES
ALSO SEE THEIR INSURANCE RATE
INCREASE. BUT THE HARMFUL FACTOR
OF HAVING TO REPLACE THE
CONVERTER- LOGISTICALLY
SPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE WHO WORK AT
A JOB WHERE IT'S DIFFICULT TO
GET TIME OFF FROM WORK AND- SHE
LEFT THEIR CARD WHATEVER IT
NEEDS TO GO TO BE REPAIRED- IT
CAUSES WILL WELL PROBLEMS. AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR-
BURKE IN THE DRESSING THAT
PROBLEM BOTH. IT THE BEGINNING-
BY RICK DEALER TO SIMPLY THE BAY
. ON THE COULD SO THAT BE TRY
AND ALSO THE OTHER END- YOU BY
PROVIDING LAW FOURTH WITH THE
TOOLS THEY NEED Q. ALSO.
RECYCLERS IF THEY'RE TRAFFICKING
IN STOLEN CATALYTIC CONVERTERS.
WE FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THEIR I
VOTED FOR SB NINE EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOLLARS HERE
FROM ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY SAYING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT. ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
EIGHTY SIX. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN THEIR
OFFICE TO YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. WILL GO FIRST ONLINE ONE
TWENTY NINE. NATIONALS FROM THE
HALF OF THE PROSECUTORS A LINE
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU CAN TELL STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY
TWO. WE'LL GO TO LINE. EIGHTY
SEVEN. HELLO REACH CHRIS ATM
PROCEED. HI MY NAME IS ON THE
BED OF THEM. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
AND I SUPPORT SB. NINE EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
ONE SIX. YES THEY CAN AND MA'AM
KIM CHANG WITH THE ON CLUB
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- URGING A
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. NO FOR THE
LINE THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT THANK
YOU LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION FIRST LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
AND AGAIN- WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
NEW CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION.
SKEWS ME TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION ANTHONY SAMPSON.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
REYES ANTHONY SAMPSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION- YOU'VE
HEARD THIS TESTIMONY ALREADY
TODAY BUT- TO ENSURE THAT THE-
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS THE BENEFIT
OF HEARING MY REMARKS I'LL
REPEAT THEM AGAIN HERE. THE NCAA
HAS TAKEN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON SB NINE EIGHTY SIX
AND APPRECIATE SENATOR UMBERG'S
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN A
DIALOGUE WITH US REGARDING OUR
CONCERNS. BURSAE IN CDA SUPPORTS
THE UNDERLYING INTENT OF THE
BILL AND TO THIS END CURRENTLY
SUPPORTS OTHER CATALYTIC
CONVERTER MEASURES FOCUSED ON
INCREASED ENFORCEMENT. AS IT
RELATES TO THIS BILL C. N. CD'S
CONCERNS RELATE SPECIFICALLY TO
THE REQUIREMENT THE DEALERSHIPS
PERMANENTLY MARK OR ETCH THE VIN
NUMBER INTO THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER BEFORE VEHICLE CAN BE
SOLD. WE'VE BEEN INFORMED. THAT
SOME BELIEVE PERMANENT MARKING
THE VIN NUMBER NUMBER IS SIMPLE
AND INEXPENSIVE. WHAT IS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
MANY VEHICLE MODELS INCORPORATE
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER AS PART
OF THE EXHAUST MANIFOLD
REQUIRING DEALERSHIP TECHNICIANS
TO DISASSEMBLE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE VEHICLE ENGINE
JUST TO ACCESS THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER. BY JUST TWO EXAMPLES
TO PERMANENTLY MARK ONE VOLVO
MODEL WOULD TAKE DEALERSHIP
TECHNICIANS TWO POINT EIGHT FOUR
HOURS THE PERMANENTLY MARKED ONE
VEHICLE DEPENDING ON ENGINE
VARIANTS AND FOR CERTAIN ACURA
MODELS IT CAN TAKE TWO TO FIVE
HOURS. BUT EVEN ASSUMING
PERMANENT MARKING THE VIN
NUMBERS INTO CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS WAS SIMPLE AND
INEXPENSIVE WE WOULD NOTE FOR
THE COMMITTEE THAT MANY OF THE
MOST TARGETED VEHICLES ARE NOT
EVEN BEING SOLD BY NEW CAR
DEALERSHIPS. DATA FROM THE
SERVICE DEPARTMENT OF ONE LARGE
TOYOTA DEALERSHIP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHOWS THAT THE MOST
TARGETED VEHICLE IS THAT IT ARE
THE 200-062-0009 PRIUS IS WHICH
VERY FEW NEW CAR DEALERS EVEN
SELL. RATHER THAN THOSE ARE
OFTEN SOLD THROUGH PRIVATE
VENDORS SELLERS LIKE RECKLESS
EBOOK EBAY MOTORS. AND FACEBOOK
MARKET PLACE YET SB NINETY SIX
DOES NOT SEEK TO REQUIRE
PERMANENT MARKING THROUGH THOSE
FORUMS. WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO
SILVER BULLET SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM AT THE SAME TIME C. AND
C. D. A. WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
SENATOR- BURKE ON A MORE
TARGETED SOLUTION WHILE ALSO
ENSURING. THAT CALIFORNIA'S NEW
CAR DEALERSHIPS ARE NOT SADDLED
WITH THE LABOR INTENSIVE AND
COSTLY OBLIGATION OF PERMANENTLY
MARKING EVERY SINGLE VEHICLE
THEY SELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR LET'S MOVE NOW MOVES FOLLOW
ME ASK ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. THING
NONE LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR. HE WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING%
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY SIX WE
WILL CONTINUE. THANK YOU TO
SUPPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE THE
AMOUNT OF ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WELL THE FIRST LINE FORTY THREE
. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE NUMBERS
OF NEIL CLARK ON BEHALF OF I.
EIGHTY AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO MOST AMENDED TO
PROTECT THE LEGITIMATE
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES POOLS AUTO
RECYCLERS TO SPAM FOLDERS AND
LICENSED WHOLESALERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE ONE SEVENTY
THREE ONE SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. RICHARD SHERMAN MEMBERS
DO FAILED SEPARATE ANY FOR FORD
MOTORS CONCERNS SIMILAR TO THE
DEALERS EXPRESSED EARLIER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
NO FOR THE ON LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
LET'S BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE
FLOOR. RECOGNIZING OUR TIME
LIMITATIONS. ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
PAN. FOLLOWED BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS FARE-
SIR BURKE UP FREESHEET YOU BRING
FORTH THIS BILL WE DID HAVE A
PREVIOUS DISCUSSION HERE TO
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE CONCERNS OF
THE NEW CAR DEALERS- I DO SHARE.
MANY THEIR CONCERNS IN TERMS OF-
SPECIALLY KALECKI BURGERS THAT
MAYBE MUCH LESS ACCESSIBLE WHICH
ALSO MEANS ARE PROBABLY LESS
LIKELY TO BE ACCEPTABLE TO
THIEVES AS WELL. WE DON'T CREATE
ADDITIONAL BURDEN SO PERHAPS YOU
CAN ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS
YOU'RE CLOSE BUT- ASSEMBLY WILL
BE VOTING FOR YOUR BILL TO LET
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BUT
HOPE THAT THAT. THOSE ISSUES
WILL BE RESOLVED BY THE TIME THE
BUILDERS- RIGHT ON THE FLOOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR PENSER
EGGMAN. CENTER EGGMAN HAS MOVED
THE BILL. I SEE NO OTHER MIKES
IN THE AIR CENTER NUMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE UP. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- AS TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO- THIS
IS A- PUBLIC ISSUE ANOTHER WORDS
THAT THE CRIME HAS NOW IS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT REACH EPIDEMIC
PROPORTIONS. IN THE PREVENTIVE
MEASURES TERMS OF THE BURDEN
LARGELY FALLS ON THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND I UNDERSTAND THAT AND
THAT'S A VALUE JUDGMENT WE NEED
TO MAKE. UP IN IN TERMS OF THE
CARS WITH LESS ACCESSIBLE KELLY
CONVERTERS YES WE WILL HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO SEE IF WE
CAN SOMEHOW- REACH SOME SORT OF-
IF NOT COMPROMISE AT LEAST SOME
SORT OF WAY TO IDENTIFY. THOSE
VEHICLES AND- MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT A
MECHANISM TO TRACE KELLY CONVERS
I ACTUALLY THAT'S THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER COUPLE OF THEM DIDN'T
TAKE LONG I REALIZED IT WASN'T A
CAR THAT HAD TO BE DISMANTLED.
TOOK ABOUT ONE MINUTE. AND I'M
INEPT SO SOMEBODY WHO ACTUALLY
KNOWS HOW TO DO IT WOULD TAKE
MUCH LESS TIME- AND FINALLY YES
IT IS IT IS AFFECTING EVERYONE
INCLUDING MY BROTHER AND HIS
FAMILY HAD THEIR CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS STOLEN WITHOUT AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND STAFF DIRECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB NINE
EIGHTY SIXTY POSSUM RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
ROTH ON. ROTH AYE MELENDEZ.
ARCHULETA ARE VIRTUAL OUT IBEATS
. B. FIVE EIGHT FIVE BACK HI
BAKER I DON. DOT AYE EGGMAN
RIGHT EGGMAN AYE HER. JONES
RIGHT JONES I LEYVA. LEAVE AYE
MAN. IN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
CHOSE OKAY I CHOSE BURKE I PM HI
IN. THE VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO HOLD
THE OPEN FOR. ABSENT MEMBERS
THEY MISTER MEMBERS THANK YOU
SIR FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SERVER
GONZALEZ. WELCOME CENTER YOU
HAVE ONE BILL BEFORE US TODAY
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE PROCEED IN READING THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON HERE
TO TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN A BRAND NEW
ISSUE FOR THIS COMMUNITY TODAY-
WHICH WILL PROHIBIT THE PURCHASE
OF A CATALYTIC CONVERTER FROM
ANYONE OTHER THAN AUTOMATE
MOBILE DISMANTLE OURS. AUTO
REPAIR DEALERS OR AN INDIVIDUAL
POSSESSING DOCUMENTATION THAT
THEY ARE THE LAWFUL OWNER OF THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER AND I'LL BE
TAKING AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE
LANGUAGE RELATED TO THE CORE
RECYCLER TRANSACTION
REQUIREMENS TO AVOID CONFLICTS
WITH OTHER MEASURES. VICTIMS OF
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFTS ARE
OFTEN LEFT WITH THE COST OF
REPLACING THEIR CONVERTER WHICH
CAN COST OVER TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT'S BEEN STATED MANY
TIMES THIS IS BECOME
ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGING FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS AND WE KNOW
THAT THEY'VE BEEN INCREDIBLE
THEFTS- AND ISSUE A LARGE
PROPORTION. WHILE OTHER EXISTING
LAWS IN PLACE IN A AN ABUNDANCE
OF LAWS CURRENTLY IN THE WORKS
SB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN ACTUALLY
TAKES A PREVENTATIVE APPROACH BY
CREATING A BARRIER FOR PEOPLE
SELLING DETACHED. CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS IN THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET BY LIMITING WHO CAN
LEGALLY PURCHASE A DETACHED
CATALYTIC CONVERTER AND WHO CAN
SELL ONE. TO A SCRAP METAL
RECYCLER TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE TODAY I HAVE
DANIEL CONVERT PERSKY. VICE
PRESIDENT AT KBI RECYCLING. AS
WELL AS JOSE JOE HETE A
CONSTITUENT FROM THE CITY OF
PARAMOUNT WHO IS HERE TO SHARE
HIS EXPERIENCE AS A VICTIM A
CATALYTIC CONVERTER FACT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON A
SPEECH TEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
SENATOR MR KIM'S FIRST KIÞM
MISTER HER RIVER PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. HELLO HI GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE ON MY OWN MY
NAME IS BEING. WELL PLEASE
PROCEED WE CAN HEAR YOU
PERFECTLY JUST SPEAK UP. SORRY
MY NAME IS DANIEL CAN THIRTY
APPLICATION ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT KATIE I IT LOOKS
COMPANY LOCATED IN I AM
CALIFORNIA WHICH- CURRENTLY
EMPLOYS AROUND EIGHTY
INDIVIDUALS I HAD A COMPANY K<c.cyan></c>
I SPECIALIZE IN THE MANAGEMENT
AND THE LIGHT BATTERY THING
COLLUDING ALL MAJOR FORM
FACTORED IN CHEMISTRY THE THING
CLUES EVERYTHING FROM YOUR
COMMON HOUSEHOLD ALKALINE
BATTERIES ALL THE WAY UP THE
YOU'RE LOGGED THE MOST
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED LITHIUM
ION. BATTERIES. SHOULD ARE ONE
OF THE LARGEST ARE PROFITS IN K.
AND THE BLACK THE CONVERTERS- WE
BEGAN CROSS. CONVERTERS IN MY
EIGHTY FOUR. AND SINCE THAT TIME
KIRCHER IN THE SPECIAL OF THE
MILLIONS OF YOU HAVE- WHEN IT
COMES TO THE- REGARDING THE
PREVENTION CALICO BURKE THAT. WE
OBSERVE WE OCCUPY OF ANY MAN
INTO TO ONLY LEGITIMATE BUSINESS
. ARE INVOLVED AND COLLECT AND
PROCESSING A WEEK AFTER MALE
PLUS. REACHING END OF LIFE CAL
EVERY YEAR. WE THAT BY THE A
TREATABLE LOOKING- ADDING THE
RECORD YOU REQUIRED ALL. OF
WRITTEN. AND PROHIBITING
PURCHASE A CALICO BERNARD FROM
ANYBODY THAN THE FACT. OTHER
NEXT FOLDERS. SB EIGHTY SEVEN A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
HELP HER CATALYTIC CONVERTER
APPS. YEAH WE ARE ALL AWARE THAT
YOU WILL NOT COMPLIANT COURSE
LIKELY REQUIRE OFFER IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE THAT YOU KNOW
COMPLYING CORPORATE CORPORATE
LIKELY. I JUST DON'T WANT TO PAY
CASH ACCOUNT AND BOARD IN ORDER
AND THOSE THAT ARE- IGNORE
PROPER ENCOURAGEMENT SHE FARMING
. LITTLE MERMAID ON. EVEN AT
THAT KENNEDY IT'LL ULTIMATELY
PASS. THAT WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
COMMITTEE AND THE CAL
LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE TO LOOK
FROM BY THE LONG BINOCULARS BE
SURE THEY BEING HOW IN THE SAME
STANDARD AB I. AS WELL AS ALL OF
LEGITIMATE CALL OVER. CALIFORNIA
ALL WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TO
TESTIFY ON THAT BECAUSE EIGHTY
TODAY- WE ARE SUPPORT BY A BILL
THANK YOU YOUR TIME CONSIDER.
WICHITA IN- IT'S STILL VERY
PRICEY TO REPLACE THEM
UNFORTUNATELY- DON'T BY TWENTY
VEHICLES IN- IN A STORAGE
FACILITY FOR THE TIME BEING
WHILE I SAVE THE MONEY. TO BUY
MY NEW TALENT CONVERTERS. THANKS
PLEASE BE DONE ABOUT THIS CRIME
BECAUSE IT'S NOT. IT IS NOT ONLY
THAT I WISH ANYBODY ELSE TO BOTH
. SO I DO SUPPORT IT- AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
LISTENING TO ME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOUR TESTIMONY SIR
NOW LET'S MOVE TO THE GALLERY
ANY WITNESSES. IN THE GALLERY
WHICH TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ANTHONY SAMPSON THE
SAMPSON ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE CAL CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU OULD PLEASE.
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU CAN
DOWNTURN ADVOCACY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE SIXTY. YES
SIR CAN CHANGE WITH THE ARTICLE
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. PINE. EIGHTY
SEVEN. AN ELDERLY RESIDENT OF
SAN FRANCISCO FOR FORTY THREE
YEARS I AM IN SUPPORT SB. TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. NO FOR THE LINE
INTO AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY. THING NO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY LET'S
<c.magenta>OVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO</c>
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. THE SENATE BILL TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WE WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION
ON THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. WE HAVE NO LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MR MODERATOR. NOW
IF THERE'S ANYTHING MORE LEFT TO
BE SAID ABOUT CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS LET ME BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE SENATE FLOOR COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. I THINK WE'LL GIVE THE
MOTION TO SENATOR ARCH ALETTA.
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
AND I WANT TO THANK MR HEAD ON
MY A CITY OF PARAMOUNT RESIDENT
FOR TESTIFYING TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE MOVE BY CENTER
ARCHULETA MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY STAFF
DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY SEVENTY
PASSES AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
ROTH ROTH AYE MELENDEZ ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I'D BE. BEATS I BAKER
. BAKER AYE DODD. DODD AYE
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE HER TADO.
JONES JONES I LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MIN. IN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE A
TO A BOGUS A TOWBOAT IPN. AND I
BILL IS PROVOKED WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FEDERER PORTANTINO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SENATE BILL. ELEVEN
SIXTEEN PLEASE PROCEED IN
READING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU
KNOW HERE'S NO SUCH THING OR NO
BETTER EXPERIENCE THAN BEING IN
A LIVE THEATER VENUE
EXPERIENCING THOSE LIVE
PERFORMANCES COMMUNITY THEATER
IS VITAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA'S BURGEONING AND
CONTINUING THRIVING ARTS
COMMUNITY THINK OF ALL THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO GET EXPIRED BY
THOSE LOCAL COMMUNITY THEATERS
TO GO ON TO STAR IN TELEVISION
AND MOTION PICTURES IN
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP ONE ONE
ONE SIX WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
EQUITABLE PAYROLL FUND- THIS
EQUITY PAY WILL FUND IS A GRANT
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
SMALL NONPROFIT PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THERE ARE
MANY OF THEM IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS THAT NEED OUR HELP
THESE IT WILL IN TURN HELP THE
LOCAL ECONOMY WORKERS AND
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIAL
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR PAYROLL
EXPENSES AND KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
AND THE CURTAINS OPEN IN THESE
THEATER PRODUCTIONS THIS PROGRAM
WILL SUPPORT JOBS FOR ANYONE
HIRED INCLUDING BOTH PRODUCTION
AND NON PRODUCTION EMPLOYEES AS
WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF
THESE NONPROFIT THEATERS DON'T
JUST FUNCTION IN A VACUUM THEY
NEED OUR HELP AND THIS BILL WILL
DO IT THE EPF INVESTMENT IN THE
ARTS WILL HELP ECONOMICS. WE'RE
JUST NOT JUST FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BUT FOR REGIONAL
COMMUNITIES A WELL ACCORDING TO
THE AMERICAN ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICANS FOR THE ARTS THE
AVERAGE NONPROFIT LIVE ARTS
ATTENDEE SPENDS ANOTHER THIRTY
ONE DOLLARS AND FORTY SEVEN
CENTS BEYOND THE COST OF AN
ADMISSION PER PERSON EVERY TIME
THEY SEE A SHOW THAT SPENDING
INCLUDES TRANSPORTATION TRAVEL
CHILDCARE SPENDING AT
RESTAURANTS AND BARS NATIONALLY
THIS AUDIENCE SPENDING IS
ESTIMATED TO EXCEED A HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS SUPPORTING
ANOTHER TWO POINT THREE MILLION
IN JOBS AND GENERATING FIFTEEN
POINT SEVEN BILLION IN TOTAL
GOVERNMENT REVENUE. MUCH LIKE
THE RECENT EMPLOYEE RETENTION
CREDIT PROGRAM OF THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN IN THE CARES ACT
THIS BILL WILL HELP CREATE AND
SUSTAIN JOBS FOR THE CREATIVE
WORK FORCE ONE OF THE HARDEST
HIT WORK FORCES DURING THE
PANDEMIC SADLY MANY OF THESE
THEATERS HAD TO CLOSE THOSE
CURTAINS. AND NOT PERFORM DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE NEED TO HELP
THEM NOW WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
BEATRICE CONCEPT PASS A GUN.
FROM THE THEATER PRODUCERS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ALSO A
REPRESENTATIVE OUR DISTRICT
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE TWENTY
FIFTH STATE SENATE DISTRICTS.
AND WE HAVE MARTHA DENNISON FROM
THEATER PRODUCERS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. BY THE WAY
BEATRICE'S FROM A FEW YEARS
JUMPED A GREAT NONPROFIT THEATER
. WHAT THIS IS PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR
BEING SUCH A CHAMPION OF SMALL
PERFORMING ARTS MY NAME IS ON
THE INTEREST RATE ON THE
PRODUCING ATISTIC DIRECTOR FOR
A FUTURE PRODUCTIONS ARE VICE
PRESIDENT THEATER- COULD YOU CAN
EASILY GET FUNDING CALIFORNIA
AND A PROUD MEMBER OF BOTH THE
STAGE DIRECTORS AND
CHOREOGRAPHERS SOCIETY. AND AN
ACTIVE EQUITY. REALLY JOHN- JP
FOR SHORT IS A TEN YEAR- B. I.
WOMEN READ COME WITH ANNUAL RED.
UNDER TOO MUCH AND FIFTY. IS
DIRECTLY OKAY HE HAD. ACCESS TO
PUBLIC FUNDING AND NO ACCESS TO
FUNDACION SOUNDING. THE LATINO
IMMIGRANTS I DON'T HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF GENERATIONS OF
NETWORKING AND- LARGE PRIVATE
FUNDERS. NEVER ONCE DID HE HAS
ALWAYS. BEEN COMMITTED TO PAYING
ARTISTS. YOUR THE PANDEMIC DOWN-
DID HE WAS. ABLE TO ACT STATE
AND THAT GRANTS THANK YOU- IF WE
DO WITH MONEY WE HIGH WORKER TO
HELP AND SERVE A WIDER. EXPAND
OUR PROGRAMMING AND IMPLEMENT
IMPORTANT GROWTH STRATEGY HE
DATE- JP HAS TWENTY ACTIVE
EMPLOYEES RECEIVING REFLECT A
HIGHER EIGHTY ARTISTS. AND OTHER
PRODUCTION WORKERS. WELL HE IS
JUST WONDERFUL COMPANY BUT WE
ARE TYPICAL OF THE JOB CREATION
POTENTIAL FOR THE TOPIC FOR ME
AFTER. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FIFTEEN IN THE JOB CREATION
CATALYST AND HALFWAY DID WELL
INSTABILITY. OUR BIGGEST FEAR IS
THAT AS A PANDEMIC SIDE WE WORK
WITH. ARE GREETED ME IS SECOND
DON'T WE- SMALL. ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT AT
ELEVEN. IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTION
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ROOM THAT PLEASE.
HI GOOD SENATOR OUT MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE MAY NAME IS NOT DENSON
. I THE PRESIDENT OF THE THAT
THE PRETTY I THE PRODUCERS OF
AND- COAST OF THE BILL BUT I AM
HERE. ON THE OF LARA DR. THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
BUSINESS AND MANAGEMENT THE
AUTHOR CLAREMONT. YOU THESE
REMARKS ARE HERS. THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR PROVIDING
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL THE
TALKS REALLY WELL WHEN
MANAGEMENT AND WEBER COME
TOGETHER TO ADVOCATE FOR
LEGISLATION BUT THIS IS THE CASE
WITH SB ONE ONE ONE SIX. ACTORS
EQUITY AND THE THEATER PRODUCERS
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AGREED
THAT THIS LEGISLATION IS FEDERAL
AND THE SOLUTION TO A CRITICAL
PROBLEM. SOUTHERN METHODIST
UNIVERSITY WAS RELEASED A REPORT
JUST LAST WEEK TO CONFIRM BUT
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE ARTS WAS
DOUBLE THAT OF OVERALL NATIONAL
UNEMPLOYMENT DURING THE PAST FEW
YEARS. AND BY PART OF DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND JOBS IN THE
NONPROFIT ARTS IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH MEANS IT'S STILL AN
IMPORTANT APPOINTMENT SECTOR.
BUT THE FIGURE REPRESENTS A LOT
OF ALMOST. ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
JOBS DURING THE PANDEMIC. NO
REPRESENT A REAL. WAY TO ADDRESS
A LOT OF THESE. AND GROUPS.
ABOUT PASTOR WITHIN. CAN TO
SERVE THE SAN INTO THE- OF
MARCUS. ARTS ARE ABLE TO USE THE
CENTER TO BRING ARTISTIC. AND
PERSONNEL BACK ON TO PAYROLL.
WILL BE ABLE TO PRODUCE WHAT
WILL BRING ADDITIONAL AND REV.
HAS LED BY SPAM THE L. FROM
GRANTS ONLY. WILL WHICH WILL
PROVE A BRIDGE TO SUSTAINABILITY
. I'M ALSO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NO ANSWER FROM ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY SAYING
NONE LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
VIA TELECONFERENCE ARVEST.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL. ELEVEN SIXTEEN
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU THE
STATE OF FOR THIS PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
YOU CAN THAT'S ONE FALL BY ZERO.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS EILEEN
AND DISSENTERS I AM THE CO
ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF GROWTH
MACHINE THEATER IN LOS ANGELES I
AM A MEMBER OF THE STAGE AND
DIRECTORS GOING TO
CHOREOGRAPHERS- UNION. AND I
TEACH CHILDREN PLAY WRITING AND
STORYTELLING AND I AM IN. BUT
MOST SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SIXTEEN
BECAUSE IT SUPPORTS EQUITABLE
JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
BUILDING OF COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU THANK YOU ROOM NEXT PLEASE.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. CLARK DUGGER ONLINE WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF DESERT HEATERS IN
THE COACHELLA VALLEY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
TWO. I AM HE WAS KNOCKING FEHLEN
I'M MANAGING DIRECTOR OF THE NEW
AMERICAN THEATRE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF BILL ELEVEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. FINE. ONE FIFTY THREE.
HI MY NAME IS ON MONDAY A WEEK
THAT I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF GUY LIKE PETER COMPANY IN
LAFIA CALIFORNIA A SMALL CARE
WILL BE DEVELOPED NEW PLAY THAT
HAVE GONE ON TO BIGGER STAGES IN
L. A. AND EVEN OFF BROADWAY-
CALLING ABOUT MY SUPPORT FOR SB
ELEVEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO. BY
EDITOR ANTHONY ARTISTIC DIRECTOR
OF MOVING ARTS IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING OF MY
SUPPORT FOR AT THREE ELEVEN
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERSBUDGET
OFFICE CALLING ON BEHALF BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA ARE ADVOCATE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS WAS. NO FOR THE MINDSET
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SIR A LIST
OF ALL THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
FIRST OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY. THING NINE LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITED
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL. ELEVEN SIXTEEN
WE WILL CONTINUE WITH THEM. TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR PHONE WE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU BUT RARE LET'S
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR DOES MOVE THE BILL WHAT
APPROACH. THOSE BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DODD. I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES UP. SENATOR
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A
STELLAR ADLER SAID STELLA ADLER
SAID THE THEATER IS A SPIRITUAL
AND SOCIAL X. RAY. OF A IT'S
TIME THANKS MAKE LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP THE STAGES OPEN AND
AS OUR GANG IN THE LITTLE RASCAL
SAID HEY KIDS LET'S PUT ON A
SHOW I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR. PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT.
BENHAM STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATE BILL ONE
ONE ONE SIXTY PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT ROTH.
ROTH AYE MELENDEZ ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA IBEATS. BAKER I BAKER
AYE DODD AYE DODD AYE EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO FURTADO I'D
JONES. LEYVA LEYVA AYE MAN MAIN
AYE NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE AYE
CHAU VOGUE. HIAN HI CAN I WAS
TEN VOTES WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA
START RUNNING DOWN THE LIST WE
HAVE- MEMBERS BILLS WE HAVE
CENTER DOT UP. ITEM NUMBER TWO
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVEN TWO
CENTER DODD PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READING THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE SB EIGHT SEVEN
TWO IS A SIMPLE BILL TO HELP
ADDRESS THE COMPLICATED PROBLEM
GETTING HEALTH CARE TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW COUNTIES TO OPERATE A
MOBILE PHARMACY. TO PROVIDE
MEDICATIONS VACCINES AND RELATED
SERVICES THE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS LACKING
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OR JIM
GROSS. I REPRESENT THE SPONSOR
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DR EMILY DOE
CHIEF PHARMACY OFFICER FOR THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCIES AND I'VE
ASKED THAT MISTER CHAIR TO- BE
BRIEF IN THEIR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU WITNESSES PLEASE PROCEED.
WHO ARE SENATOR DODD JIM GROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO- THE COUNTY IS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR WITH THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA THE BILL'S ALSO SUPPORT BY
THE COUNTING OF CONTRA COSTA-
THIS IS A AND NECESSARY CHANGE
TO ALLOW THE USE OF A MOBILE
PHARMACY UNITS TO WORK IN THE
COMMUNITIES CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT. ALLOW FOR THAT AND- WE
BELIEVE IT WILL PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO HELP BOTH-
AREAS IN THE COUNTY THAT ARE
HARD TO REACH AND THE HOMELESS-
DOCTOR GO WE'LL GET INTO THIS A
LITTLE BIT MORE I D WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE BEEN- IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY STAFF AND RECEIVED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND WE
THINK WE ARE- WELL ON THE WAY TO
HAVING A VERY WELL REFINED BILL.
A TO ALLOW A PROPER REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT WITHOUT A LOT OF
PASSAGE TO A DOCTOR GO FOR SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED FOR THIS
THANK YOU. DOCTOR THANK YOU. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON- CARE ROCK FIVE
YEAH MELENDEZ AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DR EMILY
DOE AND I'M THE CHIEF PHARMACY
OFFICER FOR THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. IT IS A PRIVILEGE HAVE
PROVIDED FOR YOU TODAY AND THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IS PROUD TO
BE A COLD SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION. SENATE BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO WHAT AUTHORIZED
COUNTY TO OPERATE A MOBILE
PHARMACY STAFF BY A PHARMACIST.
THE BRING CRITICAL MEDICATION TO
ISOLATED OR VULNERABLE
POPULATION IN THE COMMUNITY.
EFFICIENT ARE ALLOWED TO OPERATE
IN A MOBILE SETTING OR VIA
TELEMEDICINE AND CAN GO DIRECTLY
INTO THE COMMUNITY TWO THIRDS
VOTE OF ALL POPULATION SUCH AS
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND OLDER ADULTS
WHO PHYSICALLY CAN'T ACCESS THE
PHYSICIAN'S OFFICE. THIS CAN
LEAD CURATION PERTH AND HAVE
BEEN GRADUATED BUY A POSITION AS
PRESCRIPTION IN HAND BUT EITHER
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION OR AFFECT
YOUR PHARMACY TO FILL THE
PRESCRIPTION. THE DAY FUND ALL
THE MEDICATION THEY NEED THEIR
POT THERE BY PUTTING THEIR
HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH AT
RISK. FOR EXAMPLE IN THE LEGAL
CAN WHICH A REP COUPLE HAVE TO
OKAY AN HOUR FOR TWO. TO A
CLINIC FOR THAT LOCAL OF THE
GREETING. THEY DON'T HAVE TO A
PHARMACY AT ANOTHER LOCATION TO
PICK UP THE MEDICATION. C.
MOBILE PHARMACY COULD HAVE COME
TO THEM AND THEY COULD START THE
MEDICATIONS IMMEDIATELY. IN
ANOTHER EXAM. A PATIENT.
HOMELESSNESS WITH EVALUATED BY A
PHYSICIAN FROM THE STREET SCENE
AND NEEDED TO GET A LIFESAVING
MEDICATIONS AT A PHARMACY.
HOWEVER THE PATIENT WAS UNABLE
TO LEAVE HIS BELONGINGS
UNATTENDED AT A HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT. AND COULD YOU TAKE
EVERYTHING WITH HIM TO THE
PHARMACY. THE PHARMACIST COULD
COME WITH A MOBILE PHARMACY TO
DISPENSE THE MEDICATION. ANSWER
QUESTIONS TO HELP THE PATIENT
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
TAKING THE MEDICATION AND
PICKING UP CORRECTLY. THE
MEDICATION COULD BE ABOUT THE
PATIENT BY THE PHARMACY BECAUSE
THE. PATIENT DIDN'T HAVE A
MAILING ADDRESS. LACK OF ACCESS
A FARM SHOULD BE ABOUT TO. LIFE
MEDICAL. AND PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC FROM THE SPREAD OF
DISEASES. SENATE BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO WILL PROVIDE COUNTY
A NEW WAY TO ACCESS DIFFICULT TO
REACH POPULATIONS AND PROVIDED
THEM WITH MUCH NEEDED PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICES. I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT SENATE BILL EXACTLY TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU DR LET'S HEAR
FROM ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY- IS GERM
MEMBERS MICHAEL RATIGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
CO SPONSOR OR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR TIME
AND TESTIMONY OTHER ANY OTHER
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. THING NUMBERS MOVED
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE OR WAS
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP ANY SUCH WITNESSES WAITING
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL EIGHT SEVENTY TWO. BUT
AGAIN. THANK YOU. FOR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BEGIN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE TWO LINES OF
OPERATORS JUST MORE. PLEASE
PROCEED. THE FIRST ONLINE ONE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CRYSTAL ANDERSON AND I
AM SUPPORTING THE INFORMATION
WHEN PURCHASING MARIJUANA
PRODUCTS TO BE SIMILAR TO THE
INFORMATION THAT PACKAGE OF
CIGARETTES. I THINK THAT OVERALL
NINE ONE EIGHTY. LET ME JUST THE
LAST WITNESS I THINK THOSE
COMMENTS ARE RELATED TO PERHAPS
THE NEXT BILL WE TAKE UP SO YOU
MAY WANT TO LINE UP AGAIN IN THE
QUEUE. NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JEAN HURTS
CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU KNOW IT OUTLINES IN
HERE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FIRST WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE LET'S
MOVED WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR VISIT IN OPPOSITION MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE.
BILL EIGHT SEVEN TWO WE WILL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO THAT BILL YOU MAY
PRESS STAR FOLLOWED BY ZERO I
APOLOGIZE THAT'S ONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN THE STATE OPPOSITION THIS
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU TURN ONLINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MR MODERATOR
LET'S BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR KILLINGS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER LEYVA
IS SEE NO OTHER MICROPHONES UP.
THIRD I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THEIR DAUGHTER SIX ZERO VOTE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATE BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH ON ROSS HI
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
IV HI BATES I BAKER AYEBACKER
AYE DODD. DODD AYE EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO. RICARDO I
JONES THANK JONES HI LEYVA LEYVA
AYE MAN. MAN I AM NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT NEWMAN AYE AYE CHAU A
BOGUS HI BUT CHAU BOGUE IPN HI
CAN I. THE BILL HAS THIRTEEN
VOTES THE BILL IS OUT MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO BE CLOSING THE
ROLE FROM. FROM NOW ON. THIRTY
PM ITEM NUMBER TEN SENATE BILL
TEN NINETY SEVEN. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- SENATORS- FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO THANK KAREN
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING MY
OFFICE ON THE AMENDMENTS TO
REFLECT IN THE ANALYSIS NUMBER
OF THE PRESENT SENATE BILL TEN
NINETY SEVEN CANNABIS RIGHT TO
KNOW ACT THIS MEASURES BASED ON
THE STATE OF THE ART SCIENCE AND
HOW TO HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THE KEY HEALTH RISKS ASSOCIATED
CANNABIS. AND WHICH IS USED IN
THREE DIFFERENT WAYS FIRST
REQUIRES RETAILERS PROVIDE FIRST
TIME CONSUMERS A SCIENCE BASED
DOUBLE SINGLE PAGE BROCHURE WITH
A SIMPLE STEP SIMPLE STEPS
RECEIVE FOR USE SECOND REQUIRES
A ROTATING HEALTH WARNING LABEL
ENCOURAGING CONSUMERS TO BUY
LEGAL PRODUCTS AND EXPLAIN THE
POSSIBLE HAZARDS OF ILLICIT
CANNABIS AND THIRTY REQUIRES
MORE PROMINENT ROTATING HEALTH
WARNING LABELS BASED ON
ESTABLISHED SCIENCE FOR CANNABIS
PACKAGING. BILL ALSO SPECIFIES
THAT THE ROTATING MESSAGES IS
THAT DOES THE DESIGN FOR CERTAIN
PRODUCT CATEGORIES FOR EXAMPLE
IN HILL PRODUCTS WILL
CONTAINERISED ANY MESSAGE AROUND
HAZARDS OF SMOKING A PRODUCT
WEARS ANIMAL PRODUCTS WILL
CONTAIN A WARNING ON THE AFFECT
THAT ON WHEN THE EFFECTS COULD
START AND WHY WAITING. QUITE A
WAIT BEFORE EATING MORE THE
LABELING STANDARDS IN SB TEN
NINETY SEVEN ALREADY USED IN
CANADA AND ALIGN WITH SIMILAR
INCOMING FTA PROVING
CONGRESSIONAL MANDATE THEY TO
TOBACCO LABELLING STANDARDS
CURRENTLY THE LABELING ON CAMPUS
PRODUCT IT'S HARD TO SEE AND
INSUFFICIENT FOR EDUCATING THE
PUBLIC ON HEALTH RISKS AND IF I
USE A PROP SO YOU SAMPLED YOU
CAN'T SEE VERY MUCH HERE. PRINT
SMALL NOT KNOWING THE CURRENT
HEALTH RISK COULD BE DETRIMENTAL
PARTICULARLY FOR TEENS AND YOUNG
ADULTS WHO ARE MOST. VULNERABLE
TO THESE HARMS AFTER TO
PROSECUTE DIDN'T SEE. INCREASE
IN CANNABIS USE AMONG CAL TEENS
. AGES TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN AND
IN DAILY USE BY ADULTS THERE'S
ALSO BEEN AN INCREASE IN THC
CONTENT OR POTENCY OF THE
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. USES THESE
MORE POTENT PRODUCTS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE NEGATIVE MENTAL
HEALTH IMPACTS AND CAUSE HARMFUL
CHANGES. TO DEVELOPING BRAINS OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH UP UNTIL
THEIR MID TWENTIES. WELL THE
CURRENT LABELS MAY LIST THE HIGH
THC CONTENT THEY DO NOT PROPERLY
REFLECT THE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED DANGERS ASSOCIATED
WITH IT. THINK OF MENTAL HEALTH.
WE MADE. AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL
RESPONSE THE HELPFUL ISSUES.
IDENTIFIED THANKS THE HELPFUL
FEEDBACK BILL WILL NOT REQUIRE
ANY INCREASES IN PACKAGING AND-
AND FONT SIZE CAN BE SKILLED OF
PACKAGES USUALLY SMALL. MAJOR
NEW CAR SHOULD NOT BE KURDS AND
THE WARNING LABELS WILL. CHANGE
THE DESIGN EXISTING PACKAGING
THE MUSCLE REPRINTED. WE ALSO
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF PAPER BEING HANDLED BY A
REDUCING THE FOCUS TO NEW
CUSTOMERS. SB TEN NINETY SEVEN
HELPS INFORM CUSTOMERS OF SAFE
AND LEGAL CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
THAT'S WHY OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTING TEN
NINETY SEVEN- I. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY SUPPORTERS DOCTORA NEEDS
LEFT. AND EMERGENCY AND
ADDICTION MEDICINE SPECIALISTS
RIPPLING DEMERITS THE A
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF NURSING
POSITIONS AND THIS IS HAZEL
BRIGHT MOTHER KEVIN BRIGHT. AND
BECAUSE OF USED BY KEVIN DE ARE
BRING THIS BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
AND I HAVE DOCUMENTS OVER- FROM
THE PUBLIC HEALTH. INSTITUTE
BUILDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU. BUT YOU WAS. PER LET
ME JUST SAY THE- AS I ENDED. TO
OF YOU. WILL A BIT EARLIER WE
HAVE US SENATE SESSION THAT
CONVENES THIS AFTERNOON WE HAVE
A HARD STOP. FOR THIS PARTICULAR
SESSION OF THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AT ONE
FIFTEEN PM THIS AFTERNOON.
RECOGNIZING HOPEFULLY WE'LL
FINISH THIS DISCUSSION ON THIS
BILL. AND MOVE TO A VOTE- IF NOT
AND BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CONVERSATION TO ALL WHO WILL
BE PARTICIPATING NOT ONLY HERE
BUT ON THE TELEPHONE LINE. AND
IF I D NOT RECEIVE CONTRARY
COUNTRY INSTRUCTIONS WE WILL.
RECESS AT ONE FIFTEEN AND WE
WILL RECONVENE. UPON CONCLUSION
OF SENATE SESSION THIS AFTERNOON
AND IF NECESSARY RESUME THE
CONVERSATION REGARDING THIS BILL
. HAVING SAID THAT- DOCTOR PAN
YOUR WITNESSES PLEASE. I'M ON
THE LINE. PLEASE PROCEED. AT
ELEVEN EVERY YEAR THE AGONIZING
FOUND THE ROAMING THROUGH THE
HALLWAYS IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. LEANING AND VOMITING
IN THE HALLMARK SIGN OF
CANDIDATES SACRAMENTO SEND ON
HAPPENED TO CHRONIC USERS WHEN
THEY'RE RECEPTOR RADICALS I
THINK A FIFTY TWO YEAR OLD WOMAN
WHO HAD A HEART ATTACK AFTER
SMOKING MARIJUANA. I THINK HE
NEEDS AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
HIGHLIGHTS THE WITH ON CARDIAC
HEALTH IN MY EIGHTY RIGHT NOW
OUT CALIFORNIA WILL HOLDING
PATIENTS WITH CANNABIS INDUCED
BY FROM DAYS AND WEEKS NEED A
LACK OF THE- AND I SAID OVER
SEVENTY PARKING DAY CAN USE
THING. INCREASE WITH THE FACT.
EUROPEAN STUDIES HAVE WE- A
MAJOR I EIGHT THIRTY SO CAN INC. WE CAN BE ABLE NUMBER COUNTY
HE IS AN- ONE BROAD. SOUNDING
COMPLETED SUICIDE IN A HUNDRED
FIVE STATE THE DEVELOPING. I
DON'T CENTER NINE ONE CALL THE
END OF HIS. CANNABIS GROW BY
BIRTH CASUALTIES I'M RIGHT DATE
. EVERY SHIFT I TREATMENT
POINTED. IN SAN DIEGO THREE
THIRTY SEVEN POINT A DAY WITH A
K. OF RELATED. AND STATE WHY
CASES HAVE BEEN. ALRP LET AND
LEGAL OF. I KNOW BELIEVE WITH
ACTOR INCOME. OTHER STATES HAVE
A PROTECTION AND WE SHOULD. THE
PUBLIC IS AWARE OF THE TO. AND
OPIOIDS BUT CAN. HELP DOCTOR ARE
BIG YOU TO TAKE HE AND HOW AT
TIME THE NINETEENTH THAT.
HE STARTED SMOKING JOINTS
BECAUSE IT WAS COOL AND WHEN
BEGAN- AS CASUAL USE ENDED UP
WITH HIM USING HIGH POTENCY THC
PRODUCTS MANY TIMES A DAY.
SLOWLY THE JOINTS AND BOWLS
TRANSITION THE HIGHLY
CONCENTRATED THC PRODUCTS THAT
WE HAVE NEVER HEARD OF HAVE YOU
EVER HEARD OF A DEATH I HADN'T.
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF SHATTERED
THESE ARE HIGHLY ADDICTIVE THC
PRODUCTS MY HUSBAND AND I HAD NO
IDEA THE TODAY'S HIGH POTENCY
THC IS NOTHING LIKE THE
MARIJUANA OF OUR YOUTH. KEVIN
DID NOT REALIZE THAT WHAT HE
CALLED MEDICINE WAS GIVING HIM
CANNABIS INDUCED PSYCHOSIS HE
HAD VOICES IN HIS HEAD THAT WERE
THREATENING HIM BERATING HIM AND
MAKING HIM ANGRY. A FEW TIMES HE
STOPPED USING CANNABIS HIS MIND
CLEARED BUT HE WAS SO ADDICTED
TO CANNABIS HE WOULD HAVE
CANNABIS WITHDRAWAL SYMPTOMS OF
ANXIETY INSOMNIA. HEADACHES AND
DEPRESSION. HE CHOSE MARIJUANA
WORK SPORTS OR FRIENDSHIPS HE
WENT BROKE SPENDING HIS MONEY ON
CANNABIS. HIS LAST ARTICULATE
WORDS WERE CANNABIS HAS RUINED
MY LIFE. AT TWENTY NINE YEARS
OLD HE TOOK HIS LIFE. HIS WIFE
ENDED AND OURS LIVES WILL NEVER
BE THE SAME. I WISH WE KNEW
ABOUT HIGH POTENCY THC AND THE
RISKS OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS. I
SUPPORT SENATE BILL TEN NINETY
SEVEN. AND WE'RE VERY VERY SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND YOUR TIME. LET'S
SEVEN NOW HEAR FROM ANY OTHER
SUPPORT WITNESSES- IN THE
GALLERY ANY OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES. IN THE GALLERY.
DEMAND REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WERE CO
SPONSOR ASKING FOR A NIGHT OUT.
THANK YOU SIR. I'M A JIM CARREY
WITH YOU FOR THE ALSO A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STEP UP. I SUPPORT BILL
OF TEN NINETY SEVEN- AS PART
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
THANKS LYNN SILVER PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT- MICHAEL
RAT AGAIN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY.
BALLOTS MOVED TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE-PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES READY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TEN EIGHTY TEN NINETY SEVEN
RATHER WE WILL BEGIN. I THINK
YOU TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU ARRANGEMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYN IT'S DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT. NEXT PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT. MY NAME IS DAVID
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I THOUGHT SB
TEN NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. ONE
NINETY SIX- HELLO- MY NAME IS
LAUREN AND I'M ACTUALLY FROM-
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NINE ONE. ONE FIFTEEN
YOU MIGHT BE MUTED. WILL MOVE ON
TO LINE EIGHTY SEVEN. GALA LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE STATE YOUR POSITION. HI
MY NAME IS LI AND I LIVE FROM
FRANCISCO I'M FORTY YEAR READ
THE AND GO AND I SUPPORT AND THE
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU VERY
NEXT PLEASE. PINE. FIFTY THREE.
I LAURIE ROBINSON I AM IN
THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TEN NINETY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF MONSTRO
BECAUSE MY OWN SON ALSO DIED BY
SUICIDE AFTER SUFFERING FROM
CANNABIS INDUCED PSYCHOSIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE
. ONE NINETY FOUR. HELLO MY NAME
IS HEALTHY FERNANDEZ AND THE
MARIN COUNTY RESIDENT AND PARENT
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT TOLD. TEN
NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. LINE. TWO OH THREE.
HELLO I AM MARIA HI THURMOND
SAID BEACH TONIGHT SUPPORT
AGENCY. TEN SEVEN. THANK YOU
NEXT. THANK YOU ACTUALLY ONE
NINETY SEVEN ONE NINETY S. HELLO
HELLO WORLD WE CAN HEAR YOU BUT
YOU NEED TO MUTE THE FOR
WATCHING THE HEARING TO FEEDBACK
PLEASE PROCEED. HI MY NAME IS
ROBERT LOUIS ARSENAL. THERE ARE
SUPPORTERS. ONE ZERO NINE. BANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY
NINE. HELLO THIS IS KELLY
MCCORMICK FOR CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND I
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THE- PLEASE
VOTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE THIRTY
NINE. THANK YOU MY NAME IS LISA
HAYDON I'M A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCHER FOCUSING ON CANNABIS
IN OAKLAND AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT THE ONE OH NINE SEVEN
. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
TWO HUNDRED. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR JOSEPH ABSENT. WITH THE
NORTH COASTAL ASSOCIATION MENTAL
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND WE SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY
NINE. I JUST WANT HER MOST THE
COALITION FOR DRUG FREE KIDS I
STRONGLY FOR. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY SIX. VIDEO
FOR REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE TWENTY TWO.
MY NAME IS JULIE FAMILY MOM OF A
SON WHO LIKE MOST OF THE IDEAS
STARTED WITH HOT BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T KNOW THE REST AND I
STRONGLY. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. TWO OH SIX. THIS IS KELLY
O'BRIEN SAN FRANCISCO WITH THE
NATIONAL CANDY BAND COALITION TO
HELP USE PROTECTIVE CANNABIS
REGULATIONS MIRRORING THOSE WE
HAVE ON ALCOHOL AND TOBACCO SUCH
AS WARNING LABELS BANDS ON
EDIBLE CANNABIS AND BAND
UNFLAVORED BAKED SWEET SUPPORT
SENATE BILL ONE OH NINE SEVEN
FOR WARNING LABELS. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. ONE THIRTY THREE.
HI THIS IS A LONG BEHALF OF EVER
BRING MATTERS I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SENATE BILL CA NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. BLIND THIRTY FIVE EIGHT. FROM
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SUPPORT SB. TEN NINETY SEVEN. I
DON'T THINK YOU MA'AM NEXT
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY SEVEN. HI THIS
IS A LITTLE BIT- DONNELL AND
MILL VALLEY CALIFORNIA I'M A
TEACHER AND A YOUTH ADVOCATE AND
I VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT. NINE TWO
OH NINE. HI YES MY NAME IS
MARINA ROACH I AM A SAN
FRANCISCO RESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL TEN
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. ONE NINETY. HI MY
NAME IS. PHIL ANDERSON I KNOW A
FAMILY FRIEND WHO COMMITTED
SUICIDE WHILE HAVING WEED IN HIS
SYSTEM I'LL HAVE TO FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO SUFFER FROM MENTAL
ILLNESS AFTER YEARS OF USING. I
USED IN MY YOUTH AND- I BELIEVE
THAT THE WARNING LABELS THAT ARE
ON CIGARETTES ALCOHOL ARE A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF WHAT YOU DID. THANK
YOU MA'AM. PREFETCHING TESTIMONY
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN. NAME IS BECKY WRAPPED
WITH UNITED PARENTS AGAINST
MARIJUANA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINETY
FIVE. CURRENTLY GET PRIMARY
SCHOOL CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
TOTAL SUPPORTED THIS BILL THANK
YOU SENATOR BAM FOR NO MORE KIDS
DYING THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
PLEASE. LINE. NINETY SEVEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE
PROCEED TO MY NECK YOUR NEXT WE
CAN HEAR YOU PERFECTLY OKAY YEAH
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
MONEY TRANSFER SAN FRANCISCO WE
ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL. ONE NINE ONE ZERO
NINE SEVEN FOUR THIS LIFESAVING
BILL IS PRESENTED BY THE DOCTOR
AT THE EMERGENCY AS WELL AS BY
MANY MANY PARENTS THANK YOU IF
IT- THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT PLEASE. M. LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE. DIANNE GREAT PARROT AND
GRANDPARENT AND I STRONGLY. BILL
CAN. NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. A LINE OF. NINETEEN NEXT
PLEASE. TWO ELEVEN. HI THIS IS
FRANKLY PAUL G. IT'S ABOUT TIME
THAT WE HAVE WARNING LABELS ON
CANNABIS PRODUCTS I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON- WOULD
YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA HOW MANY
MORE INDIVIDUALS ARE ON THE LINE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS MEASURE. YES FOR SUPPORT
WE HAVE SIX LINES IN Q. OKAY.
LET'S START TAKING THOSE ALL AS
THE STAFF DIRECTOR TO CHECK WITH
THE SECRETARY FOR THE SENATE TO
SEE IF ONE FIFTEEN IS THE HARD
STUFF PLEASE PROCEED NEXT PLEASE
. HELLO TO ALL EIGHT. HI MY
NAME'S MIKIE CONTEMPLATIVE CAL I
STRONGLY SUPPORT ANTI TANK THAT
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. TWO
THIRTEEN. BARBARA GORDON WOULD
USE ADVOCATE I STRONG SUPPORT
TEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. TO FROM ALCOHOL
CALIFORNIA- I'M A PIANO TEACHER
AND PARENT I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. TWO
EIGHTEEN. KATHLEEN LETTER PUBLIC
HEALTH PRACTITIONER IN STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AGAINST DRUG ABUSE
THE COURT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE
NINETY SEVEN. HIS HOMES.
OVERMIND NINETY ONE NINETY
SEVENTY WANT TO MUTE YOUR STREAM. NINE TO NINETEEN. MY NAME IS
ERICA LEARY WITH THE NORTH
COASTAL PREVENTION COALITION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU PLEASE. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO FOR LINES IN Q.
FAMOUS BUT RATHER WE'RE GONNA
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION NOW AND
THE MOVE TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY I BELIEVE THAT WE
CENTERS ON BEHALF OF WEEDMAPS
AND AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
ARE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL TEN
NINETY SEVEN IF SO. PLEASE
PROCEED. WE NEED A MIKE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME FINGERPRINT A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN NINETY
SEVEN THIS BILL WOULD SUBJECT
THE LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO
DUPLICATIVE LABELING
REQUIREMENTS CREATE EXCESSIVE
NEW COSTUME LANDFILL WASTE AND
IN PRACTICE DO A DISSERVICE TO
THE CONSUMER. SB TEN NINETY
SEVENS INTENDED OBJECTIVES TO
DISCOURAGE YOUTH ACCESS IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
REDUCE DEMAND FOR CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FROM THE ILLICIT MARKET
ARE LAUDABLE HOWEVER WE FAIL TO
SEE HOW SB TEN NINETY SEVEN
WOULD MEET THOSE OBJECTIVES
UNDER RECURSOS LEGAL CANNABIS
PRODUCTS ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO
INCLUDE CLEAR AND EFFECTIVE
WARNING LABELS THAT COMMUNICATE
SCIENTIFICALLY ESTABLISHED
HEALTH RISKS SB TEN NINETY SEVEN
FAILS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE NEW
RECENTLY APPROVED PROP NIGHT
SIXTY FIVE LABELING. MARC
REQUIREMENTS WHICH ALREADY
INCLUDE THE ADDITION OF THE WORD
LEARNING NEW LANGUAGE ABOUT
EXPOSURE TO SMOKE AND T. H. C.
AND A LIST OF POSSIBLE
CARCINOGENS BY NAME SB TEN
NINETY SEVEN IS BASED ON A
FLAWED PREMISE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE ACCESSING LEGAL PRODUCTS
WELL WE DO NOT DISPUTE THE FACT
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE ACCESSING
CANNABIS PRODUCTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REPORT COMMISSIONED
BY THE INSURANCE INSTITUTE FOR
HIGHWAY SAFETY. IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE UNIVERSITY'S OF CHICAGO
MINNESOTA AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT DID NOT FIND A
SINGLE INSTANCE OF A LEGAL
CALIFORNIA RETAILER ALLOWING AN
INDIVIDUAL INTO THEIR PROMISES
WITHOUT PROPER IDENTIFICATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF TEN NINETY
SEVEN WILL MAKE LEGAL PRODUCTS
MORE EXPENSIVE HIGHER COSTS TO
PRODUCE LEGAL PRODUCTS WERE
INEVITABLY RESULT IN HIGHER
PRODUCT PRICES WITH CALIFORNIA'S
ILLICIT CANNABIS MARKET
ESTIMATED TO BE WORTH NEARLY
EIGHT BILLION ANNUALLY SB TEN
NINETY SEVEN WILL ONLY SERVE TO
BOLSTER THE UNLICENSED CANNABIS
MARKET. BY DRIVING MORE
CONSUMERS TO THE ILLICIT MARKET
UNDERMINING CONSUMER HEALTH AND
SAFETY FOR THESE REASONS THE CIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES. SB TEN
NINETY SEVEN. IF THANK YOU
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
PERSONALLY SIGN. FOR MILLER SAYS
BUT AS SOON AS- HERE ON BEHALF
OF WE MAP WE- CONCUR. WITH ALL
THE POINTS AVERAGE MADE MY
COLLEAGUE FOR CCA AN ORAL IN
OFFICE. TO SB TEN SO. WEEDMAPS
ONE OF THE LEADING TECHNOLOGY
SOFTWARE PROVIDER FOR THE
LICENSE CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND IS
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
TRANSPARENT. AND INCLUSIVE
GLOBAL CANNABIS ECONOMY THROUGH
SAFE EQUITABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
PUBLIC POLICY. WE HOLD THE
AUTHOR LOS LEGISLATION IN HIGH
REGARD GIVEN THE WORK THAT HE'S
LEAD ON PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
RECOGNIZE AN ECHO CONCERNS ABOUT
YOUTH CONSUMPTION HOWEVER WE'RE
STILL HAVING A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING THE PROBLEM THAT
THIS BILL AIMS TO SOLVE. OR
ADDRESS BY THESE ONEROUS
LABELING REQUIREMENTS. THE LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY IS AT AN
INFLECTION POINT IN ADDING
DUPLICATIVE AND SOMETIMES.
CONFLICTING LABELS WILL ONLY
HURT THE INDUSTRY AND BOLSTER
THE ILLICIT MARKET.
COMPREHENSIVE A FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. PARTY REQUIRE
WARNING LABELS AND CHILDPROOF
PACKAGING FOR CANNABIS PRODUCTS
SOLD BY LICENSED RETAIL. DEALERS
IN THE STATE. SB TEN NINETY
SEVEN ALONG INCREASED COSTS FOR
ILLEGAL CANNABIS OPERATORS WHO
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING TO
COMPETE WITH THE ILLICIT MARKET.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE THIRD
ANALYSIS HIGHLIGHTING HOW. THIS
BILL WILL HAVE FINANCIAL AND
LABOR IMPACTS TO LEGAL OPERATORS
AND THE SUPPLY CHAIN. AND
ANOTHER IMPORTANT IN UNANSWERED
QUESTION IS HOW WILL THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS WORK. WITH THE
EXISTING LABELS BROUGHT FORTH BY
THE CURSOR AND PROP SIXTY FOUR-
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE A PART
IN OPPOSITION. ENERGEN OVER
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IT'S
NOW A ONE SIXTEEN WE HAVE BEEN
TOLD THAT WE MAY NOT CONTINUE
BEYOND. THIS POINT IN TIME SO
THIS COMMITTEE WILL RECESS. AT
THIS POINT AND RECONVENE THIS
AFTERNOON UPON CONCLUSION OF THE
SENATE SESSION IN THIS CHAMBER
FOR THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INSTRUCTION
TO YOU WITH RESPECT TO THE DIAL
IN IT SEVERAL WHEN WE RECONVENE
UPON CONCLUSION OF THE SENATE
SESSION. THIS COMMITTEE IS NOW
IN RECESS.
THIS COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL AGAIN COME TO
ORDER WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO
WORK CONSIDERATION OF SENATE
BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN. BUT
BEFORE DOING SO WE NEED TO
REACTIVATE OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS FOUR SIX SIX
THREE NINE SIX EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. OR
ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH IS
WHERE WE ARE NOW OF THE COMMON
IN OPPOSITION YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO. FOR OPPOSITION
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WHITE. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME. YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU WILL THEN BE
READY TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE
. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON- TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
THIS WAS AN ISSUE EARLIER TODAY.
HOPEFULLY WON'T BE AN ISSUE NOW.
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. NOW LET'S MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN WE
WILL BEGIN. I NEED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL TEN
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'LL START WITH LINE. TO FIFTY
FIVE. AND YOUR AND ON BEHALF OF
THE PARENT COMPANY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. IT JUST MOST WOMEN
JUST QUEUED UP.
OKAY AND WE DON'T WANT TO FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THE PRIEGO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO THE COUNTY CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION TO SB CA NINETY SEVEN
. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. MR
SURELY HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR. LET'S NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. OR CONCERNS REGARDING
SENATE BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN.
OKAY SENATOR EGGMAN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU DR PAN- I ARE YOU
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT ABOUT
YOUR BILL AS I DO WITH A LOT OF
BILLS THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
LABELING CAN YOU I MEAN JUST
FIRST TELL ME WHAT WHY THIS TWO
PART WHY THE- THE HANDOUT WHICH
SEEMS MORE REASONABLE. AND THEN
THE LABELING AND WHILE THERE'S A
LOT OF DETAILED INFORMATION.
ABOUT SOME OF THE HARM THAT
COMES NONE OF THAT REALLY
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF LABELING
AND HOW LABELING WOULD INDEED
HELP. AND THEN. THIS JUST JUST
IMPACTS. THE LEGAL MARKET WHICH
IS ONLY PLACE WE CAN IMPACT.
WHICH IS ALREADY STRUGGLING AND
BY DEFINITION IS MORE IS SAFER
THAN THE ILLEGAL MARKET SO HOW
DOES THIS CONTINUE TO KEEP OUR
LEGAL MARKET. FUNCTIONAL THREE
QUESTIONS HOW DOES COOPER LEGAL
MARKET FUNCTIONING WHAT DATA DO
WE REALLY HAVE ON THE IMPACTS OF
LABELING. AND THERE WAS A STUDY
FUNDED IN TWENTY TWENTY ON TO
LOOK AT THE IMPACTS OF LABELING
AND WE STILL HAVEN'T RECEIVED
THAT AS I UNDERSTAND IT- AND
THEN WIDE BY THE TWO PART
APPROACH. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
SUCH A QUESTION SIR AG MEN UP
FIRST OF ALL I WANNA SAY THAT
THE- YEAH WE ACTUALLY DO WANT TO
DISCOURAGE USE OF ILLICIT
CANNABIS AND- AND CERTAINLY-
YEAH. WELL PART OF IT IS
EDUCATING PEOPLE ABOUT THE NOT
JUST THE DANGERS CANNABIS BUT
PARTICULARLY INCLUDING DANGERS
OF ILLICIT CANNABIS NOW BELIEVE
THAT THESE. LABELS ARE ALSO CITE
THE ILLICIT PEOPLE CRY AND
LIKELY TO PUT THE LABELS ON
OTHER TECHNICALLY I THINK THEY
COULD BE YOU KNOW ACTUALLY
PROSECUTE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
LABELS ON. BECAUSE THEY'RE
SELLING CANNABIS IN ADDITION TO
ALL THE OTHERS IS THAT THEY
COULD BE PROSECUTED FOR. THE AND
IN TERMS OF THE- EVENTS AROUND
THE LABELING ITSELF WE DO HAVE
EVIDENCE FROM EXPERIENCE WITH
TOBACCO AND LABELING TOBACCO
PRODUCTS- IN TERMS OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE LABELING
PARTICULARLY DISCOURAGING- USE
BY YOUTH- AND- BE SURE THAT. YOU
KNOW PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF THE
DIFFERENT- CHALLENGES THAT ARE
RAISED BY- TOBACCO IN AND IN
THIS CASE- THAT CANNABIS THAT
REASON FOR THE TWO STAGES IS
THAT- CERTAINLY AGAIN I WILL
KNOW WHEN. WE TOOK AMENDMENTS
AND ALSO WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW THE LABELS AND LIKE THE
WHOLE PACKAGE RIGHT SO YOU
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH INFORMATION
YOU CAN PUT ON A LABEL BUT- TO
BE SURE THAT. IT'S TIME
CUSTOMERS DO YOU HAVE THE
INFORMATION BECAUSE THAT SAID
PEOPLE MAY NOT BE AWARE. THAT
THAT MODERN- CANNABIS OFTEN
TIMES MORE POTENT THAN PERHAPS
THAN. SOME PEOPLE WOULD USE IN
THE PAST OR- ARE THAT- THEY
REMEMBER TO HEAR FROM OTHER
PEOPLE AS WELL SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT PEOPLE HAVE UP TO DATE
INFORMATION. WHICH WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD THAT YOU
CAN. EXPLAIN IN MORE DETAIL IN A
BROCHURE YOU KNOW I. HAVEN'T PUT
IT ALL INTO A LABEL AND THE
LABEL WOULD. BASICALLY KEEP
POINT INTO ROTATING LABELS WELL.
AND THIS BUT THE SCIENCE ON THE
LABELING COMES FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE FROM.
FROM LABELING AND TOBACCO. AND
AND SO THERE'S A CONSIDERABLE
EVIDENCE FOR THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THAT TYPE OF LABELING FROM
THAT EXPERIENCE. OKAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER I MEAN I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S ANALOGOUS
TO TOBACCO BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE A LEGAL AND ILLEGAL ILLICIT
TOBACCO MARKET GOING AT THE SAME
TIME. AS A LEGAL ONE AND IT
WASN'T JUST THE LABELING WAS
ALSO TAXES AND INCREASED IN A
BIG. PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS
OF. THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWER.
OKAY I THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN
SENTIMENT. THANK YOU MR SIX
HUNDRED GRAND- FORTUNATELY FOR
ME CENTER EGGMAN IS. EFFECTIVELY
ARTICULATED A COUPLE OF MY
QUESTIONS. AND TO HER POINT I
GUESS IN IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
REPLY. ONE OF THE POINTS MADE I
THINK THAT'S COMPELLING TO ME BY
THE OPPONENTS IS. IF WE'RE
DISCUSSING USE BY YOU. WHAT
WHERE WE'RE ALSO YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE DISCUSSING PRODUCTS WHICH
BY DEFINITION- IF THEY ARE LEGAL
WILL ONLY BE FOUND AND CAN ONLY
BE PURCHASED BY ADULTS. IN
LICENSES PRESSURES SO YOU KNOW
THERE'S THE BROADER QUESTION
ABOUT THE I GUESS THE SECONDARY
USER SECONDARY EXPLOSIONS THE
PRODUCTS- AND I'M- I AM AS WITH
SUGAR WINNERS EARLY BILL.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACTS ON
THE LEGAL MARKET ESPECIALLY THE
CITY AT THE APPARENT SUCCESS
OVER TIME SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN
OF US MARKET- AND SO FOR THAT
REASON- I WILL BE STAYING UP
THIS BILL TODAY- I DO APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO LIKE I
DO THINK THERE IS A NEED. FOR
CONTINUAL EDUCATION OF CONSUMERS
TO TAKE YOUNG PEOPLE- BUT IN MY
EXPERIENCE IN IN TALKING TO
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET. THEY'RE GLAD TO
DO THAT IN GOOD FAITH- AND TO
CENTER EGGMAN'S POINT YOU KNOW
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR SOME
DATA BACK. AS THE BEST
PRACTICES- JOHN WITHHOLD MY
DECISION ON THAT BASIS THANK YOU
. ALEX ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
MELINDA. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
SENATOR PAN RIGHT I HEARD YOU
SAY THAT- YOU'RE BASING THIS OFF
OF THE TYPE OF WARNINGS THAT
WERE USED FOR TOBACCO PRODUCTS-
BUT I'M LOOKING AT A STUDY HERE
FROM JAVA THAT SAYS. HE DID A
RANDOMIZED CLINICAL TRIAL. SAYS
THT THEY FOUND GRAPHIC WARNING
LABELS DECREASED POSITIVE
PERCEPTION OF CIGARETTES BUT
WITHOUT CLEARLY INCREASING
HEALTH CONCERNS AND THEY ALSO
INCREASED QUITTING COGNITIONS
BUT DID NOT AFFECT EITHER
CIGARETTE SENSATION CESSATION OR
CONSUMPTION LEVELS SO I'M JUST.
IS THERE. WHAT STUDY IS IT THAT
YOU ARE REFERRING TO THAT
SUGGESTS THAT PUTTING A WARNING
LABEL NOT A GRAPHIC ONE LIKE-
THIS STUDY SUGGESTS BY WHAT
CITIES ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
THAT. WHAT WOULD INDICATE THAT A
WARNING LABEL FOR CANNABIS USE
WOULD HAVE ANY EFFECT AT ALL ON.
THE USER. WELL I THINK THAT
FIRST OF ALL IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE GET ACCURATE INFORMATION
ABOUT- BACK CANNABIS AND- EFFECT
ACTUALLY THERE THERE'S DATA TO
SHOW THAT- PEOPLE. ARE NOT
NECESSARILY AWARE OF- BY THE
NAME OF THE ISSUES THAT AFFECT
WILL RAISE BY THE WITNESSES WHO
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT- WE
ALSO NOTE THAT- THAT BASICALLY
OURSELVES. THE WARNING LABELS
ENSURE THAT- WELL PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SURE THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS PUT IN IS BEFORE
THE USERS IN ADDITION TO OF
COURSE THEY SAID THE THEY HAND
OUT WHICH GOES INTO THAT CAN GO
INTO A LITTLE MORE MORE IN
DEPTH- THE- L. IT THERE IS- THE
REASON LABELING IS A PUT ON
TOBACCO IS BECAUSE- THERE IS OUT
THERE. THERE'S BEEN FOUND TO BE
IN COMBINATION I THINK I SHOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT IN COMBINATION
WITH OTHER EFFORTS EDUCATIONAL
EFFORTS IT DOES HELP- THAT SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE MORE AWARE OF
THE CHALLENGES AND I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT- THE WELL CERTAINLY
IT'S ILLEGAL FOR SOMEONE TO SELL
CANNABIS TO USE. THAT DOESN'T
STOP AN ADULT FROM POTENTIALLY
PURCHASING- CANNABIS THANK
INCINERATING- THIS PERHAPS
SHARING IT WITH SOMEONE WHO'S
YOUNGER AND. THE CERTAINLY-
LABEL WOULD- INDICATE- PERHAPS
IT MIGHT NOT BE SUCH A GOOD
IDEA- SO THAT- THEY WOULD BE
AWARE OF THE OF THE RISKS THAT.
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT- BUT- I
THINK THAT- ACTUALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK- BY A TECHNICAL
SOMEONE- DUCTAL IN SILVER TO
ADDRESS THE EVIDENCE BASED ON
THE LABEL THAT IF THAT'S IF
THAT'S APPROPRIATE. THAT SURE
CERTAINLY DOCTOR. DOCTOR WHO
THEY'RE WITH CAN YOU RESPOND.
YES MICROPHONE PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF THANK YOU FOR
THE- VERY PERTINENT QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY- SENATOR MELENDEZ
IN REGARD TO YOUR QUESTION
THERE'S A LARGE BODY OF RESEARCH
ON WARNING LABELS- FOR TOBACCO-
AND THE BALANCE OF THE EVIDENCE
ON IS THE PICTORIAL WARNING
LABELS ARE MORE EFFECTIVE AND
THAT THESE LARGER PROMINENT OF
ROTATING MESSAGES ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE AT INFLUENCING
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR INTENT TO
CONSUME- AS WELL AS THEIR RECALL
OF INFORMATION. SIMILAR STUDIES
HAVE BEEN DONE FOR CANNABIS BY
GROUPS FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
TORONTO DAVID HAMMOND AND
OTHERS- AS WELL AS WE HAVE OUR
FIRST PAPER THAT'S BEEN DONE
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF WISCONSIN
THAT'S CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW
AND WE FOUND THE COMPARING HER
IN CALIFORNIA LABELS TO THESE A
STRONGER MORE PROMINENT
PICTORIAL LABELS ON THE LATTER
WERE. MORE EFFECTIVE- SO THERE'S
A REASONABLE BODY OF EVIDENCE
WHICH IS WHAT THE CASE OF
TOBACCO HAS LED THE FDA TO
ADOPT. THAT APPROACH- IF I COULD
JUST INTERJECT HERE- THE BILL
DOES NOT SUGGEST USING- GRAPHIC
PICTORIAL TYPES OF WARNINGS
CORRECT. DR PANDA'S OR IS THAT
IS YOUR BILL INTEND TO USE
GRAPHIC. PICTURES AS PART OF THE
WARNING. NO OKAY BECAUSE I AND I
DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT YOU BUT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT STUDIES
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE RELATING TO
PICTORIALS AND MORE GRAPHIC
PICTURES WHICH AS I POINTED OUT
IN THE IN THE DRAMA THEY'VE SAID
THAT REALLY HASN'T HAD MUCH OF
AN EFFECT ON PEOPLE EITHER
QUITTING OR NOT STARTING IT AND
IT MAKES THEM THINK ABOUT IT BUT
IT DOESN'T HAVE ANY EFFECT ON
WHETHER THEY CONTINUE. TO ENGAGE
IN THAT BEHAVIOR AND THAT'S WITH
THE GRAPHIC PICTURES SO IN THIS
PARTICULAR CSE- WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOMETHING MUCH MORE
SUBDUED AND I'M STRUGGLING TO
SEE WHAT THE- YOU KNOW I GUESS
THE- THE ACTUAL OUTCOME WILL BE.
IF IT DOESN'T HAVE AN EFFECT ON
PEOPLE EVEN WITH GRAPHIC
PICTURES AND THE WAYS THAT. YOU
KNOW TOBACCO CAN HARM PEOPLE SO-
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
THAT'S ALL I HAVE THANK YOU
SENATOR HOLLINGS ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
I SEE NO OTHER. MICROPHONES UP.
SO DR PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I WAS GONNA ASK
DR SILVER TO MAYBE ADDRESS THE
ABSENCE OF GRAPHIC PICTURES BUT
THAT'S FINE RIGHT- THANKS OVER
WOULD YOU MIND AND I'LL CLOSE.
MISTER CHAIR. THE CLARIFICATION
THE BILL DOES CALL FOR PICTORIAL
WARNING LABELS. SO THE NATURE OF
THOSE. THIS IS NOT SPECIFIED BUT
IT DOES INCLUDE PICTORIAL
WARNING LABELS WHICH ARE
CONSIDERED TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE STANDARD THE RESEARCH
. THANK YOU FOR READING THANK
YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
FORGERS ARE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FAIR SAID. AT KERN
LABELS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED UNFORTUNATELY ARE
USUALLY MESS ESPECIALLY WHEN
COMBINED THE MATURITY IS A PROP
COMBINED WITH FUN FILLED FUN
COLORFUL- CHILD APPEALING
PACKAGES LIKE THIS ONE. IN
FLAVORS AND ALTHOUGH THEY MAY
HAVE BEEN SUFFICIENT WHEN THEY
WERE FIRST ENACTED THERE'S GOING
EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT THEY DO
NOT PROPERLY INFORMED CONSUMERS
OF THE VARIOUS HEALTH RISKS.
THIS MEASURE UP TO FIX THAT SB
TEN NINETY SEVEN ABOUT CONSUMER
SAFETY IN PARTICULAR SAFETY FOR
TEENS YOUNG ADULTS WHO ACTUALLY
ARE LEGALLY ALOWED TO PURCHASE.
AN INFANT DURING PREGNANCY THEIR
BRAINS ARE STILL DEVELOPING AND
IT'S CLEAR SIGNS THAT CANNABIS
CAN HAVE LONG TERM DAMAGING
EFFECTS LIKE IMPOSING ADDITION
MEMORY LOSS. COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT AND PSYCHOSIS AS YOU
HEARD FROM THE WITNESSES. ELEVEN
REQUIREMENT SB TEN NINETY SEVEN
ARE BASED ON SCIENCE BUT SCIENCE
SHOWS TO BE EFFECTIVE NOT ONLY
FOR TOBACCO BUT FOR OTHER
SIMILAR WARNING LABELS I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM THE
OPPOSITION WE MET WITH THEM WE
UNDERSTAND THAT BOTH SIDES WANT
TO ENSURE CONSUMER SAFETY. I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THEM AND COMMITTEE ON THE
BILL SHOULD ADVANCE TODAY TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
OUR DEPEND RIVER MOTION ON
SENATE BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN.
SIDEROXYLON MOVES TO BE. MOTION
IS TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BOTTOM STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATE BILL TEN
NINETY SEVENTY PASSING RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. MELENDEZ
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. BAKER
BACKER I'D DODD EGGMAN HER TADO
HER TADO I'D JONES. JONES I
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MAN MAIN AYE
NEWMAN A SHOW ABOUT A TERRIBLE
DRIVE IN HERE AND I. THE BILL
HAS EIGHT VOTES THAT'S ENOUGH TO
MOVE OUT OF THE COMMITTEE. ROSE
CLOSED ON THE BILL. LET'S MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX SENATOR
BAKER. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ONE
FOR MAKES A START WORKING ABOUT
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WITH FOLKS AND
HITS YOU OF UNUSED MEDICATION
WHEN WAS JUST DAWNING ON FOLKS
THAT THERE'S BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF UNUSED MEDICATIONS ENDING UP
IN THE GARBAGE EVERY YEAR. THE
NATIONAL CONGRESS OF STATE
LEGISLATURES THAT HOSPITAL'S
DISCORD OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF MEDICATION AND
LONG TERM FACILITIES CAREFULLY
THROW AN ADDITIONAL TWO BILLION
WORTH OF MEDICATION EVERY YEAR.
INSTEAD OF DISPOSING UNUSED
MEDICATION STATES WITH
REPOSITORY PROGRAMS MAY DONATED
. OVER TEN YEARS AGO SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BECAME THE FIRST COUNTY
THE STATE TO SET UP A REPOSITORY
PROGRAM THIS PROGRAM RECEIVES
UNUSED UNOPENED AND UNEXPIRED
MEDICATIONS FROM LICENSED
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES AND
DISPENSES IT NO COST TO PATIENTS
WITH A VALID PRESCRIPTION. THIS
INCREASES ACCESS ESPECIALLY FOR
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS AND
REDUCES. MEDICATION WASTE
DESPITE THE GOOD THESE PROGRAMS
DO COMMON OBSTACLES TO A PROGRAM
SUCCESS INCLUDE NUMBER ONE
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS FOR
PARTICIPATION. AND TO INCREASE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN FOR
AGENCIES AND FACILITIES AMONG
OTHERS. SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES A
PRICE OPERATIONAL FLEXIBILITY
AND ELIMINATES TASK BUT DO NOT
ENHANCE THE PROGRAM. LESSONS NSA
RECORDKEEPING REQUIREMENTS
REMOVED OVERLY STRINGENT
INVENTORY REQUIREMENTS IT WILL
HELP INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
ENTITIES. THAT OPERATE A
VOLUNTARY DRUG REPOSITORY
PROGRAM. THE BILL SPONSORED BY
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHERE THE
NO RICHARD OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU HAVE SOME
WITNESSES SO. TO TESTIFY YES WE
DO THAT WE'VE TWO WITNESSES A
GEORGE **** SERUM AND THEN WE
HAVE A- AT. ADDRESSING A
REPLACEMENT WITNESS WITNESS FOR
UNARY SAYING. WITNESSES PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DR KANSEI APARTMENT
ESPECIALISTA COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA HEALTH SYSTEM THANK AYE
SENATOR BAKER FOR ALL THREE
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX I
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON ROCKET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
SENATE BILL THIRTY FORTY SIX OF
THE CATTLE TO SPONSOR A BILL
THAT SEEKS TO LESSEN
ADMINISTRATIVE AND OPERATIONAL
BURDEN FACED BY PARTICIPATING
ENTITIES THAT OPERATE IN
MEDICATION. DONATION-
REDISTRIBUTION PROGRAM.
INTERESAR WILL INCREASE PROGRAM
IF. WITH THE TO. THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE PROGRAM IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND OTHER
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. HEALTH
SYSTEM IS A FULLY INTEGRATED
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM OUR SYSTEM
PROVIDES HIGH QUALITY
COMPASSIONATE IN A SENSE FOR
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL COUNTY
RESIDENTS AND OPERATE HEALTH
SERVICES TO BETTER HELP
BENEFICIARIES AND OTHER
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND TWENTY TIMES THE
COUNTY ESTABLISHED THE FIRST
DEDICATED THROUGHOUT PHARMACY IN
CALIFORNIA THE BETTER HEALTH
PHARMACY WHICH AIMS TO INCREASE
MEDICATION ACCESS FOR ALL
INSERTED. PATIENT WHO CANNOT OF
THE MEDICARE. EVERY NEWS OPENS
IDENTIFY MEDICAID. FROM LICENSED
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND THE
CENTER FOR DRUG THE PATIENT TO
HAVE A VALID PRESCRIPTION AT NO
COST. AUGUST FIFTEEN THIRTY AND
UP JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
BETTER HEALTH PHARMACY HAS TO
SPEND OVER ONE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND PRESCRIPTIONS AND SAVE
THE COUNTY APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
DRUG COSTS DESPITE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR PROGRAM IS
ONLY OFFERED IN ONE LOCATION AND
ACCOUNTING. BETTER HEALTH
PHARMACY OPERATE AS A STAND
ALONE FACILITY THAT ONLY
DISTRIBUTE DONATED
PHARMACEUTICALS IT HAS RECEIVED.
ADMINISTRATIVE AND OPERATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS LIMIT THE EXPANSION
OF THE PROGRAM TO THE COUNTY
OTHER PHARMACY LOCATIONS AND
DISCOURAGE MORE ENTITIES FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
LOW INTEREST CUMBERSOME BURDENS
AND AN OBSESSION OPERATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. SUCH AS OVERLY
STRINGENT. INVENTORY CONDITION.
WELL AT I'M NOT. AND ONEROUS
RECORD KEEPING THE CAR. SHOULD
OUR DRESSED- COUNTY COULD
ESTABLISH THE PROGRAM AT OTHER
COUNTY PHARMACY LOCATION. BUT
IMPROVE ACCESS TO MEDICATIONS
FOR LAUDABLE AND MEDICALLY
INDIGENT PATIENTS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIRPERSON ROTTEN THE MEMBERS
OF THE CANADIAN CENTRE BAKER I
AM TOWARDS LONG- ONE OF THE CO
FOUNDERS OF ZERO OR A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT WITH A MISSION TO HELP
CONNECT STATE UNUSED MEDICINE
WITHIN THE NEED FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS WE'VE ASSISTED
OPERATIONALIZE THE DRUG
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AROUND THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING THE PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA. AND LISTEN TO THAT
WE PROVIDED EXPERT ON OVER BILLS
REGULAR ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE DO
THE ETHICAL SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX CURRENT ALL PROGRAM
EXPANSION AND EFFICIENCY
INTERMITTENTLY IN THE MEETING
THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE PATIENTS-
ARE ABLE BE SERVED BECAUSE
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS PLEASE
UNNECESSARY AND CUMBERSOME
BURDEN HE'S LIKE SANTA CLARA
COUNTIES THAT HEALTH WORKERS THE
RECEIVING. DISPENSED DONATED
MEDICINE. WE ACCEPT WITH PROGRAM
IN OTHERS THAT HAVE SUCCESSFUL
DONATION PROGRAMS THAT IN ON THE
OWNER. REQUIRE AND CAL. BUT AT
THE SAME THE HIGH LEVELS OF
SAFETY. WE ARE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX BECAUSE THE
PLEDGES WILL INCREASE THE
THICKNESS OF THE PROGRAM
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF ENTITIES
ELECTING TO OPERATE THE PROGRAM
. REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF
PHARMACEUTICAL WASTE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY EXPAND ACCESS TO NO
COST MEDICATIONS FOR ELIGIBLE
PATIENTS SO THAT THEY CAN BE
HEALTHY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SIR.
HOWEVER FOR MANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT SURE PLEASE PROCEED
HI MISTER CHAIRMAN A MEMBER
MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY THE SPONSOR
OF THE MEASURE- JURAI VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IN THE
GALLERY. THING NINE LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ARVEST.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPTED INDIVIDUALS. WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX WE WILL
BEGIN. IF YOU WISH TO FIND
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
EACH PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT THIS
TIME. MR WE HAVE KNOWN IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU LET'S NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION FIRST.
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE OR VISITS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD. PLEASE
PROP THAT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH THEM. IF YOU WERE
SPEAKING OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
YOUR AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN
AND YOU IT IS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE SENATE CHAMBER IN MY
COLLEAGUES BUILDINGS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR LEYVA I SEE NO
MAKES UP SO. CENTER BAKER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS IN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OUT OF STAFF DIRECTORS. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
DO YOU PASSING RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH ROSS HI.
ROSS I MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ I
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA ID'S BATES
AYE BACKER BACKER HI DONNA
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE HER TADO. HER
TADO I'D JONES JONES I LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MIN. MAN HI NEWMAN.
NEWMAN AYE AYE CHAU ABODE. BUT
CHAU BUG EYED PEON CAN I. BILL
HAS THIRTEEN VOTES THE MATTER IS
OUT. FINALLY NUMBER SIXTEEN
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT SENATOR ARCHULETA WELCOME
YOU HAVE ONE BUILT PLEASE
PROCEED IN READING THANK YOU
MEASURE. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
CHAIRED THIS COMMITTEE STAFF
WERE WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA SEKOLAH THE
PSYCHOLOGY COULDN'T ASSOCIATION
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION WOULD
CREATE A NEW CATEGORY OF
REGISTERED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. A PSYCHOLOGICAL
TESTING TECHNICIANS
PSYCHOLOGICAL TESTING
TECHNICIANS TO MEET THE GROWING
NEEDS FOR CYCLE FOR
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND NEUROLOGICAL
SERVICES WHILE PROTECTING
CONSUMERS AND PAYERS THESE
TECHNICIANS WOULD OPERATE AS
SERVICING CENTERS FOR THE
PSYCHOLOGIST. ALTHOUGH YOU CAN'T
GO BUT NINETEEN IS PUT SO MUCH
PRESSURE IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
ACROSS THE BOARD THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT MORE PERSONNEL ARE
NEEDED TO CONTINUE WORKING AND
DOING THE JOB THEY DO THE DEMAND
FOR PSYCHOLOGICAL NEUROLOGICAL
SERVICES HAS BEEN. STEADILY
INCREASING UNFORTUNATELY STATE
STATUTE DOES NOT DEFINE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND IN THIS
IS THE ISSUE IN THE PRACTICE OF
PSYCHOLOGY AND CREATING
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS INTO AND TO
ACCESS THE PSYCHOLOGICAL TESTING
SERVICES THEY'RE OVERWHELMED
THEY NEED THE HELP. CALIFORNIA
IS ALSO EXPERIENCING A DIRE
SHORTAGE OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND GRAPPLING WITH
MEETING THIS NEED ACCORDING TO
THE HEALTH FOR CENTER AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO- IT'S ON TRACK TO LOSE
AT LEAST ELEVEN PERCENT. OF A
PSYCHOLOGIST IN THE NEXT DEFICIT
DECADE AND THIS IS TOP PRIORITY
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
EXISTENCE OF SUCH SCARCITY.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE RECEIVED
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURIES IN
AFFECTED BY PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISORDER AND REQUIRES SETTLEMENT
IS PART OF THE LEGAL EDUCATIONAL
PROCEEDINGS THEY RELY ON THE
WORK BY THESE LICENSED
PSYCHOLOGIST. THE PSYCHOLOGIST
REFORM BATTERIES OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL TESTS THAT CAN
VARY IN LENGTH DEPENDING ON THE
NATURE OF THE REFERRALS THEY CAN
RECEIVE IT'S UNUSUAL AND IT'S
NOT UNUSUAL FOR THEM TO REQUIRE
ONE TO TWO FULL DAYS OF FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION- OF ADMINISTERING
THE TEST. THE PSYCHOLOGICAL TEST
AND JUST FOR ONE SINGLE PATIENT
SOMETIMES TWO TO THREE DAYS THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW PSYCHOLOGICAL
TESTING TECHNICIANS TO
ADMINISTER AND SCORE
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND NEUROLOGICAL
TEST UNDER THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION OF THE LICENSE I
COLLEGES. THESE TECHNICIANS
WOULD BE REGISTERED AND WELL
READ REGULATED. BY THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY. THE USE OF IT TO
PRIMARY ALLOWS THE PSYCHIATRISTS
AND PSYCHOLOGISTS TO UTILIZE
THEIR TIME. MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
MORE PRODUCTIVELY FREEING THEM
PRINT OUT TO ENGAGE IN OTHER
INTERPRETATIONS AND- MEETING
WITH THE PATIENT ONE ON ONE
WHICH IS SO VITAL IN THE SERVICE
OF MENTAL HEALTH THAT REQUIRES
THEIR TIME. AND SKILL SET AS
SUCH AS PROVIDING THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL CYCLE THERAPY AND
REHAB TREATMENTS AND PLANNING
CYCLE EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
ENGAGING IN RESEARCH AND TO
REVISING PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATES. WITHOUT EMPLOYING
TECHNICIANS THE MAJORITY OF THE
PSYCHOLOGIST THE TIME IS SO
SPENT IN ADMINISTRATION- DUTIES
SCORE IN THE STANDARDIZED TEST
THE RESULTS FOR WHICH IS THE
PSYCHOLOGIST WORKING IN THE AREA
THAT CAN BE MORE. USEFUL WORKING
WITH PATIENTS OR SHOULD THAT
TIME BE USED- CHECKING TEST
WHICH THE TECHNICIAN CAN DO THIS
BOTTLENECK IN SERVICE IMPACTS
INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND UP AND
OTHER DISORDERS IT IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE GIVE- THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TO PROVISION. TO
TAKE PLACE THE USE OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL TESTING
TECHNICIANS HAS BEEN ON
NATIONALLY ESTABLISH STANDARD IN
PRACTICE IN THE FIELD FOR
DECADES BUT NOT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES SO TEST. OF
THE UTILIZATION TECHNICIANS IS
PARALLEL TO OTHER LOCAL
DIRECTORIAL LEVEL PROFESSIONALS
EMPLOYING TECHNICIANS SUCH AS
NEUROLOGISTS WITH THEIR EEGS AS
THE TECHNICIANS AND RADIOLOGISTS. WITH X. RAY TECHNICIANS.
PERSONNEL THAT. THE TOP PRIZE.
PERSONNEL. AT LEAST TWENTY THREE
STATES HAVE EXPLICIT LAWS
ENABLING THE USE OF TECHNICIANS
INCLUDING IN GOES ON ILLINOIS
NORTH CAROLINA ACROSS THE BOARD
THE LATEST IT NEW YORK AND
CONNECTICUT. THE VA THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
PERMITS TO USE A PSYCHOLOGICAL
TESTING TECHNICIAN SO IT IS
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT IT IS
NOW TIME TO OPEN THE DOOR. TO TO
OPEN THE DOOR THESE TECHNICIANS
BUT THE FIELD IS VAGUE AND WE
HAVE TO CLEAR THIS- SERVICE UP
HERE WITH US TODAY WE HAVE DR
WILLIAM MCCULLEN- WITH THE-
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION TO TESTIFY. AND
COLIN CHAU INSURERS- ALSO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION THE ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. AND I THANK
YOU FOR THE BY THE TIME- MISTER
CHAIR AND- ESPECIALLY THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME. FOR THE EFFORTS
AND I HOPE THEY'RE STILL WITH
US. WELL WE'LL CHECK THANK YOU
SEE. I LIKE TO MAKE BUT MULLIN
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YEAHI AM
CAN YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY PLEASE
PROCEED. RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DR WILLIAM MCMULLEN I'M A
PRACTICING BOARD CERTIFIED
NEUROPSYCHOLOGY CONCERNED
FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION TO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. WE'RE
SPONSORING SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES BY
ESTABLISHING A NEW REGISTRATION
CATEGORY UNDER THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY OR PSYCHOLOGICAL
TESTING TECHNICIAN. THE USE OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL TESTING
TECHNICIANS AND SERVICE THEIR
STANDARDS INTERNATIONALLY
ESTABLISHED STANDARDS AND IS
INCREASING USED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BY MYSELF WITH OBJECTING
TECHNICIAN IN MICHIGAN IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES AND
ADMINISTERED MANY TEST BATTERY.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE OF PRE
DOCTORAL INTERN AT THE CLEVELAND
VA MEDICAL CENTER I WAS ABLE TO
UTILIZE THE SERVICES OF THAT
CASTING TECHNICIAN AND ONE OF MY
ROTATIONS THERE AND THIS GREATLY
INCREASE THE EFFICIENCY AND
PRODUCTIVITY WILL PUSH HARD
WORK. WELL THERE YOU CAN TESTING
TECHNICIAN COMMON IN OTHER
STATES CALIFORNIA MARKET IS
FINALLY ON THIS ISSUE MEETING
THAT PSYCHOLOGIST IN CALIFORNIA
GENERALLY MUST ADMINISTER THEIR
OWN TSK EVEN THOSE THAT ARE
HIGHLY MANUAL LIGHT AND ROUTINE.
THIS CAN TAKE AS MANY HOURS
AFTER ONE TO TWO DAYS PER
PATIENT AND THAT IS FINE BUT I
COULD BE SPENDING INTERPRETING
PATH LEADING UP RESULT IN
PLANNING APPROPRIATE TREATMENTS
FOR THE PATIENTS UNLOCK
THOROUGHLY ESTABLISHING THE
AUTHORITY TO USE BIOLOGICAL
TESTING TECHNICIANS WHICH
CLEARLY NEEDED. THIS LAW WILL
NOT ONLY SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
ACCESS TO CARE IT WILL PROTECT
PATIENTS BY REQUIRING SPECIFIED
TRAINING AND PROVIDING FOR
REGULATION UNDER THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY. THE EIGHTY HOURS OF
TRAINING TWENTY FOUR ETHICS AND
CONFIDENTIALITY TWENTY FOR
OBSERVATION AND TESTING BY A
PSYCHOLOGIST AND FORTY FOUR
ADMINISTRATION AND SCORING IN
THE PRESENCE OF PSYCHOLOGISTS
WILL PREPARE THESE TECHNICIANS
FOR PRACTICE. THE BOARD IS IN
AGREEMENT THAT THIS NEW
REGISTRATION CATEGORY IS VIABLE
AND IS AMENABLE TO TAKING ON
OVERSIGHT. AFTER REGISTRATION.
THE NORTH ACROSS ARE UTILIZED
TESTING FREQUENT IN MY- INTO THE
BENEFITS OF BEING IN TO HAVE.
TECHNICIAN JUSTICE ME ALLOWING
ME OPERATE TO THE- UNDER MY
STILL OF. AND SEE MANY CASE THAN
I. DO CURRENTLY GREAT IS NOW IN
THE TO MY WHEN I THIS IS TRUE
THE MOST PART. AROUND THE
ABILITY TO USE THAT TO. THE
SICKNESS REDUCED TIME SPENDING
AND OF PATIENTS AT THE BE SEEN
BY ALLOW THEM TO INTO SCORING
POWERS BE DONE THE TECH. THE
CATEGORY ALSO IN. THE OF THE
STATE MENTAL MORE. ONE PER THOSE
UNDER. DEGREE IN. TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT AND MENTAL HEALTH
CARE. E. I BELIEVE BUT THIS BILL
IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO
EXPAND TIMELY ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO PROVIDE A
CLEAR LINE OF OVERSIGHT OF
CASTING TECHNICIANS THROUGH THE
BORDER TECHNOLOGY. AND WITH
FURTHER THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
PSYCHOLOGISTS TECHNICIANS AND
PATIENTS AND DELIVERING THIS
CARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR I
THINK- YOUR OTHER. MEMBERS
SIMPLY THERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
CORRECT. I'M HERE TO ANSWER I
CAN OF MINE AND LEGISLATION HERE
AS WELL OKAY. WELL LET'S MOVE TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
IN SUPPORT. SAYING NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT WE WILL BEGIN. HE PUSHED
ASIDE IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I'M SURE HAVE NO
ENTRY UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
IT'S ALL THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY. THING
OF SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE OF US IN
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH THEM. AND IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT THE
TIME.
SURE WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU LET'S BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER- FIRST- DOCTOR PAN
FOLLOWED BY A DOCTOR EGGMAN. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- SENATOR
ARCHULETA THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH THE- PURPOSE OF TH
BILL WHICH TO CLARIFY A IN IN
THE CODE THAT- THAT PSYCHOLOGIST
CAN USE TECHNICIANS TO HELP THEM
DO TESTING IS DEVELOPED A
BEAUTICIAN OF. THE LIVES MANY
PSYCHOLOGICAL TESTS AND WORK
WITH THE CAUCUS SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND A PSYCHOLOGIST
TO DO THOSE. I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU WHICH
IS- IN THE ANALYSIS IS THAT- IN
TERMS OF ACTUALLY HAVING TO
REGISTER THEM ALL WITH. THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY- IS NOTED
THERE MIGHT BE A OF. YOU KNOW.
HOW MUCH A ONEROUS BUT
BASICALLY. INCREASED EXPENSE AND
ALSO THE- ALSO PERHAPS EVEN
POTENTIALLY LIMITED NUMBER
PEOPLE MIGHT BE DOING THIS SO.
CAN YOU JUST ADDRESS WHAT IN
ALICE'S SAID ABOUT TERMS OF-
REGISTRATION AND- IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT. THESE
TECHNICIANS NEED TO BE
REGISTERED WITH THE BORDERS IT'S
SIMPLY ENOUGH THAT THEY HAVE A
PSYCHOLOGIST WHOSE CERTAIN YOU
KNOW SAYING THAT THEY'RE
SUPERVISING THEM AND THAT THAT
THERE OVERSEEING TO WORK AND
THAT THEY'RE DOING ACCEPTABLE
WORK. THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND
IT'S ALL UNDER SUPERVISION BUT
ALAS THE EXPERT TO- JOIN IN AND
ANSWERED THAT QUESTION FOR ME.
SURE AND HOLLINGER'S HERE AS
WELL TO BE MORE SPECIFIC ON
THAT- I THINK THE FEELING WAS
THAT- WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WORKING WITH PATIENTS- AND
CURRENTLY EVERYBODY WHO THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY OVERSEES THE
PSYCHOLOGISTS ARE ADDED TO THE
PORTAGE BY CALLING HERE HAVING
RESPONSIBILITY TO. ACT IN A
MAINTAINER LICENSOR AND COMPLY
WITH ALL REGULATIONS TO SOME
PERSON BUYING I'M IF WE'RE GOING
TO PUT IN THE- ANOTHER
PROFESSIONAL- DOWN THERE SHOULD
BE SOME OVERSIGHT BY THE BOARD
OF PSYCHOLOGY FOR EXACTLY HOW
THIS IS DONE I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. CPA HAS BEEN
WORKING AT WORKING THROUGH- I
DON'T THINK IT WOULD NEED A
LOOKS LIKE A VERY ONEROUS
PROCESS IT LOOKS LIKE AND
THERE'S A CERTAIN AMOUNT. ALL
ETHICS AND CONFIDENTIALITY
EDUCATION IT NEEDS TO BE DONE
WHICH I THINK IS ONLY ARE. YOU
KNOW IN KEEPING WITH WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE YOU ARE WHERE
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE WORKING AS
PATIENTS ARE YOU KNOW VERY WELL
OUR PRODUCT OF THE FACT THAT
THEY NEED TO MAINTAIN
CONFIDENTIALITY AND SO ON. AND
THE OVERSIGHT- THE THEY'RE
TRYING TO KIND OF. TO WIN THE
TO- MAKE HOURS- TOOLS HOUR THE
PROVISION OF. PASS INCLUDING- OF
BURKE. FOR CYCLE ARE- I THINK
ARE THINGS THAT ARE. AND WILL BE
RE. CONNECTIONS IS A TO MINISTER
THE STAFF WHEN I WAS- A
PSYCHOLOGY TESTING. AND IN
MICHIGAN I MEAN I BEEN. I'M
GOING TO COURTS WERE I HAVE I
WAS ALREADY PROJECTS. OFFER
CLINICAL. EXTERNAL AND A LOT THE
TOP ARE LEARNED ADDITIONAL
TESTING PRACTICE AND MICE- AND
SO THIS- RED. ARE JUST PUTTING
ARE KIND OF YOUR TO COLLEGE YOU
NEED TO ACTUALLY LEARN HOW TO DO
THAT. THE BATON TO YOU CAN DO.
ACCURATELY AND RETURN WITH PETER
LEE EXACTLY WANT TO SPECIFIC.
FOR EACH OF THE NINE AND I'M
SORRY I DON'T IT'S AN ALL
PROCESS. APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER
AGAIN IT'S TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
MOVING FORWARD- I DID EIGHT NO
THAT. WE DO SUNSET RE AND SO
FORTH THE WORK ON OVER BORE. AND
WHETHER THERE'S AN ASSESSOR FOR.
THE THAT TECHNO THEY HAVE TO. DO
MORE REGISTRY SO THINK THE
ISSUES MORE THE BURDEN OF WORK
ON TO THE BOARD AND NECESSITY OF
THAT. FISHER QUA. OF WAS FOR A
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO BE SUPER. BY
LICENSED. AS WELL SO BUT THAT
YOU CAN CONTINUE WORKING ON
THAT'S REALLY SUPPORT THE BILL
WE TRYING TO DO AND THE- VOTING
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR GRANT. THEY'RE EGGMAN.
BUT THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO
CENTER ACTUALLY BRING THIS
FORWARD. AND I GUESS MY
QUESTIONS WERE KIND OF ON THAT
SAME LINE. IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS FUNCTION. BUT
WE'RE GOING TO DO NOW IS PUT
SOME REQUIREMENTS ON THEM. TO
GET REGISTERED TO DO THIS
FUNCTION. AND SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IF THERE'S A LACK
OF. WORK FORCE IS INCREASING-
THE REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS.
WILL THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF FOLKS WE
HAVE HELPING OUT OR DECREASE IT
AND- MY FIRST QUESTION A FEW
QUESTIONS YEAH I THINK IT WILL
INCREASE. AND WHAT IT IS IT IN
STATUTE THAT IT IS NOT
EXPLICITLY SHOWN HOW THE
TECHNICIAN CAN PERFORM. OR EVEN
IF THEY CAN. BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT IT'S NOT LAW IN SOME OF THE
OTHER STATES WE KNOW THERE IT IS
LAW IN CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT
EXPLICIT. THIS JUST BRINGS IT UP
THIS SHOWS THAT USE A
PSYCHOLOGIST YOU'VE BEEN IN THAT
FIELD. YOU CAN HIRE YOUR
TECHNICIAN TRAINING GUIDE. AND
AS THEY GET CERTIFIED BY THE
ASSOCIATION THEY COULD GO
FORWARD WHAT THAT'S GOING TO DO
IS OPEN UP DOORS FOR THOSE THAT
ARE IN SCHOOL RIGHT NOW AND IN
THE FUTURE. WHO HAVE BEEN
STUDIED PSYCHOLOGY AND AT THE
MASTERS AND SO ON TO ENTER THE
FIELD AND MAYBE NOT BE THE
THERAPIST 1100% BUT- OBVIOUSLY
WOULD BE THE GUIDE THE EIGHT AND
SO ON. AND I I'D BE OUT QUITE
HONESTLY I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT
THE TESTING WOULD GO ON SO LONG.
WHERE THAT PSYCHOLOGIST COULD BE
ALREADY WORKING WITH THE PATIENT
BUT THERE SPENDING SO MUCH TIME
REVIEWING AND- LOOKING AT THE
DOCUMENTS. WHERE THAT TECHNICIAN
COULD HAVE JUST SAT THERE AND
INTERVIEWED QUESTION AFTER
QUESTION AFTER QUESTION AND THEN
TURNED OVER THE RESULTS TO BE
ANALYZED AND THEN IN TURN. THE
PSYCHOLOGIST MEET ONE ON ONE
WITH THE PATIENT AND WHERE THEY
ARE DOING ONE OR TWO A DAY NOW
THAT WOULD IT GO BUT OPEN UP
MORE. IN BECAUSE THE VA IS
ALREADY DOING THIS ISSUE TELLS
ME THAT THERE'S ROOM FOR MORE
AND THIS WILL JUST CLEAR UP
THAT. VAGUENESS ABOUT IT BEING
LEGALLY. ABLE TO BE DONE IN
CALIFORNIA. OKAY N. AND MAYBE TO
THE TO THE WITNESS AS WELL BUT
THERE ARE ALREADY PEOPLE
PERFORMING THIS FUNCTION AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. BUT THE LAW IS
SILENT ON IT SO NOW WE'RE GONNA.
WE'RE GONNA. WE'RE GONNA CREATE
A LAW AND THEREBY ALSO CREATE
THE SUPERVISION AND- THE
REGISTRATION AND THE LICENSE IF
YOU WILL TO REGISTRATION. AND
THEN WHO'S IN CHARGE IS THAT THE
IS THE PSYCHOLOGIST IN IN CHARGE
OF. IS IT A ONE TIME
REGISTRATION IS IT ONGOING IS
THERE. THE C. E. IZARD A
GRADUATION OR IS IT JUST A
REGISTRATION AND THEN THAT
PERSON IS READY TO GO AND HOW IS
THAT DIFFERENT NOW. DESPITE JUST
BEING REGISTERED. AND ALL THAT
THE EXPERT- ENSURE THAT ONE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER CALLS WERE AS- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION SO THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING ON
WITH THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY ON
TO THE FIRST PART YOUR QUESTION
THAT'S A GREAT POINT- WE DON'T
ACTUALLY TRACK WHO IS DOING THIS
WORK RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OUR-
CHIEF- CHIEF ORGANIZATION THAT.
DEALS WITH OUR OVERSIGHT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY TRACKED INFORMATION WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING MORE THAN
ANECDOTAL WE KNOW. THAT SOME VA
CLINICS USE THEM. AND THERE IS
SOME YEARS IN ACADEMIC SETTINGS
BUT AS TERMS OF WIDESPREAD USE
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT TO BE THE
CASE- I AS THE SECOND POINT WE
ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY ON
DEVELOPING AMENDMENTS THAT WE
LOOK ON TAKING AS THE BILL
MOVES. THAT WOULD STREAMLINE THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION PROCESS IN
LINE WHAT WE DO FOR LICENSEES.
ARE CREATING AN ANNUAL
REGISTRATION PROCESS INCLUDING-
INTAKE FORMS FOR LIFE SCANNED
AND OTHER REQUIREMENTS MAKE OF
LICENSEES- BUT ALSO ESTABLISHING
A PROCESS BY WHICH INDIVIDUALS
WHO OVERSEEING- ADEQUATE
TRAINING AND EDUCATION AND OTHER
STATES- MAY HAVE AN INTAKE
PROCESS SO THEY CAN ALSO
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA WE ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO TAKING.
AMENDMENTS WORKING WITH THE
BOARD PSYCHOLOGY AND OBVIOUSLY
WITH COMMITTEE WHO HAS DONE A
GREAT WORK ON THIS BILL SO FAR.
SO THAT ONCE WE DO GET FOLKS IN
THE HOPPER. WHO WILL BE ABLE TO
GET THOSE TECHNICIANS. ON THE
JOB TRAINING AS PART OF THEIR
KERR- IS PART OF THEIR EIGHTY
HOURS OF REQUIRED TRAINING
PROCESSES. IT THE CHAIR I CAN
ASK SO IT IN THE REQUIREMENTS IS
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IT DOESN'T
IT DOESN'T SPECIFY ANY. TYPE OF
BACHELORS. YES IT DOES SO IN THE
BILL AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER THE BILL.
REQUIRES AT LEAST A BACHELOR'S
IN PSYCHOLOGY OR RELATED FIELD
SO OBVIOUSLY THAT WOULD BE IN
LINE WITH THE SOCIAL WORK
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPY- BUT
IT DOES REQUIRE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN A- MENTAL HEALTH
RELATED- DEGREE. IT CAN ALSO BE
A MASTERS AS WELL THAT'S IN THE
STATUTE BUT AT LEAST A MINIMUM
OF BACHELOR'S DEGREE. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
. WELL LET ME ASK A COUPLE I'M
I'M A LITTLE UNCLEAR DID I HEAR
YOU TO SAY THAT WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY TESTING TAX ARE UP
THERE. IN CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGISTS
OFFICES. ASSISTING THE CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST. AT MISS HERE I'M
NOT AWARE THAT THERE'S ANY THAT
WILL ADMIT TO THAT FACT BUT I'LL
LET AGAIN THE EXPERT TO ANSWER
THAT WHOSE- AS A PULSE ON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- COLLINS WORSE
AGAIN SO NONE OF OUR MEMBERS-
WHEN WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS OVER
SEVERAL YEARS ON THIS ITEM
INTERNALLY- WE DON'T KNOW OF
ANYONE THAT ACTUALLY USES
TECHNICIANS BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD
PRETTY CLEAR DIRECTION FROM A
REGULATORY BOARD THAT. THIS
PRACTICE IS NOT ALLOWED UNDER
LAW- BUT THAT'S NOT THAT'S
CONTRARY TO THE ANALYSIS YOU
UNDERSTAND WELL I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THE ANALYSIS TAKE HOWEVER I WILL
SAY THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY AND
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION. HAVE BEEN PRETTY
CLEAR WITH OUR MEMBERSHIP- THAT
THE USAGE OF THESE TECHNICIANS
IS WE DON'T SEE AS BEING
PERMITTED UNDER THE LAW- I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE ARE OTHERS WHO DO
USED TECHNICIANS- IF THAT
INFORMATION IS OUT THERE IT'S
ANECDOTAL- BUT THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY NOR CPA COLLECT ANY
INFORMATION OTHER USE
TECHNICIANS. WITH THE FACT THAT
YOU DON'T COLLECTED DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEY'RE NOT IN USE CORRECT.
IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE CENTER I
CAN'T SPEAK TO ALL THE
PRACTICING PSYCHOLOGISTS HOWEVER
I WILL SAY THE FOLKS IN OUR
NEUROPSYCHOLOGY DIVISION OF
WHICH- DOCUMENT MULLIN IS A
MEMBER- WE DO NOT KNOW OF ANYONE
WHO IS ACTIVELY. THESE FOLKS
WITHIN THE PRACTICE. WITHIN THE
LAST AT LEAST HALF DECADE. SO
WITH RESPECT TRANSACTION
EDUCATION. GO AHEAD PLEASE
STEPANEK FALLING APART I JUST
WANTED TO JUMP IN THE YOU KNOW
CONTRAST THIS WITH HOW THINGS IN
OTHER STATES IF IT WAS IF I AND
MY COLLEAGUES VIEWED US AS BEING
ACCEPTABLE FROM THE BY THE BOARD
AND LEGAL- I WOULD ALREADY BE
USING ONE- WHEN I WAS IN ANOTHER
STATE I WAS USING ONE IT MAKES
THE PRACTICE SO MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT BUT IT'S HIGHLY
DESIRABLE THAT WE COULD USE ONE.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA IT'S- IT'S
CLEAR THAT- AT LEAST THE-PERCEPTION ON WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TOLD BY REPORTERS THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT- IT IS- IS TO BE
DONE IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
WHY WE NEED TO CLARIFICATION ON.
IT WILL JUST NEED TO SCALE
HERE'S MY HERE'S MY PROBLEM I
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH USING THE
LICENSE REGISTRATION.
RECOGNITION PROCESS. WHERE IT'S
NOT AB REQUIRE BECAUSE IS THE
ANALYSIS OF DATA. AND I FOR
BELIEVE. THESE RULES THAT WE PUT
IN PLACE- CAN SERVE AS A BARRIER
TO EMPLOYMENT AND THEY'RE A
BARRIER TO EMPLOYMENT. VERY MUCH
FOR THE FOR THE PIECES IN
PORTIONS OF THE POPULATION THAT
WE OFTEN CARED THE MOST AND
FIGHT THE MOST FOR. HERE IN THIS
FLOOR THE DISADVANTAGED AND
THOSE WHO COME. FROM COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. AND SO I REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT THESE REQUIREMENTS IN
THESE REQUESTS FOR REGISTRATION
OR RECOGNITION. OF VERY
SERIOUSLY FOR EXAMPLE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE WAS THAT YOU ALL ARE
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGISTS AND- IN
AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WAS
THAT VALIDATED IN SOME WAY BY A
STUDY. IN OTHER WORDS WHAT TASKS
ARE THESE TESTING TAX GOING TO
PERFORM. THAT WOULD REQUIRE
NECESSARILY A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN PSYCHOLOGY AND IS IT A DEGREE
IN SOCIAL PSYCHOLOGY IS IT A
DEGREE AND- IN THE OTHER
DISCIPLINES WITHIN THE
PSYCHOLOGY FIELD AND IF SO WHY.
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN GO AHEAD-
DOCUMENT MULLIN. I WOULD SAY
THAT AND THE REASON THAT TAX IN
THERE IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
SORT OF STANDARD ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THEN IT'S BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY OUR PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
NATIONAL ECONOMY AND KNOWS THE
COLLEGES THAT- ACTUALLY
TECHNICIANS ARE HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND BE TRAINED
UP BY THE PSYCHOLOGY I THINK
YOU'RE A STRAPLESS THING- YOU
KNOW SENATE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS AND- YOU KNOW I
DON'T SEE IT. AS A BARRIER TO
OUR- HI THIS IS THE BILL
ACTUALLY ON- LIKE TO THE NUMBER
OF JOBS IN. HEALTH BECAUSE IT'LL
BE MORE PEOPLE THIS THIS POINT.
IF THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
USING TACTIC TESTING TECHNICIANS
ADDITION A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF WHAT WILL BE AND WHAT WILL
END UP HAPPENING IF- IF AND
WHEN. THE BILL PASSES AND LOOKED
IN THE STATUS OF TESTING
TECHNICIANS IS CLARIFIED BECAUSE
WITH DISAPPOINTING. YOU KNOW I
WOULD. MENTION CLARIFIED I WOULD
DEFINITELY- YOU KNOW ADVERTISED.
TO HIRE IS TESTING TECHNICIAN I
WOULD GET FROM MY EMPLOYER TO DO
SO I'M AND I THINK A LOT OF
PLACES WHERE THERE'S JUST A MUCH
MORE EFFICIENT WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS AND SO I THINK IT WOULD
GENERALLY INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. DOING THIS WORK WELL YOU
KNOW IN THE EMPLOYMENT FIELD.
FIFTY PRETTY CAREFUL ABOUT HOW
WE SET QUALIFICATIONS BECAUSE IF
YOU SET THE QUALIFICATION OF A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FOR EXAMPLE.
WITHOUT DIRECTLY TYING IT TO THE
SKILLS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO DO
THE JOB. THAT'S A PROBLEM
BECAUSE AT LEAST HISTORICALLY IT
TENDS TO DISCRIMINATE. AGAINST
MINORITIES AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND THAT'S WHY AS MIKE. WITH
RESPECT TO YOUR BROTHER DEGREE
REQUIRED. HAVE YOU HAD ANY
COMPLY WITH AS I'M ASSUME SOME
AROUND SOME IS BEEN ASSISTING A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST SOMEWHERE
IN CONDUCTING TESTS NOT
INTERPRETING THEM BUT CONDUCTING
THEM. HAVE THERE BEEN ANY
COMPLAINTS ANY COMPLAINTS OF
HARM ADDRESSED TO THE BOARD AS A
RESULT OF A TESTING TAX
SOMEWHERE. OR WHATEVER WE WANT
TO CALL IT AN INTERN OR A
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSISTANT-
CONDUCTING THESE TESTS WHERE.
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT WOULD BE
CALLED FOR. I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE-
IN CONVERSATION FOR PSYCHOLOGY
NOT RECEIVED ANY OF THAT
INFORMATION. WELL THEN I HAVE
ANOTHER ONE AND I'LL TY TO WRAP
IT UP- WHAT HAPPENS IF YOUR
WRONG. AND THERE ARE TESTING
TECHS OUT THERE. IN THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ASSISTING.
PSYCHOLOGIST IN THE PERFORMANCE
OF THEIR DUTY TO MAKE THEIR WORK
DAY MORE EFFICIENT AND I'M-
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT. WHO
DON'T MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR GRADUATE
DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY. EIGHTY
HOURS OF TRAINING AND ON AND ON
BUT HAVE BEEN PERFORMING THE
DUTIES. OF THEIR POSITION FOR
TEN FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEARS. IS
THERE SOME PROVISION IN THIS.
BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO BECOME.
GRANDFATHERED SO THEY ARE
GRANDFATHERED WHATEVER THE
PROPER TERM IS THESE DAYS SO
THAT THEY COULD CONTINUE TO
PERFORM THEIR- THEIR JOBS
WITHOUT. UNDUE INTERFERENCE WITH
THEIR ABILITY TO GENERATE A WAGE
. YES THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
MISTER CHAIR- PART OF THE WHAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ON THIS BILL
AS IT MOVES IS WORKING WITH ALL
OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE CONTINUUM OF HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY IN MENTAL HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY TO FIND OUT IF THERE
ARE THOSE INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE-
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON- EXTERNAL
MESSAGING TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
THOSE FOLKS ARE IN PRACTICE THEY
CAN REACH OUT TO US. WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY AMENABLE TO WORKING
ON TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD GRANDFATHER IN INDIVIDUALS
WITH A CERTAIN BASE LEVEL OF
EDUCATION AND TRAINING OR AS-
MAKES SENSE WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF THESE NATIONAL STANDARDS- BUT
AS YET WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM
ANY INDIVIDUAL THAT WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM PRACTICING. BY
THE INTRODUCTION AND PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL I STILL THINK YOU NEED
YOU MAY NEED TO TAKE A LOOK. AT
THE STANDARDS THAT YOU PLUGGED
INTO THE BILL IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TO ARTICULATE WHY YOU'VE PICKED.
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE WHY YOU'VE
PICKED A CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOURS
AND INSTEAD OF SIMPLY INCLUDED
THEM BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT SOME
OTHER STATE DID I THINK. WE
PROBABLY. MAYBE MORE EXACTING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
WAY WE SET OUR STANDARDS. I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL-
OF WE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. AS HE MOVES A BILL
FORWARD I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT STRANDING.
WORKERS ANYWHERE BY SETTING NEW
STANDARDS AND NOT PROVIDING. FOR
A PATHWAY WERE OFFERING UP FOR
THOSE WORKERS TO. CONTINUE TO DO
WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING FOR
WHATEVER PERIOD OF TIME THEY'VE
BEEN DOING IT. SENATOR MELENDEZ
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I JUST WANT TO. GO
BACK TO SOMETHING THAT WAS JUST
SAID WITH RESPECT TO-
GRANDFATHERING IN. THOSE WHO MAY
ALREADY BE DOING THIS- TYPE OF
WORK YOU SAID THAT. YOU ARE WORD
I MEAN A BOWL TO MAKING SOME
AMENDMENTS PERHAPS DOWN THE ROAD
PROVIDED THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAD THE MINIMUM EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS WHICH TO ME SAYS
THE BACHELOR'S DEGREE SO THEN
THEY WOULDN'T BE GRANDFATHERED
IN UNLESS. THEY YOU KNOW IT'S
KIND OF THERE'D THEIR STOCK CAN
YOU JUST GO BACK TO THAT PLEASE
CERTAINLY SO I WHEN I WAS TRYING
TO REFERENCE IS NOT NECESSARILY
A MINIMUM OF BACHELOR'S DEGREE
BUT- TO ESTABLISH SOME MINIMUM
STANDARD FOR FOLKS WHO MAY BE
DOING THIS WORK SOMEWHERE. OUT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
DETERMINE WHAT AN APPROPRIATE
MINIMUM STANDARD WOULD BE
ALONGSIDE OR LIKE YOU- REGULATOR
AND THE COMMITTEES OF BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE SO I
WASN'T ATTEMPTING TO. MAKE A
STATEMENT THAT IT HAD TO BE OUR
MINIMUM STANDARDS BUT IF THEY
ARE OUT THERE PRACTICING WE
WOULD NEED TO ESTABLISH SOME
MINIMUM FROM GRANDFATHER OKAY
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT
BECAUSE I'M- I FEEL FAIRLY
CONFIDENT THAT WE DO HAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ALREADY
PERFORMING. THESE TASKS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD HATE TO.
BE PARTY TO A BILL THAT.
ESSENTIALLY CUTS THEM OUT OF
EMPLOYMENT UNLESS THEY GO BACK
TO SCHOOL FOR THEIR- BACHELORS
OR WHATEVER IT IS DETERMINED IS
NECESSARY FOR THIS WORK SAID
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
CERVANTES COLLEAGUES ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
YOU KNOW MIKE'S UP THOSE SEARCH
A LOT OF FLOOR'S YOURS
REGIONALLY COMMISSION CHAIRED
AND THANK YOU FOR INDULGING US
IN AND YOUR PATIENCE AND TIME- I
WILL BE WORKING WITH YOU IN YOUR
IN YOUR STAFF- ALONG WITH THE
AUTHORS AND- I'M SORRY THE- THE
OF THE CO AUTHORS AS WE ALL COME
TOGETHER THERE'S A DIRE NEED OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS NO
DOUBT. IF THIS WILL OPEN UP SOME
DOORS WILL BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
AND- TAKING SOME AMENDMENTS-
THAT SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP I THINK WILL WILL
MAKE IT SUCCESSFUL AT THE END
AND SO I WITH THAT ORIGINAL
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTERS LOAD
RIVER MOTION ON SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. CENTER
TYLER MAKES MOVES THE BILL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM STAFF DIRECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROSS HI ROSS I MELENDEZ. WINDOWS
I ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA IBEATS
BATES AYE BAKER BAKER AYE DODD
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE HER TADO HER
TADO I'D JONES LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MAN MAN I AM NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE
AYE CHOI BOGUE. AND SHOWBOAT IPN
AND I BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES IT
IS A ROLES CLOSED. I'M STEP
DIRECTOR LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE- BILLS THAT ARE STILL OPEN.
MEMBERS WILL GO BACK THROUGH THE
FILE ON THE ORDER THAT WE TOOK
SOME MEASURES UP SOFT COAL THE
BILL NUMBER IN THE CURRENT
EVENTS- FILE ITEM ONE. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT TO TWO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO BEAT. BATES NO DODD
HER TADO HER TADO I. MODE IS
NINE TO FOR THE BILL IS A. FILE
ITEM THREE SB NINE ONE NINE
CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO ZERO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ I BEAT. EIGHT
I EGGMAN. HER TADO HER TADO II
THE BILL HAS THIRTEEN VOTES THE
BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM FOR SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE
TEN TWO ZERO MELENDEZ. MULLIN
DOES HI PLEASE. BATES I EGGMAN.
HER TADO HER TADO II WILLIS
THIRTEEN VOTES THE BILL IS A.
FILE ITEM SEVEN SB TEN SIXTY
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE NINE TWO
ZERO. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO BEAT. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE HER TADO HER
TADO I'D JONES. THE VOTE IS
ELEVEN TO ONE THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM EIGHT SB ELEVEN FORTY
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE NINE TWO ZERO
MELENDEZ. I'M IT FILE ITEM EIGHT
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
BY MR LAYERED THE CURRENT VOTE
IS. NINE TWO ZERO MELENDEZ BAIT. B. FIVE FACTOR BAKER I EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO. HER TADO I
. VOTE IS THIRTEEN ZERO MEASURES
OUT. FILE ITEM TWELVE S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX. CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN TO THREE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
NO ARCHULETA. EGGMAN HER TADO.
EGGMAN I. SURE IT'S M. WE'RE
VOTING ON FILE ITEM TWELVE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX BY
MISTER WINNER. EGGMAN EGGMAN I'D. HER VOTERS EIGHT THREE THE
MEASURE IS OUT. FILE IN FOURTEEN
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO ONE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO EGGMAN. HER
TADO. HER TADO I'D JONES NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE UNTIL A BOGEY. A
TURBO NO. BOAT IS NINE TO THREE
THE MEASURE IS A. S. B. NINE
EIGHTY SIX THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TWELVE TWO ZERO MELENDEZ. THIS
IS FILE ITEM- SIX SB NINE EIGHTY
SIX. BY MR UMBERG. AND MISTER
PORTANTINO. MELENDEZ FIVE HER
TADO. HER TADO HI BOAT IS
FOURTEEN ZERO MEASURES OUT.
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TWELVE TWO ZERO
. WHICH ONE IS MELENDEZ MULLIN
DOES I HER TADO. HER TADO I'D.
VOTERS FOURTEEN ZERO MEASURES
OUT. SENATE BILL ELEVEN SIXTEEN
THE CURRENT LOTUS TEN TWO ZERO
MELENDEZ. B. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SENATE BILL. ELEVEN
SIXTEEN. THE SENATOR PORTANTINO
. MELENDEZ B. JONES. A SHOW
ABOUT. CALTON ZERO MEASURES OUT. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
CURRENT VOTE I THINK WE'RE DONE. HOLD ON. YEAH.
THANK YOU ALL. THANKS TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE HAVE NOW
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IS ADJOURNED.